Okay, the board will convene and the first thing we'll do is salute the flag.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic for which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
The first thing I must do is swear in our new board member.
So if you'll come up, please, and you can then fully participate in the meeting.
Raise your right hand.
So I, Karen Valdez, do solemnly swear that I will support and defend the Constitution of the United States
That I will support and defend the Constitution of the United States.
Against all enemies, foreign and domestic.
That I will bear true faith and allegiance.
To the Constitution of the United States.
And the Constitution of the State of California.
That I take this obligation freely.
without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion, and that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties upon which I am about to enter.
Thank you.
I'll make some comments later, but right now we'll have to adjourn the room because we're going to go into a closed session.
And so the board will be adjourning to the closed session to discuss or take action on the MSC case as noticed on the meeting agenda.
Okay, the board will reconvene.
I want to announce that in closed session, the board discussed or took action on the following case as noticed on the meeting agenda.
That was the MSC case, the only case that we discussed.
So now we're ready for the report of the superintendent and then I will have the opening announcements about the structure of our meeting.
Well, thank you, President Kirst and board members.
A delightful day and certainly to welcome Karen Valdez and her whole family seems steeped in education and aspiring to make a difference in education.
So again, congratulations and welcome aboard.
And spring, ready to spring to action.
I wanted to share a couple of the highlights from the last time we met and one of those was we actually had a spring refresh in which 700 of our employees in the building participated.
It was a professional development opportunity.
We had 2,100 hours of professional development.
Workshops conducted by our own staff, peer-to-peer learning, capacity expanding.
And it was focused not only on policy but on personal health, how to focus, how to stay healthy and stay productive and have meaning going forward.
So it was a building-wide effort the first time in the 15 years of this building that we then had a big lunch for
the 700 and again after 2,100 hours of professional development, we did a spring clean.
We actually jettisoned boxes and boxes and we cleaned and cleaned out clutter and staff had just a free time to do what often never gets done.
And so we feel a lot lighter for that.
I want to thank Brianna Mullen on my staff for helping organize that great opportunity.
High school graduation rates.
I met with the wonderful students and teachers and staff and parents, community members at Woodland High School to make an announcement about our progress on graduation rates.
For the seventh year in a row, high school graduation rates went up in California.
Latinos, African-Americans, English learners, foster youth, special education students, all student groups did better.
Statewide, the class of 2016 reached an overall all-time record of 83.2%, the highest ever.
And the state's rate has increased totally about 8.5 percentage points since the class of 2010 posted a 75% rate of graduation.
Still, we know
We know we must keep working hard to narrow the pernicious and persistent achievement gap and bring about more equitable success around the state for all students.
There was a special note of progress for African American students.
The graduation rate reached a record high of 73 percent, up nearly three percentage points from the year before and up 12 percentage points since 2010.
And for Hispanic and Latino students, the graduation rate climbed to a record high of 80%, up a point and a half from the previous year, and also up 12 percentage points since 2010.
We have different understandings of what's making the difference and causing this, and I think it's a focused effort at all levels.
We continue to thank the California voters for supplying some money and keeping a more steady stream, stabilized funding.
And we're seeing smaller class sizes, local control funding formula where priorities are set locally, CTE, a renaissance and comeback of CTE, and the arts.
So I think these things are all contributing.
So all in all, a great team effort with keen focus and we need to know, we need to make further progress.
Another inspiring opportunity occurred with our Gold Ribbon Awards.
I'll invite you to the last three ceremonies coming up.
But we're honored to join students and parents and teachers and administrators at the Gold Ribbon Schools Award Ceremonies.
We are honoring 275 California middle schools and high schools, which are leading the way in embracing our new rigorous academic standards.
These schools have made great gains in implementing the performance standards and goals set by this board.
and achieved outstanding focus in several areas, arts, creative arts, civics, environmental literacy, engineering and career pathways in STEM.
We also heard from two of our Teachers of the Year who are just fabulous and fantastic and I'd like to invite them to come and present to the board at some point.
Their insight and their passion and their personal commitment are really inspiring.
Megan Groth, who made it to fourth in the nation as a Teacher of the Year this year, fourth in the nation, is a wonderful teacher from San Diego.
And Jennifer Chen, they did a great job.
Update on Safe Haven Schools.
Last week I had the privilege of visiting with students, parents, teachers, and community members at New Highland Academy in Oakland.
And in partnership with the California Teachers Association, the Oakland Education Association, we celebrated May 1st as Schools are for Everyone, Safe for Everyone.
A day to show that all students and parents are welcome regardless of immigration status.
Scores of walks were held around the state on May 1st to support our students and their families and to protest against the misguided immigration policies of President Trump and his administration.
As you know, I've asked school districts to declare themselves safe havens.
To date, more than 60 districts have done that, representing over 2 million students in the state now in schools that have the safe haven specific focus to protect their personal information, to again make them feel welcome, and to not have our schools becoming arms of ICE.
And dozens of other districts have adopted similar resolutions, but not verbatim the safe haven, but it's all in the same direction of protecting our students.
Two more things to mention, I had the privilege of regularly I meet with the smaller rural counties which have very unique
challenges as board members know who visited these counties, Mariposa County, Amador and Calaveras.
For instance, the transportation challenge in Mariposa County, the bus fleet that goes out around the county every day travels a distance of Sacramento to Akron, Ohio.
in terms of the number of miles they cover with picking up the children, sometimes bus rides of 45 minutes to over an hour.
So we met regularly here in the building with them and then I went and personally visited those three counties.
We did take time out and did a hike in Yosemite in Mariposa County.
It was wonderful, just fabulous waterfalls, grand majestic beauty of California.
On the bus ride after a tour with a great teacher who knows the geology and natural history on the shuttle bus, I was surprised thinking to get away for just a little bit from all the acronyms and intensity of our work.
I was surprised that the driver of the shuttle bus said LCAP.
Why LCAP right out here in the middle of all this wilderness?
There is a school on the floor of Yosemite for the families.
It was El Capitan.
It was the stop for El Capitan.
So, anyway.
I still had acronyms on the brain.
I couldn't quite shake it.
Anyway, finally, to end with some good news, actually great news.
As we count down the final weeks of this school year, as the SBAC and CAF testing proceed with all green lights, super statewide team effort, we broke all records yesterday on the number of students taking the test simultaneously, 498,000.
students.
That is all-time, maybe Guinness Book of World Records.
So, we'll ask, you know, we'll be able to congratulate directly Michelle Center and Kerry Gashley's terrific team when they make their presentations later today.
But can you imagine that?
One moment.
Half a million students online and the purchasing of equipment, the training, the diligence.
It's been all green lights, knock on wood.
So, spring forward.
Thank you, Mr. President, board members.
Thank you for that uplifting report.
So I'm going to give a little bit of background on our new member so we understand her wonderful and broad background in curriculum, assessment, teaching, and many other aspects of school administration.
So Karen Valdez has been Assistant Superintendent of Curriculum and Instruction for the Menifee Union School District since 2006.
and prior to that she was a regional director for the Riverside County Office of Education where she coordinated instructional support.
She's also served as a mentor teacher and master teacher in districts such as Temecula Unified, Lenox Elementary, Norwalk La Mirada Unified,
in Lenox Elementary.
Karen was president of the Association of California Administrators Region 19, and she's been a member of our CPAG, our Committee for Professional Advice that we use.
So she already has a good head start on some of our issues and how we work.
We look forward to you and working with you.
And a lot of what this board does is try and connect state policy to improving classroom instruction.
And you certainly have that kind of a background.
So, changes on our agenda.
Waiver item 20 was pulled at the request of Los Angeles County.
We have Spanish interpreter services for the relevant items.
We have six public hearings, items 16 through 21.
We have an agenda item with an addendum that is attachment 4 to item 13.
We have consent and waiver items that we'll be hearing.
The consent items are items 4 through 13.
And the waiver consent items are Waiver 1 through Waiver 19.
So if you wish to remove as a board member any item, please let Karen and staff Walters know by today at 1.
We have electronic folders for those of you to look at our letters.
And we understand the public can now see these as well.
So this is really an important thing to enhance public understanding because they can access the letters we receive about our agenda.
The meeting can be accessed through the electronic agenda.
Speakers, please sign in at the table just outside the room and specify what item you want to speak on.
And we'll allow one minute for all items on the agenda, both today and tomorrow, except for items one and three, which will allow a group of five speakers to sign up together and designate one speaker who will be allocated a total of three minutes.
We have general public comment on items not on our board and that's item 15.
One minute there.
Anybody wishing to give us copies of anything, please provide 25 copies to the people in the front, Amy Bovico, who is there on the left, my left.
When you speak to us, please identify who you are and what organization, if any, you represent.
We have additional seating with TV monitors in a room.
And board members are well aware that they need to recuse themselves on the items that are relevant to that.
So with those preliminaries over, we're ready for item one.
And Cindy Kazanis will present this along with a guest presenter, Josh Daniels of the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
This is one of these composite items with some different subjects in it.
And we have one action item and two, in effect, information items.
Good morning President Kirst and welcome Member Valdez and good morning to all those teachers out there.
I know it's a teacher appreciation week and I wouldn't have been in the position I am without some great teachers and some great mentors along the way.
So as President Kirst mentioned we have some ground to cover this morning.
It's exciting since we last met we actually have a live dashboard so I'm going to
without further ado, get started and walk through just briefly the history that you've taken in to where we've gotten to this point.
And this doesn't reflect your full actions related to the development of accountability system, but really over the last 15 meetings, you've put forward the effort to put together what we are seeing now on the dashboard and in other places and other items.
So, specifically, I think the key dates that I'll refer back to in the item is your July 2016 meeting where you approved the standards and performance expectations, and then the September 2016 meeting where you approved the evaluation rubrics.
And subsequent meetings where we had discussions
I'm finalizing the academic indicator.
Just, again, important that this has been an iterative process to get to where we are today.
We did have a nice panel last meeting to talk about alternative schools.
And so we're going to build on that discussion today in asking you to take action on an application process for alternative schools.
I also wanted to give you a preview of what to expect for next time.
So there are some things I'm not going to cover because we haven't yet gotten there yet.
So we do plan to do an information memorandum on the progress towards a growth model, assuming that you approve the item two addendum for ETS.
There are some simulations in that contract that will benefit our work towards a growth model.
So we'll discuss that in our memo, along with some work Smarter Balanced is doing on this on behalf of the entire consortium.
Just wanted to give you a preview that that is something that is a work in progress and I think by June we'll have a lot more information to share with you.
We also will, in getting ready for the discussion at the July meeting, have an information memorandum on the emerging state system of support.
So I know that's a discussion that you all keep wanting me to bring up and I keep saying we're going to get there, we're going to get there.
So we're still going to get there, but it will be at our next meeting.
And then
Just as a reminder, September is really the big meeting for you to approve anything that goes in the state indicators for our release of the dashboard for fall.
So that is where we'll bring all of our recommendations for any changes to the state indicators.
And if for any reason there are things that you want us to do additional simulations on or we're not able to
make decisions in September.
We have reserved November just in case.
So we do have that.
This is what's on the horizon.
So I just wanted to give you that perspective as I move forward with the item about things that I'm ready to talk about and things that we'll talk about in the future.
So we had five attachments.
I'm going to go through them in order.
The one attachment that we're asking for you to take action on is attachment two.
So I'll circle back around to attachment two after we walk through the English Learner Progress Indicator Workgroup.
We also, like President Kerr said, will have a couple of guest speakers in between.
And then also, as we walk through each of the discussion topics, we'll pause for questions, because we don't want to lose momentum from you all.
You may have questions about regarding the content.
So I'm going to bring Jeff Beshears up first, who's going to
assist me with this presentation.
So we, not Jeff and I, but actually Jason Willis and I last meeting gave you an orientation of the dashboard.
I'm not going to give you an orientation of the dashboard today, but what I want to show you is some new functionality we've added now that the dashboard is out.
And it's actually been added in the last week to 10 days.
So one of the things that we've done on our landing page
is we added, and you have a copy of this, and we left copies on the back table.
We've added data reference guides.
We got a lot of questions from stakeholders about what data are you using.
And so these are color copies that should be in your baskets.
And again, copies are available in the back.
And really, if you look at them side by side, you can see what data was used for spring and what data is going to be used for next fall.
And I think the important thing is, is by fall, we're going to catch up on the data years.
So we'll be using more recent data, which has been a criticism of the dashboard.
But with every effort to get this out in a timely manner, we did not rerun data that we
We had newer data, but we were not able to rerun it.
So if anything, as you can see on these last two lines, it refers to our new data reference guides.
So again, I wanted to point this out to you and make sure that the audience was aware that these are in direct response to stakeholder feedback.
So Jeff is my partner in this because we did a webinar yesterday on the local indicators and this new functionality.
And we were fortunate to have 500 participants, about 500 participants.
And so we did get a lot of questions about things outside of what we were presenting on.
And I think it provided a perspective that there are still some LEAs that are catching up.
And so later on in this, as soon as we're done with showing you these new functionality,
I'm going to bring up Josh Daniels and we're going to talk about how we're providing support to the field on the dashboard.
So we did get permission to just to use Sanger Unified as an example.
So I'm going to type in Sanger and I'm assuming.
You're not seeing a live screen.
Thank you, Sue.
No, I'm on the internet.
I'm on the web.
It's an old screenshot, too.
I should point out we've actually updated it since that was produced.
Yes, we are.
We are.
We are?
Yeah.
OK.
So on this home page, you can see the new data reference guide link.
See, it says spring 2017 and fall 2017.
So I appreciate you letting me know that it wasn't working.
All right.
Now we're going to type in Sanger.
And like I said, they graciously allowed us to use them as an example.
So these screens should be familiar to you.
One of the things I wanted to make sure I pointed out, because I know when we use a PowerPoint, it's difficult to show how the functionality works.
So for college career, there is a link on this home page.
Again, this home page is the equity report that takes you directly to the grade 11 Smarter Balanced Assessment results.
So that was something that I wanted to make sure
I showed you.
In addition, directly off the equity report, if we select our English language arts or mathematics, the decision you made in January was to make sure that we displayed information for our English learners.
And so this further disaggregates that data.
Again, this is on the
status and change report, but you can get it off from the home screen.
And so when we've shown this to our stakeholder groups, they find this to be helpful.
They want to see additional information, so we'll further vet that out to see what we can put together for the fall.
And then what was released at the end of April that is new that I was not able to show you during our PowerPoint presentation in March is the detailed reports.
And the detailed reports, what we've done is we've put together, we've grouped our state indicators and our local indicators in one location.
And so it's displaying the same data, but in different categories.
And for the academic performance,
Very important because this is the first time that districts and schools are seeing the college career indicator information.
Again, this is only status only, but you can see how many students for the district are prepared, approaching prepared, or not prepared.
And again, if you think about our one pager that you all approved back in September, the criteria for this, this gives districts a glimpse of
It's only status, so again, this is not putting together a performance category.
That won't come for another until fall of 2018.
But this is really the first time they're able to see the cohort information all together.
So this was released actually just this last Friday.
The detailed reports were released at the end of April.
The other two subcategories for detailed reports are school conditions and climate and academic engagement.
So with that, I'm going to turn it back over, turn it over to Jeff, and he's going to walk through the local indicators.
Hi, good morning.
Jeff Breshears, Director of the Local Agency Systems Support Office.
So I had the opportunity to talk to Nevada County Office of Education.
I just washed my hands.
Can't do a thing with them.
And they allowed us to show the local indicators.
And they're actually, so far in the field test, the only county office that has have participated in the field test and have done these local indicators.
A couple things in Nevada County shared with me is one, they were pleased to do so because they are so small, they don't have state indicators to show and have information to share with the board.
So they were excited to have this and be able to participate.
And then also they were appreciative of especially the self-reflection tool of Priority 10 because it served as a catalyst for conversation of where they are and where they are in the implementation of coordinating services for foster youth.
And as they went through that, in fact I'll start with that, excuse me, and the rating you can see is the
They define what these ratings mean for themselves, but they had the opportunity to have the discussions at the local level and also with the board of where they are in developing their coordination of services for foster youth.
And so I'm just going to just click through and show you the local indicators.
This is basic.
The percentage, you can see the prompt.
And then this is their submission.
They have no missed assignments, no students without access, and then two facilities that do not meet the good repair rating.
For priority two, there's two options with the self-reflection tools and they chose option two, which is not just a narrative response of their implementation of the academic standards, but went through the questionnaire and again rated themselves in discussion with the board and also with the local stakeholders.
Parent engagement, they chose for option one, and here you can see their results.
It's in a different color font.
It's not a text box that shows up, you know, articulated as a text box.
They show that they have a small amount of parents, but they do have the participation.
It sounds like my mic went dead.
Is it back, or do I need to get closer?
Okay.
Local Climate Survey, again, their response to the percentage of feeling safe reported a positive response.
Here, it's interesting to me, interesting that 93% of students reported they are treated respectively.
However, 100% of the students said that they're not reciprocating that respect to their teachers.
They are not.
It's honesty.
I like that, you know, that they look through and again offers conversation.
Coordination of services.
Again, they have the ability to define these rating scales here of what it means for them at the local level.
And they went through from full implementation, full implementation and sustainability to the beginning development.
And again, I showed you coordination of services for foster youth again there.
So again, they were pleased to want to share, they were pleased to participate with these.
Again, they don't, they're small enough that they don't have the state indicators, so they have some information and talk about and share with their board.
Yes, question by board members.
Just a question on the local indicators or maybe a reminder for me that they're optional right now, right?
For people to upload.
And did I understand that Nevada County is the only one that has done it for the county offices?
County offices, yes.
And do you know what, how many people on the district side have been, have taken advantage of doing it?
The last figures we had from last week was 14, which is why we did a webinar yesterday.
So just a pitch to our friends, and I know we have lots of constituent groups here, including my friends at AXA, that this is a golden opportunity.
for LEAs, both school districts and county offices, to use this as a tryout period to work with the local indicators, have the very necessary conversations with the local stakeholders.
When it goes live next year, it's not a brand new experience.
And also a benefit, if I could add to that, it's a benefit of that if they participate in the field test now, this information that they've with the local indicators will follow through or carry over into the fall for the for the dashboard when it's released in the fall.
Board member Valdez.
Thank you.
This is great.
Some of the changes you've made are really wonderful and they're really helping develop the LCAP at the local level.
Just a quick question.
Who actually reads the dashboard for these local measures?
Is it the county office when they're looking at our LCAP or is there some kind of state feedback?
So it'd be part of the county office, part of the LCAP process.
You know, I think one of the challenges of having districts input this information is it is a district input, right?
They need to check for spelling.
They need to check for grammatical errors.
And so we want to make sure that we attribute that local input because we're pushing down the state indicators.
And this is very different.
They're pushing up.
They're filling out the information for the local indicators.
To Sue's point, I think that that is why I think we're only at 14.
I think we're going to get higher.
I'm confident we are before the end of the school year, but I think it's a very different process for them.
So we have some work ahead of us to get the word out on it.
Okay, so if we don't have any further questions, we're going to move back into the PowerPoint.
And what I wanted to now focus on is local agency support.
So now we have a dashboard.
Now what?
What are we doing to make sure that local educational agencies are able to use the dashboard and use it as a starting point to talk about how they can meet the needs of their students?
So we've already talked about the data reference guides.
You have the color copies of those.
we have included on our website, and actually last month AXA showed a video as part of their public comment, so we've added that video to our website as a resource.
We've also added some materials, some great materials that Alameda County's put together.
I actually went down with a couple members of your staff to Alameda County last month to a legislative forum that they provided some stakeholder
engagement that they're doing on the process and how they're incorporating the dashboard into it.
And so they've done some really great things.
And so that was nice to view.
We will continue our ongoing stakeholder input sessions.
That's something that has been in place, I think, since we've started the discussion about the new accountability system and about LCFF in general.
And so we did have a real
really fruitful discussion last month, and I think we've already scheduled one for the end of this month.
And what that's allowing us to do is talk about the functionality of the dashboard that folks would like to change.
So, you know, this dashboard is not static.
It's continuous improvement.
There's a commitment to that.
And actually, a couple slides later, I will show you some functionality improvements we already have planned for the fall.
So with that, I'm going to turn it over to Josh Daniels to present a couple of slides he's prepared on how the collaborative is also providing support for the dashboard.
Good morning.
Oh, sorry.
You're not coming back?
Okay, yes, I do have some questions about the dashboard.
So I have now attended a couple of, including the collaboratives, training on the dashboard.
I was at a boot camp on Friday with parents, Spanish-speaking parents.
I will be meeting with the South Stockton parents because they have concerns about the dashboard.
And I also have a nice little focus group with a lot of friends.
The majority of my friends and family members are educators.
So in having them explore the dashboard, there's been a couple of themes.
And one that is the one that's near and dear to my heart is the equity report.
And so having them and it's just not realistic for people to read.
They just want to get in there and they just start exploring.
Right.
And so.
there's a lot of confusion of what the equity report's meant to signal to those that are using it.
Because when you land on it, it shows all student performance, right?
And so even when we're looking at the West Chavez Unified here, you see suspensions rates, ELP is blue, mathematics is green.
And so it's kind of lost on people what the equity report is intended to communicate.
unless you go and click one click away, but unless we have a little voice that says, if you want to see achievement gaps, click here, right?
Unless that happens, it's not really effectively communicating what this equity report's intended to communicate, which is there are some achievement gaps that you should be aware.
And that is not represented in the all student performance, right?
Because you could have four student groups that are underperforming,
you know, an orange, I'm sorry, red and yellow or an orange, and that won't show here.
And so I want us to consider how can we redesign that so that the intent of the equity report, which was to pay attention to those student groups that were the lowest performing,
is actually now something that could be actionable.
And the current layout is not giving that.
And again, we've seen it, I've seen it with parents, I've seen it with fellow educators, and they're just missing that mark and they're missing that point because it's not laid out in a way that would invite that discussion.
So that's one.
The other thing,
The translation, I'm sure you know that the translation in Spanish when you come to the two or more races is dos or mas carreras, and carreras are careers.
And I understand that we have to use Google Translation, but Spanish
is Spanish.
I mean, we're in California.
If we're going to get it right, it's going to be in Spanish.
So I'm kind of nervous to know how other things are translated in other languages.
I think that quality control and really looking and vetting before we release something that could be minor, but yet because it's something that there's plenty of people, I'm sure, in the department that speak Spanish that could go through it and say,
Oh, hey, that translation is literal there.
There was, you know, people were offended by that.
One other thing that parents noted, they were asking, okay, so this is where we're at.
Y luego que?
Where are we heading?
What is the goal?
So if this is my school's here, how do I know as a parent where they're supposed to be heading?
So there was a lot of conversation about stating the goal.
And I know that that's part of our next conversation, but that's something that will likely, you know, from what I'm hearing, it's and I think it's a good idea for people to know if we're in red, then what's the goal?
Thank you.
Thank you for the feedback and we'll cover some of the pieces that you've talked about.
I'm going to wait until we talk about the functionality improvements right after Josh's presentation.
Board Member Rocker.
Well, I do want to say again, you're right.
Since the last time we spoke, the rubric was not up and running.
I need to congratulate you, first of all, knowing that there was going to be a great deal of interest on that during the period of time when it initially launched.
that the site didn't crash.
So I think that that's something noteworthy, first of all.
I'm also pleased that the decision to start with the launching page, the landing page, to be the equity report does put front and center where our concerns and our issues are.
I'm glad to know that you're working on some of the functionality issues and some of the end user pieces.
I also think that the other part that, however, that's missing
in the equity report is including some of the decisions that have not been made, in particular the growth model and the decision about how that's going to be reflected.
So I'm going to ask you as we go forward and those other decisions are made to look at how the information is presented on the equity report that will reflect those things.
Because I think some of the points that Board Member Lincoln brought up
about where we are going or what the goal is will be addressed by how the information from the growth model is actually presented in the equity report as well.
Great.
Board Member Holliday.
Thank you for all this and tremendous work and tremendous improvement over where we were five, six years ago.
I do think that the additional information that can be provided by the district in a text box can be tremendously helpful to parents and others.
I don't really like it way down at the bottom.
It would be nice if it were.
An introduction to the equity report explaining where we are and where we're going perhaps, you know in in verbal form and also When I was looking at at the dashboard with various schools, is it automatic?
that that box appears or does the district have to actually know that it exists?
Is that part of the training that's going on?
The district has to actually complete it.
So like the local indicators, you're not going to see the box show up unless it's completed.
And my statistics are a little old, but last time I checked with our contractor, it was just over 120 that it completed it.
Yeah, I hope that they get the word because it can be very, very helpful to parents, students, and help drive the LCAP process.
Thank you, and I, sorry, member Ortiz-Lacon, I'm going to move on to the functionality improvements just because you guys have all started, you've moved on to there.
We'll come back, we'll come back to Josh, I promise.
I know he traveled all the way here to talk to you about what they've been doing, but because there's an eagerness to jump ahead, I guess I should have,
had this organized differently.
But really, we've talked about the data years.
So again, commitment to the data years being as up-to-date as possible.
And we will have Smarter Balanced scores for this.
The students that are taking the test right now will have those scores incorporated into the fall release.
We are also developing a four-year graduation cohort report in our student data system in CALPADS.
Because up until now, the department actually has to put together this report to show districts who's in their cohort.
So we're going to add that functionality.
It's been on the to-do list probably since the system was built.
It just hasn't risen to the occasion of where we are today, which is it needs to be done now.
So we will be putting that together for implementation for this time next year.
And then there's been a lot of requests, I think even from our colleagues from across the street, from the legislature, to have a more mobile-friendly app.
And so that is something that is in development.
the contractor is starting to work on.
And then there's also additional, we've had a lot of comments to go to the usability piece of it, that searching and printing is not user-friendly.
So we are using CDS codes, and I think it was Terry Burns that said,
Who knows CDS codes?
Why is that helpful?
And so it's helpful for us, obviously, because we're using data and that's how we track all of our data.
But to the field, it's not the first thing they think about.
So we need to do a better job.
And when we bring up the search and we display things, if we can display perhaps an entire district schools, that would be a first step.
We're not doing that right now.
So, again, those are the really labor-intensive focus of the functionality improvements, but the items that you've discussed about how things are displayed, is the equity report truly an equity report?
You know, those are things that we need to continue to vet, and I think that those are good points.
We've also talked a bit about the translation piece of it and the need to, I think that there's an ability within Google Translate to make your own translations, and so,
We will be taking advantage of our resources here at the department through the clearinghouse for multilingual documents to make sure that we can get at least something as basic as two or more races to say two or more races in a different language.
So that is something that, you know, all these things together, you may not see the fruits of our labor until we release in the fall, but know that we are working on them.
And one thing that we will start to do, I think, in our board item is also show you the functionality additions in our timeline.
So I'm realizing that we don't talk enough about functionality, and I think that that's important to you.
And we saw from the letters from stakeholders, it's important to the field, too.
So we know what's ahead on this dashboard.
And then I want to give a plug, because my staff's done a tremendous amount of work on these five-by-five placement reports.
But on the department side, we've also tried to make sure we have as many available resources as well.
And so those reports have been
I think really helpful for having folks look at a district as a whole and seeing where their schools land on the different reports.
Okay, so we're going to go back to Josh and talk a little bit about the collaborative work on the dashboard.
Thanks, Cindy.
Good morning, Mr. President, members of the board.
Thank you for having me here.
My name is Josh Daniels, Director for Training and Outreach for the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
I'm going to briefly go over the work that we've been doing in the professional development training for the last year.
As you may know, the legislature in the budget for this year approved a one-time allocation of $20 million to the CCEE over a three-year period.
And the purpose of that allocation was to have the CCEE establish a system of statewide professional development training that focused on how to use the dashboard and the LCAP to support continuous improvement.
We presented our PD training plan to our governing board in October, and it was subsequently approved by the Department of Finance as required by state law.
Here are a couple of pieces that by law the training is supposed to address.
How the dashboard, although of course it says rubrics, but we've changed it to dashboard.
The dashboard may be used to develop and implement LCAPs.
how the dashboard may be used to improve people outcomes and close the achievement gap, how the dashboard may be used to communicate with stakeholders, and how the dashboard and the LCAP template may be used to establish a system of continuous improvement.
So our PD plan is currently being implemented, contains three different components, and one builds on the other.
Here is a chart that attempts to show that progression.
Component one, which is these large scale workshops, we had one set in the fall.
Once it in the spring, those were intended to establish a common baseline, common language, common understanding, very broad.
As you can see, the depth of content is shallow.
We didn't intend to go deep.
But the audience was broad.
We wanted to cover a lot of different things.
The second component goes a little bit beyond that, and it's focused on supporting alignment across trainings that are offered by local trainers.
So we do that in two ways.
One, we've partnered with County Office of Education, and we've identified regional leads.
And those regional leads are working with us and ensuring that trainings on the dashboard are offered to all LEAs in that region, both school districts and charter schools.
In addition, with component two, we are developing what we're calling the LCFF content library.
And I want to be clear, currently the way this library is envisioned is it's for trainers.
So it's not for everyone in the public.
It is for a trainer, a county office staff member, a statewide association staff member, to access aligned, up-to-date content on the dashboard and then use that in their training.
And then the third component are what we call professional learning networks.
These are based upon this idea of professional learning communities and that you learn from each other and from experience.
So this is intended to go even deeper using this idea of collaborative learning to really support how the dashboard and the LCAP can be used as tools for continuous improvement.
So each component sort of builds on the other.
And then we found that we've been getting these requests for what we call customized training.
So it will be an association that wants us to come and give a training to its members.
Or it'll be a school district that's interested in having a strategic thought partner
think through particular issues around LCFF.
And so we've gone out into the field and done a number of these over the course of the past year.
And the work for next year will be somewhat different and we'll be presenting that to our governing board next month.
But this is a quick summary of the work that we've been doing to help the field understand LCFF.
I'm happy to stay for questions or I can go back and let Cindy come up.
Board Member Burr.
who is the chair of the collaborative.
So Josh, thanks for being here and Cindy, thanks for including this as part of the presentation.
I just wanted to say how appreciative I am of this particular chart because as you all can imagine the task of professional development
for this endeavor is wide and broad.
And I think we've talked about this before and it's unique in that past professional development activities in the state have been directed toward LEAs or administrators or teachers, people right on the ground doing the instructional work.
This is much broader than that because we're trying to have wide open arms to member holidays conversation earlier that include parents and civic organizations, community organizations, everybody who's interested in improving public education.
So that creates just a different challenge.
You got to be clear about who your audience is.
And I think the collaborative staff have done a very nice job in creating a structure that allows us to do this, to go broad and go deep.
I just appreciate it.
I had the opportunity to attend.
I know a number of you attended collaborative training sessions as well and appreciate that and would appreciate your feedback.
Board Member Strauss.
So just to follow up to, this is really helpful.
Also, I did go to your early rollouts and the broad, the component one workshop.
But I wanted to thank you also, not only for the quality of your workshops,
but the availability of the PowerPoints and the resources online for anyone to access.
And I just compliment the work that you all do to get those slides to be so careful and so helpful.
And I know you put hours and hours into this.
I've worked with some of you.
But I just wanted to say that that's a resource to people who don't go or need a follow up that you're making all the materials available.
to educators and people who want to use them.
And I think that's a great resource as well for all those of us who continue to look for extra ways to clarify.
So, just a compliment.
Yeah, Josh, can you expand on the networks a little bit in terms of how, what's your theory of action there, where you are, what you hope to do with them?
Will they last beyond the 20 million and once it's spent, that kind of thing?
So thank you, Mr. Chair.
So from January of this year to June, so we're in the middle of that six-month period, we have funded 28 what we're calling early adopter networks or early adopter PLNs.
And the purpose of that was to get a sense of how those might function and how we can support their work.
It was not intended in those six months to directly impact on-the-ground learning.
That is requiring a much longer time period.
And what we've learned, among other things, is that the networks that we have seen function the best, given the data we've seen so far in the first four plus months, is that they really need to meet frequently enough to keep the conversations on the front burner, so that it's not just a network that you participate in once a month on your calendar, oh, you have to go to that meeting, but really,
weaving the learning and the conversation into their daily work.
I was actually on the ride to this meeting.
I was talking with a couple of counties that are running a joint network.
And they've talked about how the participants of that network said, wow, I didn't know what I didn't know.
and that the interest in these networks has grown because the people who attend, they're talking about LCAP, come with much more confidence to the meetings that the counties organize around doing the LCAP.
Because they've had that opportunity to learn from each other, to learn from their peers, to struggle together, and to really utilize this idea that not that the facilitator of the network is the
bearer of the knowledge, but that the knowledge is brought to the group by the other participants.
And so having that opportunity to struggle and learn and build capacity around the LCAP and the dashboard, we think has been really powerful.
For moving forward, we intend to do two-year-long networks.
There is a request for letters of interest out right now, and the deadline for that is Monday.
And we do believe that over the course of two years, we will be able to draw a much more direct line from understanding how to use the dashboard and the LCAP, not just tools in and of themselves, but really how to support improved learning at the classroom level for students.
We certainly are hoping, as part of the application process, is to ask for hosts of these networks to identify what in-kind contributions they are making to the networks to demonstrate sort of investment
in this process.
And so we are very much keeping in mind how can we keep these networks going beyond the two years and what would that mean for the role of the CCEE?
Could that be done by these networks themselves, these hosts themselves?
And so we haven't come up with any specific solution on that issue, but we've definitely been thinking about how to continue the work, you know, beyond the 18-19.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
So my question is about capacity and reach.
I know many administrators and teachers that have no idea that this data dashboard exists.
And so if the goal is to use this in combination with our LCAPS to improve instruction in the classroom level, then that's a concern, right, if they don't know that this is
a thing.
So how are we gauging how the information is trickling down?
How do we know how many more schools, districts do we have to reach so that this information is common knowledge among our educators?
Because that is a concern that they have, they don't know about it, they're often confusing it with the LCAP.
or in the core districts to be honest there is also confusion about how is this different or is it different and I'm in a core district I looked up our data very different than what the core districts are reporting so that's that's also a concern.
So how are we gauging how the information is trickling down and who's receiving it and when we are done.
So within the CC, I guess I should start by saying there are a lot of entities out there that are doing similar work.
So the counties are doing, and you'll hear about what they're doing after my part, the associations themselves are doing a whole lot of work.
So I can't speak necessarily to each individual other entity.
For our part, we are constantly looking at the data, the number of touches we have,
As part of the allocation of funding, the legislature directed the CCE to administer a statewide survey on LCFF that will be done next fiscal year.
So, we are attempting to get a sense, sort of really to drill down into those areas that have not yet been touched.
One of the components, I think, maybe two of the components that we hope would allow for just the issue that you raised, certainly the workshops are intended for all audiences.
And so, we have attempted to put together resources that are available online that anyone could access.
Similarly, with Component 2, the content library, we know that as a small, nimble agency, we do not have the capacity, nor were designed to have the capacity, to touch all of those particular people.
But we do know that there are a relatively small universe of perhaps 300, give or take,
people who train the field on this sort of work, you know, that are going to touch the teachers, going to touch the parents.
And so we hope that by having this content library being available, that it will make it easier and to support those trainers that are doing the work.
And so that's another way that we're trying to get just at the point that you raised.
For Valdez and board member.
I really appreciate what the collaborative has done and I'm part of our district is participating in the EAPLIN and so it has given us this opportunity and I see it as reciprocal benefit in terms of bringing things and then and getting things but more honestly it's an opportunity for leaders who are leading the initiatives right now.
Come together in an open honest conversations about how to get better at something that's been unknown But we have a target of where we want to go So I think the resources that are present and the opportunities to bring groups of people together ongoing But also knowing that it's time sensitive so too much.
It's kind of like Goldilocks not too much not too little just about right and I think that's up to that local group to determine The parameters of when to come together, but if you make it so infrequently, it won't have that robust conversation that we really want But I thank you for that.
It's been a great opportunity
Thank you.
And the letter of interest process is such that we really wanted to, one of the learnings we had from the early adopter process is to try to find that Goldilocks zone and to try to minimize the requirements and maximize the flexibility with the underlying intent of getting, just as you mentioned, sort of how to find that right spot for local needs.
Board Member Sandoval.
I had the pleasure of attending a workshop in Santa Maria on the Central Coast, so I was very happy with how the information was presented.
It was very well structured, set up the focal point right in the beginning.
It was an opportunity for local stakeholders.
There were parents, there were administrators, teachers, association representatives there.
Having an opportunity to really engage around the local indicators as a tool for self-reflection So I just really appreciated that and was very well organized and lots of materials that people could take with them hard copies to Distribute so I found it very helpful and relevant Any other questions for Josh if not, I think we're ready for the next presenter.
Thank you very much.
I
We have also, as department staff, participated in the CCE trainings and I am reminded, and I think Josh will have to be here more often, that we need to also show publicly that we are, you know, collaboratively working together among the agencies.
So with that in mind, I asked Efren Mercado to provide me some content about the counties and what they've been doing to help train their staff
on getting ready for the dashboard, getting ready for the new accountability system, and obviously their process of approving LCAPs because they are a critical component in this.
And so I appreciate the
the content that was provided to me.
And so I have abbreviated some of it to fit into two slides.
But really what the counties decided to do through the California County Superintendent's Educational Services Association, CESSA, is to do a five-part training series.
And four of those were in-person trainings.
And I was able to attend three of the trainings.
And I think the fourth one, or rather the last one I did online as well.
But really the purpose was more focused.
This is training.
training the trainers for the counties.
So County Office of Education staff building their capacity to know and to lead this work.
And this is also trying to get greater consistency across the state for county offices related to how to implement the state accountability system and specifically understand the new LCAP template.
And so Jeff reminded me when I sat down that the LCAP template was redesigned in November per your request to align with the dashboard.
So there are prompts in there that really ask districts and
and counties to look at the dashboard and to comment on their progress.
Every county office that reviews LCAPs participated in the training.
There are obviously a small handful of county offices that have to submit directly to the state because they are their own entity.
a district and a county office of education.
And then an overwhelming majority of counties that review LCAPs were involved in the development and review of materials.
And I think the last bullet was one that they were really most proud of, that they had a tremendously collaborative process.
It was different county offices assigned different topics and they took the lead on the content.
These trainings were all held in Sacramento, which was great for us, but other folks had to travel, of course, and they were very well attended.
I mean, they were really sort of sold-out crowds.
This is the content that they covered specifically.
So, obviously, you know, setting the timeframe or the tone back in October about what this new accountability system is.
You've been doing these LCAP reviews for the last couple years.
What's going to change?
And so, anticipating the change.
And because it took us a little while to get the rubrics all figured out and finally finalized in January, they were able to adapt these trainings.
And I know it's been a lot of hours and probably holidays and weekends to get their trainings ready to have the most current information.
So they also focused on development of a strategic approach to multi-year LCAP planning.
This isn't a one-time deal.
You're thinking about it over the next couple of years.
The nexus between the dashboard and LCAP.
And then a lot of focus on stakeholder engagement, really.
How do you provide rich stakeholder engagement?
How do you support districts to increase the quality?
And so, again, these are coming from County Office of Education staff to fellow County Office of Education staff.
They also talked a little bit about differential assistance and intensive intervention, reflecting on calibration and ongoing access or support across the County Offices of Education, and then finally working with local educational agencies towards LCAP approval, because ultimately that is, you know, again, a primary role of the County Office of Education.
So, if anything, I wanted to make sure that you knew the full complement of work.
And like Josh said, these are two examples, but these are examples that the state has heavily invested in to make sure that we have support around the structures of implementing this new accountability system.
Before I leave this, I wanted to mention, I talked to a county office of education yesterday following our webinar, and they're from a small county.
And she asked about what kind of differentiated support we could provide the smalls.
And so we've done some data runs that we haven't figured out how to solve the issue when you have one student and it gets suspended and you're now
You have a red performance category, right?
So we need to do a little bit of work on the technical design side, but we do want to bring together a group of smalls and have a rich discussion and have them help us come up with a solution to what we know is a problem for a number or hundreds of our school districts that have under 1,000 students.
So I wanted to make sure that I mentioned that we are always open to discussions, and this is how we adapt to making sure that these meet the needs of everyone.
I just want to thank you for presenting this.
And just I went to one of these sessions out at SCOE and it was a packed room with teams from each county.
And just to assure the board and the public, these are our county offices who are going to work with districts to align and try to collaborate, but then also norm some of the LCAP process.
And so I just wanted to
commend the team from SESASA and everyone and CDE and everyone who was there together.
Again, I only was at one of them, but I just the energy in the room and the number of people across, I think out of 58 counties, there was 56 counties present.
It was an amazing team.
And so I just think it shows that while we're developing a new process,
We are trying to align all the parts and we're a really big state and we have some giant counties and some very small counties.
And so it really is a piece that's important as we align all the parts to fit together.
So for me, both the collaborative presentation that Josh did and this piece about what Success is doing is just really showing us how all the parts fit together.
So I just like you to keep us posted on it and allow the and help some board members have different roles.
And so it's important for all of us to know these efforts that everyone's working on.
I like the idea of the calibration process because it allows different LEAs to have a better understanding of what's happening next door or across the state.
And I'm wondering if the local indicators have been part of that.
Only because parent engagement could look so different, school climate is looked through a very different lens depending on what LEA.
And I think that from what I'm hearing, this is of concern.
It's like, well, you know, how does this look?
How often will we know, you know, parent engagement is defined in our district?
Who has an input?
In some districts that are small and very similar, you could probably get a good temperature of how parent engagement, for instance, is being implemented.
But in other districts where you have a diversity of students, a diversity of type of schools, one side of town may think that things are great, but not the other.
And so how do you calibrate that, you know?
And so I think that LEAs would also need assistance with
For instance, some of the big districts, how would you truly reflect what is happening there in terms of parent engagement when you have some communities or some parent groups or some schools that may feel that there needs to be improvement and others may be satisfied?
How would you calibrate that?
Is that part of the conversation?
As far in relation to success I don't I don't know that they specifically covered that particular point But I know that through the CCE trainings there were breakout sessions for local indicators But I do think that the numbers tell a story with only 14 completing this information.
It's early I think this is our next big area of focus and that's why I wanted to make sure Jeff got a little bit of
time before you because we are partnering together to make sure that we're doing what we need to.
So I know there's been, you know, a tremendous amount, especially in the school conditions and climate work group, but can they move on to talking about implementation and helping us with implementation?
I don't, have not had that discussion yet with, with, with Glenn, but, you know, those are, those are possibilities.
But I do, I agree, we have a lot of work ahead of us as far as the local indicators go.
And that's why we wanted to make sure we, we talked about that this morning.
This, I think, concludes this.
Now you're moving to alternative schools, so we're on to attachment two.
Yes, we're moving on to attachment two.
And this is, we are going to ask you for, this is going to be an action piece to put together an application process for alternative schools.
And just briefly, as way of background, the department and the board has always been very interested in this population of students.
And I think one of the reasons that you all made the decision to, to not echo,
to allow alternative schools as defined under education code and then under your policy to be excluded from the spring release of the dashboard was because the state indicators that have been approved to date are not necessarily fair for that population of students.
And so you've asked us to do some work to put together indicators that
that are appropriate for our alternative schools population.
So when incorporated, this data will roll up into a district's performance.
I want to make sure that I state that publicly because I think there's been some confusion around this population.
So the new application will be a first step towards making sure that we are looking at this population and then also to, for us, we will be watching for unintended consequences.
So we don't want to see students moved into alternative schools in March to take
maybe the CASP test and then move back to the school.
So we always watch for those trends when we're looking at data.
And mobility is something that I know is very important for alternative schools.
That is why some students end up at alternative schools is because they're moving around a lot.
So we want to make sure they're there for the right reasons.
So with that in mind, this attachment
I'm going to give you a brief overview of who was included in the dashboard and who was excluded because of the existing law and then the criteria that you adopted, you being a state board back in 2003.
It's been a long time since we've talked about eligibility criteria.
The reason that we're bringing this to you now is because this process is going to take us a little bit of time to put together and we want to make sure that we have the right universe of schools for the dashboard release this fall.
So we did hear some feedback from a handful that they are no longer serving the student population and they didn't know they were going to be excluded as an alternative school.
So we will do, through this process, do some education about why they were considered an alternative school and if they don't want to be in the dashboard as an alternative school and rather a traditional school, then we need to figure that out as well.
So, we do need your approval to start a new application process and as part of that, the next steps after the application process in July will bring back some new criteria for alternative schools.
We have put together a task force.
We have partnered with the Gardner Center and Jorge Ruiz de la Bosco has been fantastic in providing support, technical support and logistics.
And they'll meet for the first time later this month.
And as far as timing, keep in mind that the alternative school indicators will come to you for the implementation in fall 2018.
So we're still over a year away, but there are things that we are doing, such as this, we're making steps and progress towards developing that system through things like the application process today.
So just in a way of context, I think it's important to show you that for alternative schools in the dashboard, they make up approximately 13% of the dashboard.
So 13% of the schools that are listed in the dashboard do not have performance categories.
One of them is Nevada County.
So a lot of our county offices only operate alternative schools.
So as you can see, there's a breakdown within the alternative schools.
Those are the first
several rows there and the largest number of alternative schools are actually defined in education code.
And that makes up 82% of the population that was again excluded from the dashboard.
The remaining 18% meet the eligibility criteria that the state board established back in 2003.
We want to make sure that those that met the eligibility criteria in 2003 are still meeting eligibility criteria today.
So that is the action before you.
Yes.
Sorry, I'm looking at the high school category, that column on the far right.
And down at the bottom, I just want to make sure I understand there are 927 alternative schools by these definitions and 1,388 non-alternative.
I assume that means traditional high schools.
That is traditional high schools.
So.
So I don't understand the percentages.
I'm struggling.
But because it looks like it's almost half and half, which seems way too high to me.
But high schools often have a continuation high school that goes with them as an alternative.
So it's not actually so off to have the equal because a large high school would have a continuation high school as part of the program, if you think about it.
Maybe in LA.
So can you help me understand?
Yes.
Is that accurate?
Jenny, are you?
Maybe Jenny can help me to describe this too.
But when we're looking across the rows, that's how you want to make sure you're 100% adds up, not between the total alternative schools and total non-alternative schools, although it should add up to 100%.
So that's a good point.
I'm sorry, I understand why we have more alternative high schools than you would think.
So the total non-alternative schools you have to read it across.
So 65% of our non or traditional schools are elementary, 15% are intermediate, 3.5% high school.
They're concerned that...
Sue, why don't we take a look at it, and we'll get back to you.
Yes, we'll have to take a look at it.
Thank you.
We'll dig into the data a little bit more.
I know that the non-alternative schools row was sort of added at the last minute, so we need to do a bit more careful review next time.
I apologize.
So education code, and this is a section, requires the state superintendent with the approval of the state board to develop an alternative accountability system.
So this language is, like I said, goes back to the prior state system.
And it identifies specific types of schools as alternatives.
So again, this is the 82% of that current mix.
So the remaining schools, the 18%, are things that the previous state board of education back in 2003
came up with the definition for inclusion in alternative school system.
So this definition includes those that you would expect.
Expelled students, suspended, wards of the court, pregnant and or parenting, recovered dropouts, habitually truant or habitually insubordinate and disorderly, and then retained more than once in kindergarten through grade eight.
So the definition
for these schools that the board had adopted previously was 70% of the school's total enrollment needed to be comprised of this high risk group.
What we're simply asking you to do is to allow us to develop an alternative school application process for those that are not currently defining EDCO, those that have been to date defined under the State Board of Education eligibility to verify that they continue to serve this high needs population.
We will bring back in July a definition to expand it out.
So credit deficient is one that we've talked about.
And I think that there are going to be some others and this is the purpose why we're not bringing this to you as a twofold action because we want to spend time in the field talking to others about what else should be included in
the description and one of the things is how did we get to 70% too?
So what is how do we do we keep that threshold of students as well?
But simply today we're asking you that you allow us to develop an application process and then in July we would again
bring back additional criteria to include potentially additional types of schools in this criteria.
So they would be excluded again from the dashboard for fall, but they would be the population of students we would focus on for our alternative indicators in which we're developing as we speak.
Okay, Board Member Holliday has a question.
Thank you so much for this.
So many of these schools have been waiting for this work to begin and thank you for diving into it.
Yeah, once again, we are talking about when we talk about closing the achievement gap, you know, we're so many of these schools, we're talking about kids at the very bottom of the achievement level, and they need all the help they can get.
And one of the ways that we are going to help with this is by creating this accountability system, not as a way of
distinguishing these schools from traditional schools or other charter schools, but by providing them with the right kind of data that will help them with their continuous improvement.
And that's very tricky.
I'm very interested in this task force.
And I assume from what you said, it's already been pulled together.
It's been pulled together.
We haven't met yet.
So we will bring forward a memo or it'll be in your next board item of the members of the task force.
But because we haven't met, we didn't want to leave out anybody.
So it's very comprehensive.
It's particularly LEA practitioners making up.
Good.
Excellent.
And charters, schools involved and all that.
That's terrific.
And I sincerely appreciate the idea that you need to get started with this application process.
I think there are a lot of schools that didn't know whether they were ASAM or not ASAM.
And it's about time that we start fresh out of the box.
And I hope that all the schools will get this information and have the opportunity to apply.
I'm very grateful that you are working on Plan B for July and including other
you know, sets of students that would make up these schools.
I'm also very pleased that you're willing to think about the 70% and whether or not that actually makes sense.
It may.
It may be the perfect percentage.
But then again, it may not.
And the practitioners probably have a better idea.
So that would be very helpful to reconsider that at least.
And finally, the heart and soul of all this is
what are the indicators going to be?
And that is, therein lies the ability for this alternative assessment program to be truly valuable to these schools and to the students and to the parents, or whether it's just kind of same old, same old.
So, very excited to hear all that develop.
Thank you for starting this work.
Okay, any other comments?
To Lisa?
Go ahead.
I think that clearly our goal with setting up our standards and our accountability system and the LCFF is to keep students in traditional schools and to try to prevent a number of students from having to take an alternative path.
But once they do reach that alternative path, I think it's important for us to also hear the perspective from those that have some concerns about what this alternative accountability system
could mean or what should be considered.
I enjoyed the panel that we had.
I'm not sure who is part of this task force.
I was just quickly reviewing a report by the Public Policy Institute of California and they do have some concerns about setting a separate accountability system.
I think that it would be important to have those voices as part of the conversation so that it could better inform our work.
and understanding that there won't be consensus when it comes to setting an alternative accountability system.
But yes, definitely what board member Holiday stated, making sure that those indicators are solid and that they do align to our accountability system, even though we understand it's a different population.
But I want us to invite voices that could maybe shine light on some of our blind spots as we discuss alternative accountability system for these students.
Thank you.
Cindy, could you put the slide up that shows that one?
Sorry, the one that's got the list of folks.
So sometimes I sort of feel like the resident historian here.
But just wanted to remind people that the reason this happened in 2003 was because we put the old accountability system in place.
This is what was the fallout from the API.
There was also at the same time, and I think this is the important consideration, we were in zero tolerance for kids who brought guns to school, weapons.
It was on the heels of Columbine.
Lots of concern about school safety.
And at that time, I would just say that we were not hesitant to send kids right out of school into another setting because we didn't want them in the regular school setting.
So the first two, especially expelled and suspended, fall into that zero tolerance category.
And subsequent to 2003, and especially most recently, we've made lots of statutory changes to how we handle student discipline.
So I just want to make sure that we bring all that stuff forward and go, okay, we're in a different context now.
We're also not in an accountability system that only looks at test scores.
That was also what was happening here.
Because the transient nature of many of these students, it didn't seem fair to hold them accountable just to test scores.
So I just want to make sure, and this sort of goes to board member Ortiz-Lincoln's point, that we bring our context up to date here as well as we talk about alternative schools.
I completely applaud the department for going, yeah, we got to start over here, make sure that we know what population we're talking about.
But I think we also need to think about what context we're asking educators to educate our children now as well as we think about this, not just kind of go on autopilot.
Thank you.
These schools ought to be going down in enrollment and going through some kind of change from that alone, it seems to me.
Yeah, that's a very good point.
We just heard from a couple graduate students from your university, President Kirst, who did some work on San Jose as a case study for alternative schools.
And it was very enlightening on the enrollment and the transiency.
and lack of transiency.
And so things like that will definitely help us with our work ahead.
I also wanted to mention, we're approaching this work group and the college and career work group a little differently.
We are going to schedule stakeholder input sessions outside of the group members, specifically on these topics in intervening.
intervening meetings and so So to the point of we need to be as inclusive as possible We hope that the task force members are representing those populations, but where they where they don't we will definitely involve All of our stakeholders and the advocacy groups and the associations and intervening months to comment on the work groups work absent, you know prior to it becoming to the California petitioner's advisory group and prior to it coming to you because there's been some concern that there hasn't been enough
public discussion, and so we will be approaching these a little differently.
And then I also just wanted to make sure that we're using the same terminology.
The Education Code says we're going to put together a system.
We want to make sure the system is integrated into our current system.
So as we start to talk about alternative schools, we want to emphasize these are indicators within the current system.
so that it marries what we've already done.
And it's not separate and apart and something that's an alternative schools dashboard.
That's not what we're creating.
We have a dashboard.
We want to be inclusive and bring them into the fold.
Are you doing any descriptive analytical work of this, like recovered dropouts?
That's another area that's grown enormously since 2003.
I'd like to know more.
What are these schools?
What do they do?
So you can list numbers for us, but in light of this conversation, can we get some description and analysis of the types, what they do?
A recovered dropout school, I mean, that could cover a whole lot of things, like some of these other things too could.
So beyond the numbers analysis, have somebody do... Okay.
Perhaps we can bring a memo forward in June.
I know we're already doing a couple others, but it sounds like this would be a good backgrounder for the discussion in July when we're asking you to actually adopt the definition.
We can do that.
Jenny, you want to...
So I just wanted to say for the chart that is on Attachment 2, page 3, we have 927 alternative high schools.
That number is correct.
We have a lot of alternative high schools, but remember the enrollment in those high schools are very low for most.
So they make up about 13% of the enrollment.
Thank you.
So with that, we're ready to move on to our final topic.
Attachment 3, which is English Learner.
I'm going to ask Veronica Aguilar to come up and help me with this presentation.
Good morning President Kirst and esteemed members of the board.
Welcome member Valdez and just as Cindy Casanas mentioned, happy appreciation week.
I know I wouldn't be here if it wasn't because of the wonderful teachers that I had when I came here to America.
And actually today is also
Happy Mother's Day for those of you that are from Mexican descent.
My daughter called me this morning and reminded me of that.
But it's so nice to see that the teachers are our second, or parents are our first teachers, and then we go to school and learn with the teachers.
So, happy Mother's Day.
I will provide you with a brief summary of the English Learner Progress Indicator, better known as the LP workgroup, and their activities to date.
This is work that my colleagues Cindy Casanas and I have been co-facilitating.
As you may recall, in June of 2016, the SBE recommended that the department convene a workgroup of experts to explore the use of English Language Proficiency Assessment for California, commonly known as the LPAC.
Also, the workgroup was to look at incorporating long-term English learners and reclassified students.
to capture a fuller picture of the student performance and to advise on the development of the English Learner Progress Indicator, or as we commonly are calling it now, the LP, to include in the accountability system.
The group of experts is comprised of 10 members from throughout California.
It includes English Learner Program Experts, Data Experts, County Office of Education, and District Office Experts, as well as classroom teachers, and representatives from institutions of higher education, as well as the Comprehensive Center, and representatives from the State and Senate.
Both Kimberly and Tanya have attended the meetings.
The CDE has provided updates on the LP workgroup during the September, November, January, and March state board meetings.
As mentioned before, the convening and the facilitation of the meetings has been a joint effort between both the Accountability Division and the English Learner Support Division.
Although the Accountability Division has been taking the lead because they have that expertise.
The CDE, or the department, has consulted with the workgroup on whether or not LTELs, long-term English learners, should be incorporated into the English learner progress indicator.
The department has consulted with the workgroup on adding additional English learner reports in DataQuest and the California School Dashboard, and on whether or not reclassified students should be included in the English learner student group for the academic indicator.
As you may recall, action was taken by the board
during the January meeting.
To summarize the group's work, the LP work group first met by phone in October of 2016 and convened three subsequent times in person.
In October, the work group asked for simulations to be run using both the California Education Code definition of long-term English learners and also run simulations using students identified as English learners for six or more years in school.
The SBE received the update about the workgroup's meeting in an October memo.
On December 2016, the LP workgroup provided feedback on presenting information on the EL subgroup for the academic indicator.
The actions that took place is detailed in the January state board item.
This was the action that the board took on including reclassified students in the academic indicator.
In addition, the workgroup reviewed whether LTEL's data
or long-term English learners could appropriately and viably be incorporated into the current LP.
The LP recommendations were presented to the committee of practitioners or the CPAC, and I believe member Valdez was part of that committee back then, and the Technical Design Group, better known as the TDG, to review the technical validity and reliability of the recommendations and present it to the board in January.
On January 2017, the workgroup met again and reviewed and provided feedback on the draft long-term English learner reports for posting on the CDE's DataQuest website that further desegregated the long-term English learners student population.
The English Learner Progress Indicator Workgroup reviewed the LTEL data simulations and agreed not to include data into the existing LP formula for status and change due to two things, difficulty in interpreting the results and data unfairly penalized middle and high schools.
Again, the LP recommendations were presented for input to the CPAC.
and to the TDG.
The recommendations from all three groups were presented to the State Board during the March meeting by my colleague, Cindy Casanas.
And this brings us to our last work group meeting in March.
At this time, Cindy Casanas will provide the information from the last work group meeting.
So because of the reasons that Veronica just mentioned about the challenges of including long-term English learners data, we took a different approach for the March meeting.
And we ran data simulations to see if schools could get extra credit who had long-term English learners for the LP.
So they needed to advance at least one level on the CELT.
And the LP workgroup did support this, and they also discussed
the additional LTEL reports and DataQuest in the dashboard.
So this work group has did a lot of work in just a short couple of meetings and I'm going to show you the formula that we presented to them and the data is in the subsequent slide.
So these are the text that is in black is the current LP.
What has been suggested is that we add extra credit and so we would add LTELs who, again, they're taking our language development test and they need to increase at least one CELT level.
So what does this mean for this group of students?
For the spring dashboard, if we would have included this formula, you would have seen schools change color.
Adding this extra weight, you'd see 63 schools change at least one color.
This represents 46 different local educational agencies.
This is not concentrated.
That's sometimes an argument for our English learners that they're concentrated in one district.
This is not the case.
This is actually pretty widespread and would have a full effect.
We brought these recommendations to the California Practitioners Advisory Group.
They affirmed that this was a good step.
It showed a signal that we were committed to promoting long-term English learners doing well.
This is a population that has been, again, this is time and then they have to make progress on
on assessments.
So it's not just they've been an English learner for six years.
It's actually a more complicated definition.
And so they also thought that this would encourage schools to look more closely at this work group, or the student group, rather.
The technical design group, we asked them from a technical aspect, is this technically sound?
And they said, of course.
But they thought it was more of a policy decision.
So they really did refer to the work group's recommendation and said that there were no significant technical issues.
They did not have any concerns with the recommendation.
So what that takes us to is our final slide, and we are suggesting that you have a discussion about the work group recommendations, but that you reserve your action for September so that we look holistically at the dashboard and all changes to the dashboard.
We don't do this piecemeal.
So that is the recommendation, that you take action as appropriate at your September meeting.
And then we do have actually an action item for the alternative schools that I've already discussed.
So that is bullet number two.
So with that, I can open it up to questions.
Hi, Cindy.
I just wanted to ask a question because you, the last information you gave about schools that would change color when this information is added and you use the term of art weight.
I want, because that has a particular meaning when you talk about each of the elements.
This new piece or this recommended piece that was, that's being tested by the technical design group.
It's not a weighted factor.
It is a,
equal weight with all the other elements in the indicator.
Is that correct?
That's correct.
OK, but because you said the word weight, when you add what you really meant was when this element is added for consideration, this is the weight of what that means.
OK, I just want to be sure I was hearing that correctly.
You're correct.
And actually, we ran half weight as well.
Okay.
Not being that, you know, we're differences of use, but this was the one that was preferred with the worker.
I just wanted to be clear on that.
So, yes.
Okay.
Thank you.
We'll wait to the rest of it.
Okay.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
And I know that we won't take action until September, but as you're moving to improve and add additional information into the data dashboard, the LTELs was one of the subgroups that we were waiting to see if it would be considered into the, what are we calling it, the English language proficiency.
Indicator, progress indicator.
And so now that it looks like it won't be included other than extra credit, I would like to see the LTIL data in the dashboard under the academic indicator disaggregated so that we know how our LTIL students are doing along with the ELs, I'm sorry, ELs, RFEPs, and long-term ELs.
Thank you.
Well, we said we were going to wait to see if it was going to be considered here.
But since it's only considered for extra credit purposes, I think it's appropriate for us to also show that information in the data dashboard.
Thank you.
Board member Valdez.
So maybe if you could clarify something for me.
So this whole incentive model of giving the extra credit, and how is it not double weighting?
Because I've heard some concerns about that.
I just don't completely understand it.
So I think the technical design group had some concerns about that.
So I need to give full credit to Jenny Tseng and Jonathan Eisler of my staff and their staffs who staffed this workgroup and ran all these data simulations.
We've transitioned Jenny out of this role just for this one indicator.
And so Jonathan Eisler is one of our other managers who's done our Title III accountability.
And so welcome, Jonathan.
Thank you.
Good question.
So I'm Jonathan Iser from Data Visualization Reporting Office, and I presented at the CPAG.
So in effect, there is a double count of these particular students in the numerator, but we realized that because there was no way that anyone would get close to 100% total, it wouldn't skew the results in that way.
But yeah, that was a legitimate question about weighting as well.
I mean, I think it's more of a semantics question,
But yes, that was the intent of giving the extra credit is in fact giving additional credit to those LTEL students who are improving.
Who are improving, yes.
Thank you.
I think we're ready for public comment then since on any of these items and we do have an action item at the end of the public comment.
Would the following people... We're going to take a break of 10 minutes before the public comment, 20 of 11.
And we'll come back at 20 of 11.
...by the sponsoring district board.
And getting things together for a fall 2017 reapplication is dicey from our end.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Ernie Silva from SciTech, you know, the network of dropout recovery public charter high schools.
I want to say, I'm just here to say thank you.
I know this has been a long time coming.
I appreciate all of you are the boards and the staff's willingness to tough this alternative accountability stuff out.
This is really difficult issues and we really appreciate that we're there and that we're in the process of making that work.
And specific to item one, I want to thank Kerrick and Cindy and Ginny and Howard and Dave and whoever else was involved in this.
We're working on some data glitches that we've identified for our school and we look forward to being able to work those through.
I'm going to bleed into the related issue of item three.
It's really important and I want to thank you again for recognizing and being explicit that we're looking at the
hate to say bottom, but the bottom 5% of traditionals and the bottom 5% of alternatives and not just making all alternatives the bottom 5%.
That's really, really important to all of us and to the kids that we serve.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. President and board members.
Carrie Mazzoni with Opportunities for Learning and the Coalition for Alternative School Accountability here to thank Jenny Singh and the department for the work they've done with us on the issue of alternative accountability, particularly the expansion of the criteria to include such things as credit deficiency and mobility.
Again, we're supportive of the recommendations and look forward to our further work with them.
Thank you.
Good morning, Board, Dale Marsden, Superintendent, San Bernardino City Unified, along with a couple of our student board members, Ms.
Danielle Cazada and Isabel Cholby, as well as our Executive Director of Community Engagement, Ms.
Ginger Antoveros.
Good to see you again.
Our message this morning is really just to stay on course.
You can continue to rely on the power of local control and the power of authentic
community engagement.
We've given you some handouts on our community engagement plan, which is our strategic plan, as well as some other documents to refer to around our local measures.
But, you know, with that, this is my fifth year.
I've come to you previously.
Previously, our graduation rate was, for all students, was in an area of nearly 90 percent.
Poverty was 66.8 percent.
Today we're at 86 percent, passing the state, county, national average, which we're very proud of in our community.
But that's not all.
With the local attention,
and the authentic engagement of our community staff and parents and students.
We see our English learners going from 61% to 84% graduation rate.
Our foster youth, because of the focus of this state board, 21% growth, 81.8% graduation for our foster youth.
And you know what that means.
A lot of hard work done at the local level to make that vision a reality.
We agree with the comments made about strengthening user friendliness of our dashboard, including
translation for our second language speaking families.
However, we strongly advocate for the board to maintain flexibility and local indicators of school success.
We'll hand out to you a copy of one indicator we're using from the Gallup student poll, which measures four areas around engagement, hope,
entrepreneurial aspiration, career and financial literacy.
And with that, we have a trend already established.
We have a strong alignment to our district's current strategic plan.
That's why these local measures are important.
Local control, which helps line us up.
And that close attention to our own community's context.
And this lines us up for success in college and career readiness.
With that, Ms.
Danielle Quesada, one of our student board members, has a few comments to make as well.
Hello my name is Danielle Quesada and as he said I am a student board member for the City of San Bernardino.
I would like to say thank you but I would also like to emphasize that this wouldn't be possible me standing in front of you guys and giving my input if we didn't have local control.
The idea of each county and district customizing their governing and doing things will
will meet certain needs, and I feel like my needs are being not only considered but met through this.
For example, we have a student advisory council where we have students speak about their first-hand experiences, which could go in the example of safety.
If we're trying to figure out things through regular safety, we get it from students who experience these violent issues such as domestic violence or just going and living in these perilous streets and say things that affect them firsthand and how they'll be more effective.
In general, I'd say that through the local control and getting a student voice, I feel like I'm being considered more as Danielle Quesada from San Bernardino and not just another teen in California who's a student and following rules that are constituted by people who are actually just viewing us rather than actually letting the experiences speak for themselves.
Thank you.
Time.
Go ahead, yeah.
Hi, my name is Isabel Cholby.
I go to Cajon High in San Bernardino City Unified School District.
And I would like to thank the board as well, the State Board of Ed, for their recent commitment to local control.
In my district, local control has allowed student voice to flourish like never before.
And I know this personally from being in student groups like the new Student Advisory Council and seeing the opinions of my peers having an impact on our lives in school.
But without student engagement, students feel that decisions about their lives have been made for them.
So they become disillusioned with their education and their lives at large.
And without local control, they'd be right.
The decisions would have already been made by adults who live miles away from them.
So it is only through local control that student voice can have an impact.
And it is only when student voice has an impact that students feel empowered to take charge of their own lives.
So I know that the State Board of Ed's decision for local control will continue to help us for years to come.
Thank you.
Good morning, I'm Ginger Ontiveros, Executive Director of Community Engagement for San Bernardino City Unified School District.
Thank you for the opportunity to share our thoughts about local control.
I'd like to add my voice to encourage you to stay the course in your current path of local control for funding and accountability decisions.
Local control has allowed our district to build a robust set of link learning career pathways aligned with industries that are important to our region.
We now have 34 pathways across nine high schools preparing more than 8,000 students for future careers in healthcare, manufacturing, advanced technologies, and even more.
In fact, we're growing our own teachers for San Bernardino City Unified School District.
The ability to decide at the local level where to apply funding has meant that we're able to invest more in innovative thinking that promotes higher engagement for our students.
As you heard from Dr. Marsden, those investments are paying off and the accountability decisions at the local level are helping us to respond more effectively to what's needed by our community.
So we understand that accountability is important.
We like the dashboard that you've produced and thank you very much for continuing the course.
Good morning, I'm Doug McRae, a testing specialist for Monterey.
Last week I submitted nine pages of observations on topics for items number one, two, and three to your electronic folder.
To highlight the three pages of observations and reflections for item number one.
First, the dashboard system is not yet a true accountability system.
It needs decision rules for identifying districts and schools for rewards and required assistance before it's a true accountability system.
State Board has yet to adopt these.
Second, the overall data quality contributing to the dashboard is substandard for a statewide accountability system.
Details justifying this description may be found in the first three pages of the nine-page document submitted to the electronic folder.
I'd be happy to answer any questions on the above highlights, particularly what might be done to improve the quality of the student achievement data contributing to the current dashboard.
Thank you.
Good morning, Jesse Aguilar for the California Teachers Association.
CTA urges the board to remain focused on its longstanding goal of establishing a single coherent system that is multidimensional with a focus on supporting equity of access, opportunity and outcomes for all California's diverse public students, school students.
With respect to the development timetable attached to this item, CTA asks that the board clarify and confirm the status of the numerous critical local indicators adopted for the current transitional or field test year with assurances that they would be further developed.
We understand some work may be underway, but any efforts related to parent engagement, implementation of state academic standards, and courses accessed beyond the CCI are not reflected in the timetable.
When read in conjunction with the SSA plan and its limited focus on state indicators, the timetable reinforces our broader concern about the lack of progress on ensuring a well-developed and holistic set of indicators that meaningfully measure and therefore prioritize what matters, student outcomes and the conditions of learning that form the foundation of equitable educational opportunity.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
Three quick points.
First, we appreciate the staff recommendation regarding the eligibility criteria.
Second, we're concerned about the closed meeting nature and gag rule imposed on the members of the technical design group.
It really limits our ability to monitor what's going on.
And third, we've been barnstorming the state with charter-specific LCAP and dashboard workshops that have gone very well.
But we're also getting a lot of feedback from our members that they're hearing different messages in other workshops that they go to that don't include the charter-specific information and that they're getting a lot of confusion and dissonance over that.
And we hope that you'll send a message to other providers that they need to include that in their messages.
Thank you.
I'd like to call some additional speakers.
Could we please have Tracy D'Meldo, Kareem Gangara, Terry Burns, Brian Rivas, Leticia Garcia, Jewel Patterson, Shelley Spiegel-Coleman, Elizabeth Robitaille, Samantha Tran, Dale Shimazoski, Esperanza Ross, Carla Cross, Roberto Viramontes, and Sasha Horowitz and Liz Gien lineup.
Good morning, President Kirsch, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
Leandra Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association.
I just want to take a moment to recognize the outstanding outreach efforts being done by state board staff, CDE staff and CCEE, particularly to smalls.
I can't tell you how many calls that we've gotten about members for input, the stakeholder meetings that David Sapp arranged.
I'm talking to Cindy about the volatility of the suspension rates for smalls.
working with CCE on professional networking.
The efforts are working.
Folks feel invested and empowered in this system.
And I just urge you to stay the course.
And I just want to thank them for their work and for reaching out to smalls.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Karim Gonagora.
I am a parent from the Fontana Unified School District in San Bernardino County, and I'm here today with COPE, which is an Inland Valley advocacy group.
I'm here today to talk in regards to the dashboard, as you guys had a presentation on earlier.
Something that I understand as a parent is that it's an important tool to keep our school accountability up to date, and we really appreciate the first version and the board's continued work to add and improve it.
But for me as a parent, I honestly believe that we should be able to use a dashboard to understand how well the schools and their communities are going to serve students.
Right now, I don't believe the dashboard is too easily accessible and understandable for parents.
There are certain key information that was discussed.
The first thing is that some of the Spanish doesn't actually translate accordingly.
So however you guys could remedy that would be much appreciated.
It needs to include numeric goals and timeframes for meeting those goals, and it should show if a school is receiving targeted or comprehensive support, and it should demonstrate that equity matters by showing the performance of subgroups.
We know that these improvements are possible.
We hope that you'll make the improvements it needs.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Jewel Patterson.
I'm a youth organizer from San Bernardino County, and I'm here on behalf of COPE, an Inland Valley Advocacy Group.
The Education Trust West has developed a possible sample dashboard to show one way these improvements could be made.
The sample dashboard preserves multiple measures, color-coded ratings, and the focus on continuous improvement.
But it also makes the information more clear to parents and other stakeholders.
We appreciate the time and attention that you will invest in improving the dashboard so that it is both understandable and meaning to parents and community members.
Thank you.
Good morning, Terry Burns on behalf of the California School Boards Association.
And in my letter, we have several suggestions on the definition for alternative schools.
But we're very pleased that you're taking a look at defining alternative schools before building a system that you have to fit them into.
So that's a real plus.
We also like
we appreciate the attention in the dashboard issues to the issues of small districts and county offices because that will need some further attention.
We think the dashboard rollout went very positively and continues to grow the as hearing from stakeholders you put up documents and resources that folks can use to improve that.
We echo Mr. Holiday's concerns about the placement of the narrative and
somewhat below the mileage and interest disclaimer information.
It should be a little bit more prominent and easily accessible.
And we're getting the word out to school board members and thus you'll see more pressure on boards to put that information.
in the dashboard, you'll see that we hear anecdotally that folks will be adding the local indicators after the end of school activities and graduation stuff.
Thank you.
Good morning, Shelley Spiegel-Coleman with Californians Together.
We just want to thank the work of the English Learner Proficiency Indicator Group for really taking seriously the issue of long-term English learners.
We think having an incentive for the growth of long-term English learners is something that really will spark more schools and districts to look at the issue of those students.
And we would agree with what board member Lincoln Ortiz said that in addition to that having the achievement data of that subgroup in conjunction with the English learners and the RFEPs will give the districts and the schools a fuller picture of what they need to address when they attend to the students in their LCAPs.
So thank you very much.
Hi, Patty Scripter, California State PTA.
As you know, we've been working to make parents aware of all the changes in accountability and with the rollout of the dashboard at our California State PTA Convention in San Jose last weekend.
On Sunday morning at 9 a.m., the last day of convention, we had over 150 parents at our dashboard workshop.
It was incredible.
They really wanted to learn about it.
Our message that it's not a score, it's a story really resonated with parents.
But what we're really finding in our trainings is that we'll get into how easy it is to use the dashboard, but first we have to make them aware of the dashboard.
And there's a huge range of even awareness of what we're looking at and what it's supposed to do.
And we've been really clear in our messaging with parents that the goal is to get to green so that they do understand it's not just looking at where they are, but where they're supposed to go.
I have to applaud the under two minute video on that dashboard side.
It's quick.
We've used it in trainings.
We need more like that.
I want to thank Member Ortiz-Lincon for your comments about the equity report.
We have parents asking, but where's the summary?
So we need to make sure that we're looking at equity, but also that there's a quick summary.
Thanks.
Good morning, Elizabeth Revitae on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
I just wanted to go back to the discussion you were having about small districts and how they might be impacted by the dashboard and hope that you will remember many charter schools are in that same exact situation as the small districts and hope they will be included in the discussions moving forward.
Also, we appreciate the State Board of Education's efforts to clarify the criteria for alternative schools to ensure that they are appropriately nuanced and robust to really measure the student learning outcomes and success of those students.
We know that there are several charter high schools that are classified as ASAM and these revised criteria will be very important to them as well.
Thus, we look forward to supporting and collaborating to the discussions on the revised criteria.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Leticia Garcia on behalf of Riverside County Office of Education.
I'm here to express our appreciation for the inclusion of a High School Readiness Indicator in your timeline, attachment four.
And this is to begin conversations on work of a High School Readiness Indicator that may be included in the
in the dashboard in the fall of 2018.
Riverside County leaders continue to believe that a high school readiness indicator would be a direct and powerful analog to the graduation rate.
Currently, you have a void of early performance indicators, so this will be a way to address that void as well as meet federal requirements for an alternative.
K-8 academic indicator, as well as leveraging current data that you have at the state level.
In an interim step, we have reached out to State Board of Education staff to begin the conversations of leveraging the dashboard and maximizing the opportunity to develop an early warning system tab to identify students in need earlier in their academic careers to ensure success in high school.
Thank you.
Good morning, Roberto Viramontes with the Learning Policy Institute.
We thank the State Board and CDE staff for all their work on developing an accountability and continuous improvement system.
As we move forward with refining indicators, the Learning Policy Institute expresses support for the inclusion of some long-term English learner data as part of the English learner progress indicator formula.
including El Tal Data will incentivize school districts and schools themselves to focus on this high-need EL subgroup who require additional focus and resources to move them to English language proficiency.
Also, we would like to recognize and applaud the creation of the College and Career Indicator Workgroup.
We look forward to providing input as California works to develop more robust and integrated measures of college and career readiness.
The College and Career Ready Indicator will be a critical indicator for incentivizing greater access to college and career preparatory course sequences.
and other opportunities to learn as well as focusing our attention on student outcomes that signal that our California graduates are prepared for post-secondary success.
Thank you.
Good morning, Brian Revis on behalf of the Education Trust West.
When it comes to the dashboard, we would ask that as you're sorting out feedback from various stakeholders, inevitably there are going to be tradeoffs.
Please choose transparency and user friendliness.
I think in your theory of action, access to the data is critical and making sure people can get it and work with it.
So please keep that in mind as you're working on this.
We agree with Member Ortiz-Licn about the equity report.
I know what the intent was.
It didn't quite work out that way.
We think maybe some more work should be done to provide perhaps an equity indicator for each of the indicators to flag what's going on with subgroup performance.
And then lastly, we would suggest that you take another look at the cut scores for the academic indicator.
We came across a couple of instances where schools were rated blue or green and maybe fewer than half the students were meeting standards.
So we think we need a little bit more of an ambitious standard for the academic indicator.
Good morning, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, representing the California Association for Bilingual Education, and we concur with the statements made by Shelly Spiegel Coleman on behalf of Californians Together.
We appreciate the fact that the LTEL data will be included in the English Learner Progress
indicator as extra credit, but we also do support the recommendation that the LTEL data be also included on the California School Dashboard in order for schools and districts to be able to see the progress and monitor the progress of this vulnerable population, the LTELs.
Additionally, when the statement is made that a decision in September, that the decision has been deferred to September in order to view the indicators more holistically, we would like to know as a public, what does that mean?
Does that mean that there are going to be additional criteria looked at at some of these indicators or what?
So we would appreciate just more clarification on that.
Thank you.
I'd like to ask the final group of speakers to line up.
Could we please have Martha Alvarez, Michael McCormick, Liza Moms, Christy Sinclair, Jason Henderson line up.
Good morning, Sarah Lillis.
We are excited and appreciate the fact that you are digging into the issue of how to deal with students in alternative schools and incorporate them into the system.
We're concerned that we won't have any data until fall 2018.
And we're also concerned that they're not currently
included in the measurement in the dashboard and measurements of districts.
The legislature wrestled with this.
Superintendent remembers Senator Steinberg and others passed a law to make sure that these students were not only counted in the districts but in the schools that were referring them because there are incentives involved in how you measure the outcomes of these students.
And so that statute is set to would be repealed with
the superintendent's proposed legislation of AB 1661, but there are really important incentives involved.
And so I would urge you to take Cindy's invitation for data to consider for adding to the dashboard in September to look at what it would mean to incorporate students in alternative schools into the district academic outcomes and other outcomes for the next iteration, as well as to be a broken record high school academic, a separate high school academic indicator.
Good morning, Samantha Tran with Children Now.
And I similarly want to focus in on the alternative education piece.
We do appreciate the dialogue around alternative education schools.
I think we could find that there are indicators that may not only apply in that setting, but that we might include in the broader system, like, for example, credit recovery and thinking through those as a state.
There are two separate issues here, though.
There's how we think about alternative schools.
And then there's the district level piece that Sarah just mentioned.
We're really concerned that these kids are invisible in the system right now and we're talking about one out of every five seniors that at one point or another goes into an alternative education setting and it is the quickest way to drop out.
30% of those kids graduate, the others don't.
So we really need to dig into this and think about the incentives.
I do think current statute provides a way to think about it.
We'd welcome that policy conversation with the board about, you know, where do you tag those kids back and
you know, how we think about it at the district and county levels.
Because as was mentioned earlier, a lot of these schools are sitting side by side with the traditional school.
Thank you very much.
Good morning.
I'm Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
Firstly, I want to make sure that you know, we appreciate so much the continued engagement that staff has been demonstrating with us and our allies and partners around the work they're doing.
We know they have a lot of work to do.
But it is really concerning that in the timeline,
there's no reference to continuous work on the local indicators.
That's especially concerning because of the report that only 14 local educational agencies have reported on them in the dashboard.
We want you to focus on that, please.
And I want to remind you about last year, about this time, all the hundreds of students and parents that were here saying, measure our success.
The local indicators are such a critical part of multiple measures.
In addition, we know that more resources will be needed by.
everyone and we urge you to work with the administration and the legislature to get them and we will work side by side with you on that.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Martha Alvarez with AXA, the Association of California School Administrators.
Welcome to the new board member.
We're happy to see you here.
On behalf of AXA, we support the staff recommendation on the alternative accountability item, and we look forward to the discussion in July regarding the definition and how to expand it.
We also support the staff direction in the future about the EL progress indicator and including the extra credit for the long-term EL students.
There's two items that are not specifically discussed today, and that's the LCAP addendum that was discussed by the CPAC at their meeting last month.
And we'd like to receive more information about the pilot that will happen in 17-18.
It's not clear whether the State Board will be having to adopt the LCAP addendum before that pilot begins.
We at ACCESS stand ready to support that effort to ensure more school districts apply when that happens.
Similarly with the local indicator self-reflection tools, thank you board member Burr for acknowledging that we need to do a better job about reaching out to the field to ensure that they take advantage of this opportunity to do the self-reflection tools.
So I'll be taking that back to our office.
And lastly, the dashboard.
We will get more feedback to your staff.
We appreciate all the stakeholder engagement and we'll continue to let you know what the field thinks.
Thank you.
Good morning.
It's Elias Hernandez with the Mexican American Opportunity Foundation.
We are the California's second largest nonprofit.
And on behalf of our 1,000 employees and 10,000 parents currently going through our child care services and whom students will be attending our public school system soon, we appreciate the first version of the dashboard and applaud you for all the work that you've been doing.
Specifically, board member Ortiz for continuing the conversation in Los Angeles.
With that said, we urge the following recommendations.
The dashboard should show if a school is receiving targeted or comprehensive support based on its performance or the performance of particular groups of students.
In addition, the dashboard should demonstrate that equity matters.
So the performance of subgroups should carry substantial weight in the raw rating that the school receives.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Ida Bautista and I'm also from the Mexican American Opportunity Foundation, and I'm here on behalf of the Spanish speaker parents.
There's a concern about the language translation.
they really are encouraging you to focus on that because if it's one of the indicators is parent engagement for them is how can they engage if the dashboard is not in their language, native language, so they can help the children.
So, that's one of the concerns that they have the parents.
Also, another concern that they have is the colors.
I know colors are very easy to identify, but they also want numerical goals for them to see and based on that, because that way they can see the long-term impact on the children's education and also for other kids.
And like Isaias said in the previous, we have a lot of kids in our programs that are going to enter the public schools in the future and want them to be prepared, want parents to be involved, because like I said, it's parents
Educators and children, that's the key.
We all have to work as a team to be successful.
So please, time for some consideration, okay?
Thank you very much and have a wonderful day.
Hello, good morning.
My name is Lang Luntown.
I'm a member of the Board of Trustees with the Stockton Unified School District.
Excuse me, Stockton Unified School District.
Thank you to the superintendent, the board, and particularly our student board member.
What an awesome thing to have a full student board member sitting on the board with you all.
I'm here along with some colleagues from the South Stockton Schools Initiative to echo what you've already heard from COPE.
the PTA around increasing the usability of the California Schools Dashboard.
I'm a teacher, obviously a member of the school board, wrote my charter school's LCAP, have a Harvard degree, and I still find the dashboard mind-boggling to use.
You'll also hear from some of our parents that I think we're still struggling to make this information accessible and really actionable for our students and also our policy makers.
So I know that you've already seen the draft
Proposal from the Education Trust West, I'd like to echo that.
But I just would like to echo that in the state that birthed Google and Facebook, I find it beyond comprehension that we can't find a more user-friendly tool.
And I hope that in the spirit of continued improvement, you can continue improving this tool, please.
Thank you.
Hi, good morning.
My name is Nancy Huantasin Sun, and I'm speaking on behalf of some of our Spanish-speaking parents who couldn't be here and who are also involved in the South Stockton Schools Initiative in Stockton.
So again, thank you for your time.
I'll be speaking about the dashboard specifically, and we have two urgent recommendations of which already been kind of called out for through these other organizations, but basically the translation to Spanish.
That really, when we had our workshop on the dashboard, that really became a large concern because using Google Translate wasn't really particularly safe.
A lot of words didn't easily translate as well.
It was a wrong translation.
So we urge you to take a look at that.
And for sure, in terms of accessibility, that's the first red flag that we saw.
And then the second one that a lot of us are particular and hope that we can work with you is this conversation about equity matters.
And so thinking about the performance of subgroups and thinking about like what are we looking at in terms of equity?
What are those indicators?
And so we look forward to hearing those conversations and working with you all for sure.
Thank you.
Hola.
Mi nombre es Guadalupe Chavez.
Vengo del distrito de Stockton.
Y tambin vengo con mis compaeros... Wait a minute.
We have a translator coming in.
Okay.
Good morning, my name is Guadalupe Chavez.
And I come from the Stockton district.
And I represent the organization of schools for South Stockton.
And I want to thank you for the information provided in the dashboard.
But for us parents who have very little knowledge of how to use a computer, we are interested in the academics.
And in addition to the color coding that's provided in the dashboard,
we would like to see some sort of a percentage at the beginning of the page.
Eso fuera ms prctico y mejor comprendido para nosotros los lectores.
This would be more practical and easier to understand for us readers.
Y sobre todo la traduccin que nos cuesta mucho trabajo entender palabras que se utilizan en el dashboard.
And especially the translation, we have a hard time understanding the words that are used in the dashboard.
Ya que nosotros, el distrito de Stockton es uno de los distritos que es ms campesinos.
And the Stockton district has a large population of field workers.
Y nos cuesta mucho trabajo en entender las grficas por medio de colores.
And we have a hard time understanding the color graphics.
And we hope that you take this into account so that us field workers can help our children achieve professional development.
Thank you.
Hey, one more, yes.
Go ahead, come up.
I'm sorry.
Hello, my name is Ileana Huante.
I am a parent organizer for South Stockton Schools Initiative and I am a parent myself.
I have a little recommendation for the dashboard.
I think you guys should create an app for smartphones so it could be more accessible for parents.
And it would be pretty cool because...
Just like Class Dojo, I think it would be easier for me and my kids to sit down together and look at the colors, the numbers together as a family and then create plans.
And that's it.
Thank you for having me here.
That's the end of the public comment.
So I think we're now ready for
discussion and on the motion which is in your packet.
So I'm going to make a motion that the State Board of Education approve the development of an application process to require alternative schools of choice and charter schools, those schools not explicitly defined as alternative schools in the Ed Code, Section 52052, to recertify every three years that at least 70% of their enrollment is comprised of high-risk students.
as defined in the SBE approved eligibility criteria in order to continue participating as an alternative school in the accountability system.
Second.
All right, any further board discussion on this motion?
Okay, questions of course.
There was a point of clarification.
I think we should clarify why we're voting for the indicator and inclusion of the LTELs in September.
And you said because there may be some things that may change.
So there was a question out there.
What can possibly change with the academic indicator or with the indicators?
So we could just clarify what was meant by that before we take this vote.
So in attachment four, there is a timeline broken up into six-month increments about what we'll be taking to you come September.
And so I think that clarifies the various items.
The college career indicator is one.
For academic indicator, we may bring to you actually as early as July our initial calculations with the California alternate assessment because we have first-year results there.
So that would be the academic indicator change.
It's not specifically around English learners.
It's around other things.
in order to provide you a full complement of all the changes to the dashboard at once.
That is why we are waiting until September for the English Learner Progress Indicator to make those changes.
Okay, no further discussion.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, that carries unanimously.
Thank you.
So now we're on to item two.
Yes.
And Michelle Center will present this item concerning the California assessment of student progress.
Good morning, Superintendent Torlakson, Board President Kirsten, members of the board.
Before I start in celebration of Teacher Appreciation Week, I need to acknowledge my high school science teacher, Mrs. Vera Bryant.
who not only was my high school science teacher, but took an interest in me personally.
And I know we all have those teachers that we remember because they went the extra mile and thought of you even outside of your classroom.
So I wanted to take a moment to recognize Mrs. Bryant.
And also, as Superintendent Torlakson mentioned, we had an amazing day yesterday where we had almost half a million students testing at the same time.
which I've had some stomach pains over the last week as these numbers continue to climb.
But I do want to also acknowledge that last week as our numbers started to increase beyond what we originally anticipated,
Our contractor, ETS, as well as our subcontractor, AIR, were there, right there with us.
And they actually added capacity to our systems immediately so that we could have that load that we had yesterday.
So, acknowledge them for doing that work, whatever night that was, Wednesday night and then over the weekend.
So, if we, you know, even go beyond that number, we're ready.
So, want to acknowledge them before we go on to the item that you have before you.
So, this is an action item and as a reminder, I was here in March and you directed the CDE to enter into negotiations with our CASP contractor, ETS, and to come back to you with a proposed amendment to that contract.
Following that approval at the March meeting, the CDE, SBE staff and Department of Finance staff entered into contract negotiations with ETS.
And I'm returning today to request that you, the board, approve the proposed CASP contract amendment and you also authorize your SBE Executive Director to approve any technical edits as needed.
Before I go on, I must start by thanking all the participants that helped with this.
This was a very collaborative effort, what you see in front of you, that we have engaged in over the last couple of months.
A special thanks to all the California Department of Education divisions who have assisted, including the Analysis, Measurement and Reporting Division, the Technology Services Division, Legal Affairs, Personnel Services Division, and of course, my own staff within the Assessment Division.
Also a special thank you Department of Finance and State Board of Education staff and of course to our contractor ETS.
I'd like to also point out that in the audience back there is from ETS John Oswald.
He's the Vice President of Client Relations and Outreach and he's here today in case you have any questions of our contractor.
So I'm not going to go over all 300 pages because, you know, we might want to lunch.
So instead, I'm just going to highlight a few of the changes that you will find in the contract.
So as a reminder, the reason why we are bringing this contract amendment before the board is because we have added additional funds to the contract, which then requires your action.
The additional funds is approximately $1.5 million that is currently funded in the governor's proposed budget.
As with every contract that we enter into, there's also a language that says it's contingent upon us receiving funding.
So I wanted to make sure you were aware of that also.
I also want to orient you, because this is a rather large item, that Attachment 1 is a concordance table that summarizes the edits in the contract.
And Attachments 2 through 4 actually make up the contract amendment.
So when you hopefully approve the contract amendment today, actually the action is related to Attachments 2 through 4.
So let me go through a few of the highlighted changes.
I'm pleased to share that the contract allows for enhancements to our system so that we can take advantage of reporting out on our interim assessments student level item responses.
This will assist our educators in the interpretation of the interim results.
We also have an additional enhancement to the online reporting system.
As a reminder, the online reporting system is for our summative assessments.
We will be adding to that rubric scores for our English Language Arts portion specific to the Long Ride.
That item is scored on three rubrics, organization and purpose, evidence and elaboration, and conventions.
And we will be having those scores reported in the online reporting system beginning in 2018.
We also have an amendment that allows for, as we all know, we have to continually field test items so that we have items on the Smarter Balanced Summative Assessments and Interim Assessments.
In order to do that, the amendment includes the work that our contractor is responsible for so that we can deliver those embedded performance tasks without increasing testing time for our students.
I'm also very excited to say that we've been able to add some professional learning opportunities in this amendment.
ETS will be partnering with WestEd to develop a CASP Science Academy.
This professional learning opportunity will build capacity for the implementation of the California Next Generation Science Standards.
It will support the understanding of how the new science assessment item types can inform teaching and learning.
So those are the highlights that I wanted to share with you today and I'm open to any questions.
Though I don't have all 300 pages memorized.
So there are questions of, I have a question.
You talk about training tests, practice training tests.
Can you elaborate on what that means and how that relates to the interim tests and all those, all these terms?
I'm confused.
So the practice and training tests for our assessments are really to help our students, one, familiarize themselves with the platform.
They are not required to actually have an interim assessment administered to them in order to familiarize themselves with how to use the online assessment system.
We also know that our educators find those useful to show students how to access and use certain supports that are available on the system.
While those students may, for example, have use of a similar support in the classroom, that support may not display the same as an online system.
So they use those types of practice and training tests to familiarize the students with, for example, what does a glossary look like?
The ASL videos, how you can display those and actually slow them down and rewind and all of those types of familiarization with the system can be done using this.
Other questions by the board members before we have public comment?
If not, we're ready for public comment.
I would just say, again, congratulations to Michelle and the team.
They did a fabulous job and it was truly a team effort, but a lot of hours, a lot of focused talent.
I think she's getting the sheet.
Yes, go ahead.
Just as a practitioner, and our district is beginning the testing next week, we kind of put it to the end of the schedule.
And knowing how many successful log-ons you were able to do, I think that that's a great sign.
But I'm also concerned that the infrastructure of technology in and of itself has allowed us to do that.
And a lot of districts bought it with one-time money.
So there needs to be some kind of an infrastructure for a refresh down the line to support CASP ongoing.
That's just a comment I wanted to make.
We have two people for public comment Sarah Lillis and Doug McRae
Good morning, Sarah Lillis with EdVoice.
We're encouraged to see that addition of the contract to test the growth models.
We're very excited about that.
We would just ask, sorry I ran here.
We would just ask that with the three models that are decided to be tested, there be a public conversation about how those, what those three models are, how that's determined before it gets tested with ETS.
again not to be a broken record, but we would really love for there to be as part of the deliverables in alignment with AB 484 that ETS is actually providing formative assessment tools, not just the digital library which is the container, the holder of those things, but the actual tools themselves.
Thank you.
Good morning, I'm Doug McRae, a testing specialist from NRA.
In addition to the four pages of detailed observations on the agenda materials for this item that I just submitted to your electronic folder last week, I'm now circulating a one-page handout listing priority issues for state board consideration.
The handout lists three issues focused on the analysis of test results and the timing for public release of test results, especially the provision for floor and ceiling data that define the functional range of each Smarter Balanced test, not only for statewide results, but also for school and district results at the subgrade level.
This data is vital for adequate interpretation of results, yet it's currently not provided.
The handout also lists four cost-saving topics that could improve spending to the tune of $4 to $6 million on this annual $80 million contract.
I'd be happy to answer any questions on the topics listed.
Okay, that ends the public comment.
I'd like to, Michelle, for you to comment perhaps on the formative assessments.
And so it's back to my, the formative assessments, there's interim assessments.
Just walk us through where we are on these now and where it's going with this contract.
Sure, sure.
So the interim assessments, we are very fortunate to have a state that dedicated funds for the purchase of the full suite of Smarter Balanced so that our schools and districts and educators have access to the interim assessments.
The interim assessments are valuable for our educators during the school year so that they can have those checks of understanding throughout the year.
That being said, California continues to have conversations with Smarter Balanced.
And we continue to engage with other states that are in the consortium to find additional ways to have instructional relevance with those interims.
And I feel like we're making some progress in that area that I hopefully will be able to share with you at a future board meeting.
In terms of formative assessments, I try not to actually use that term and prefer to talk about formative as a process.
And Smarter Balanced dictates, has information on the process and has a digital library with formative assessment resources and tools available for use.
We currently have, I can't remember, 10,000, is Tony in the room?
10,000-ish?
No?
He's not going to tell me how many.
What we have, we have resources within the digital library and we continue to have educators access that.
I reported last time about the login attempts that we now have teachers that can do that without relying on their LEAs to sign them up.
We continue to have teachers actually use that self-login registration and have additional accounts created.
We had, I think, about six million administrations of interim assessments this school year.
So, we know that our educators are giving them and are finding a use and purpose for those.
We, Smarter Balanced has a, what we call connection documents that I talked to you about before, which really tries to draw the connections between giving an interim, finding out that information about students, and then diving into the digital library and specific resources that may be useful
depending on how the students scored on the interim.
So that loop, if you will, is really outlined in the connections document that Smarter Balanced has created with the assistance of educators across the consortium states.
Board Member Rocker.
Okay, so I do want to thank you, Michelle, because this contract does represent a significant amount of work and a large body of assessment shifts that will occur because of the implementation of this contract.
California is a state where the law of large numbers can create some really impressive data.
So testing half, almost half a million students in a single day is a really significant number.
And then, but that almost pales to hear that six million administrations of the interim assessments have also been done during this year.
But the point of this contract really is to create some type of view of a value added about the work that's being done, not only with the interim assessments, but with the other tools that are supposed to be available for teachers to support the assessments that are happening right now.
There is a gap in perception about the value of these interim assessments between what we're expecting here in this room and on this dais and what many people in the field believe is going on with the interim assessments.
What this contract will do is expand not only the types of services that are being provided in support of the interims,
It'll also expand and continue the state's work to add to its accountability tool chest with the development and testing of a growth model.
What this contract will not fix are some of the misunderstandings in the district about the use of these tools, about the types of accessibility tools that are available to students.
It won't fix the problem that districts think
that if they allow students to use accommodations or the accessibility tools that it nullifies the outcome and the student scores.
It won't fix the problem that districts are not allowing teachers a variety of options on how they use the interim assessments.
So I'm very happy to know we have six million people or six million times that the assessments were used, but how were they used?
Were they treated like a benchmark event or were teachers actually allowed to embed them in their instruction or choose to use the assessments and not score them?
How were they used?
Were teachers allowed to have them use out of grade level activities for choosing assessments?
That's the stuff that's not known and frankly,
That's the problem that creates a difference in the perception about what's perceived as the value of the assessments here and the work that this contract represents and the value that is not seen in the field really and truly for using the assessments and the type of data that the assessments are supposed to give back.
So in implementing this contract, assuming that it's approved today, improved today and approved by the board, I think this also defines or even frames for your department the work that has to be done to create some type of messaging to the field
not only about what's been changed and added to the contract and the suite of supports that are being provided, but to clarify what the field should be doing and how they should use it.
So I'm glad to see the work that's being undertaken by the contractor.
with a substantial enhancement from the legislature to the budget.
But I think that there are some enhancements about what is communicated to the field.
And I wish there was some way to hold the field accountable for not just getting the memo, but reading the memo and implementing it appropriately.
Because that's where the gap and what's going on with this work and the work that this contract represents really rests.
Member Burr.
First, I just want to echo Superintendent Torlakson's comments about gratitude for the level of work.
Whenever we have to go through these contracts, it's a massive undertaking.
It takes lots of teamwork between the department and the board staff.
Member Sun, who's the other assessment liaison, and I had a lot of opportunity to review this and have conversations with Michelle and her staff.
And I'm confident that they've done an excellent job.
So with that, I would like to move the department recommendation to approve the contract.
Second.
Okay, is there any further discussion?
I have a comment that I think the work in here on growth models is very important and we should think about perhaps having a board information item on that at some point.
We get all this discussion about closing achievement gaps and you and I keep saying we need a growth model to really work that out.
I mean, that's not something, and here we are, and they're technical.
So these are important and I'm not...
quite sure what the options are.
I know the prior board was entranced with a model used by the state of Colorado, but they were using it for value-added teacher evaluation.
That's not what we're doing here.
So, I think that it is an interesting issue, and it's more than a technical issue, and it's difficult to convey.
I must admit I'm not a total
totally understand how different growth models work.
So, I don't know whether you want to comment on that or not.
I think that Cindy Kazanis also highlighted in her item in one that we are working together to write an information memorandum for you for next month that will provide you an update on where we are in terms of the work on the growth model.
And we will continue, of course, to engage in conversations and provide you updates.
Okay, thank you.
I have been here before talking about growth models and setting of priorities for our growth model.
And I also was lucky enough to recently attend the Smarter Balanced Technical Advisory Committee meeting where they also discussed growth models at that meeting.
So we will be also providing you some information on the work that the consortium is doing in that memo.
We are in this with other states, so that's, I think, very useful, actually, to get a couple of, to have 15 states looking at this as well as us as one of the 15.
All right, with no further discussion, all those in favor of this motion?
Okay, that carries unanimously.
And let's see, we can start on item three.
We're going to start then on item three.
We have quite a bit of presentation on this, and we will obviously not complete this, but we will break for lunch.
But I think we're ready for the item three.
But before we proceed, I want to stress that what we're considering here today is really a document that is incomplete and for public comment.
So our move is really to have something that people can react to, but we're not pretending that this is a finished document.
And we're really seeing it as a document to inspire public comment and to give them something specific enough to react to.
And so there are many things that are not decided in here.
And I also think people need to look at this federal document in two ways that often aren't thought about.
One,
we're doing an integrated system of accountability.
So some of the concerns people talk about in the federal document are covered in our state accountability policies that we have been enacting over the past two to three years.
And so you just can't look at the federal document as a standalone document.
People have to understand
that we've already done a lot of work that is in the state documents and state approvals that we have done.
And finally, I would say as a framing, last time we talked a lot about the purpose of this document and it is a state plan for the federal government.
And the federal government provides about three to four percent of the total money we spend in this particular bunch of federal aid we're considering.
We don't have special education in this.
And so this is a document that is prepared for them, that is in effect a contract with them, which they will send outside monitors in to hold us accountable to.
So, our last time we discussed, there may be items in this that we don't want to put into a federal document because they will hold it to us contractually.
Now, some of the people out there may have a high level of confidence in the Federal Department of Education, but
But that being said, there are things we can do on policy that are very useful that we don't have to sign a contract with the federal government about.
And so we're sort of thinking about that as ways of
of what this purpose is for and more of a holistic view of policies we've made in the past and where we should make policy in the future in terms of a federal contract as against doing it through our state accountability and other many, many issues that are discussed here.
With that, I'll have Barbara start presenting.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Kerse, board members, Superintendent Torlakson.
And I think, you know, President Kerse has pretty much summarized it.
We're good.
I'll sit back down.
No, but it's really true as, you know, in the year and change that we've been kind of grappling with the plan and all the new developments, certainly trying to find that sweet spot.
has been a challenge.
But anyway, we're continuing our journey in that.
The purpose of this item is to provide you and the public with an update regarding progress in the development of the Every Student Succeeds Act.
Are you seeing?
All right.
Is it running?
Yes.
Awesome.
Thank you.
So we recommend that the board approve the draft as a state plan for the statutorily required 30-day public comment period.
And we plan to bring a final draft to you for approval in September of 2017.
Before we get into the plan, I want to provide you with a quick update on the ESSA assurances.
You'll recall that at the March meeting, the status of the assurances was in flux.
We knew that they were going to be revised to remove references to the now rescinded regulations, but we didn't really know exactly when they would be due or what they would contain.
And you authorized President Kirsch to sign and submit the assurances by the due date that would be established by ED.
So since your last meeting on April 27th, ED published a revised assurances template for public comment.
The public comment period ended last week on May 5th, and we anticipate that the final template will be available soon.
So we still do not have the final template for the assurances.
We do know that the signed assurances will be due to ED on June 2nd.
before we see you again.
So you don't really need to take any action on this today, because you've already authorized President Kirst to sign those assurances on your behalf.
Right.
It's sort of the way things are moving with the assurances and ESSA in general.
New information coming from the feds on a regular basis.
You don't need to take any action today because your action in March still stands with President Cruz being authorized to sign those on our behalf.
But I just wanted to give you the update so you knew what was happening with that.
Later on, I'm going to bring to your attention some changes in the budget that obviously the federal budget has settled out a little bit and that has some impact on the document in front of you as well, but we'll get to that in a minute.
So here are ESSA state plan guiding principles.
Recall at your January meeting you approved this set of guiding principles.
The principles state that our plan will support the creation of a single coherent local state and federal accountability and continuous improvement system with the state priorities and direction.
Come on now.
And opportunities in the ESSA leverage to assist in accomplishing the state goals and objectives.
These principles also reflect our commitment to updating federally required applications and plans to reinforce and align with state priorities and to use ESSA resources to support the implementation of rigorous standards and the principles of equity, local control, and continuous improvement that drive our LCFF-based system.
These principles have driven the development of the state plan you have before you today.
So I think it's worth reiterating what President Kurz said at the outset.
This is not the final draft of the plan.
As pleased as we are to have a complete working draft to share with you today, we are not recommending that you approve this plan for submission to ED today.
Today, we really just have the opportunity to discuss the contents of the plan and to make any changes that you deem necessary before we take the draft plan out for the public comment period.
There are going to be many opportunities for stakeholders, including the California Practitioners Advisory Group, to revisit, discuss, and comment on the document and for you to provide revisions based on that comment before we submit the plan on September 18th.
As you can see on this slide, we plan to ask you to approve the plan in September.
You'll be provided feedback on the draft at both the July and September meetings.
So in June, we're going to bring the plan to the CPAC for their feedback, which we will bring you in July.
And then in September, we'll bring you the public comment feedback and how CPAC recommends moving forward with the public comment feedback and have some good conversations about refinements before we submit in September 18th.
So it's been some time.
This is my seventh time before you just talking about the ESSA State Plan.
We've had some ups and downs and backs and forth.
So I think it's worth taking a moment to just talk about, you know, this plan has been developed using inputs gathered from really thousands of California stakeholders in the last year and change.
We've had a number of phases of stakeholder engagement.
certainly been based on your discussion and the direction we have gotten from you over the last several meetings.
And it also reflects really extensive contributions from board staff and the work of really dozens of department staff here.
So I think it's probably worth taking a moment to thank all those folks and all of our county office partners and our other associations and organizations that have helped us to get to this point.
Per your direction at the March meeting, the plan has been written at a relatively high level which will afford us maximum flexibility to design programs and activities that are aligned with our LCFF based system.
So a week after we were last together in March, ED made available a new template, our third template.
As anticipated, this new template was greatly streamlined with all of the regulatory requirements except those for assessments removed.
Previous templates were organized thematically.
This new template is organized by program.
So as you'll note, it goes instead of thinking more holistically, how do we support teachers?
How do we support schools?
How do we support students?
It goes through the programs, Title 1A, Title 1C, Title 1D.
So that's fine.
We've had a lot of conversations in the last year around braiding resources across programs.
We've been trying to think really holistically as well.
And I think that's still our intent, but it may not, the new template doesn't really lend itself to the description of that coherent system because it is broken out into programs.
So it's a little different than some of the drafts that you and the public have seen in the past.
So when you look at the document, you'll notice that we have placed our responses to each prompt in the template in shaded text boxes.
Just hopefully that'll make it a little easier to read.
It's a pretty dense document.
And we've also provided what we think is a super helpful glossary of terms and acronyms, a glossary I wish I had seven years ago or even three years ago, with links to more information for those who are interested in learning more about any particular program or entity.
And finally, and I think this is really important as well, just in terms of how the document is organized, the draft plan contains quite a bit of contextual information that will not be submitted to ED.
Okay, in keeping with this is an application, a contract,
We don't need to send all of that context to ED, but we think it's really helpful to provide that context for stakeholders as we go out and talk about the plan.
How does this all fit together?
So we've included an introduction to provide more context for the entire plan, and we've included italicized text throughout the document where more contextual information we thought might be helpful.
These elements will be removed before we submit the plan in September.
So the plan contains a lot of information.
I think, you know, for our time together today, it feels important to frame the document and today's discussion how we think best to approach today's time together a little bit.
As you review the plan, you'll note that there are fundamentally three types of responses.
The great majority of the plan, most of the responses are based upon previous board action or discussion.
You've done so much work in the last half dozen years and much of that is what's reflected in the plan.
We do not necessarily need to discuss these topics today, nor do we want to bring these topics to stakeholders for additional feedback unless you decide that that would be helpful.
So there's that set of things that feel relatively set.
Then, for a number of responses, you and stakeholders have been presented information and discussed the topic, but the way forward has not yet been formally agreed upon, right?
So we don't have action on those.
Four of those topics will be the focus of our presentation today, as we hope to include your decisions in the plan that we submit to ED in September.
The third type of response represents content that is much less well defined.
This content may not be fully defined by the time we submit the plan in September.
So I want to take a couple of minutes to discuss these topics now.
So our statewide system of support.
So you will note that there are multiple references to the statewide system of support across the plan.
You'll note it referenced in many different places.
For more than a year, department staff has engaged in extensive conversation with a wide variety of stakeholders across the state and presented information to you regarding what the elements of this system might look like.
How can we best support students, educators, and schools?
Should we leverage the optional title to reservation to support school leaders?
How should we support our lowest performing schools?
How should we use our required reservations to improve student outcomes?
How will all of this work in concert with the state system of support?
Certainly, we've had lots of conversation and lots of material around this.
As these conversations have progressed, several really important themes have emerged.
First,
There's a really deep commitment to aligning the system that is funded with federal dollars to California's existing LCFF-based system, integrating the two to the greatest extent possible.
So I know that's really your intent and is reflected in those guiding principles, but it's something that's, I think, shared by stakeholders across the state.
They are really excited at this opportunity to bring all of these pieces together and not have separate systems.
It's consistent with our ESSA guiding principles.
It's very important that California's system drive the use of ESSA resources, not the other way around.
Second, there's a really deep commitment across the entities who will be providing supports to districts and schools to collaborate systematically to maximize our collective impact and avoid redundancy of effort.
We've had some good conversations around that with a variety of different folks, the collaborative, county offices, CTC, Subject Matter Project.
How can we all really work together so that we aren't doing separate things to different ends?
And third, putting all of these pieces together in a way that's supported by evidence is really complicated and is likely to benefit from more extensive stakeholder input.
We anticipate that we'll present to you an information memorandum in June and an agenda item in July to serve as a basis for continued discussion around the development of the state system of support.
Because this conversation is likely to extend beyond September and the state system of support is not likely to be defined in great detail in the plan, we don't recommend that we discuss this at any length today.
It will be coming back to you.
The other topic for which we would like you to postpone discussion is the ESSA ineffective teacher requirement.
As you know, to promote equitable access to teachers, ESSA requires states to collect and report data regarding ineffective teachers and the students that they serve.
California doesn't currently have a definition for ineffective, so we're going to need to address this.
It's important that we address this in a manner that's consistent with the California way.
We really want to make sure that we respect local collective bargaining agreements, facilitate cooperation between teachers and school leadership, really avoiding mislabeling people and schools.
That's something that's not really consistent with our continuous improvement mindset.
And we want to ensure that all students have equitable access to good teachers.
So that would take a little bit of time.
We've had some preliminary conversations with some stakeholders on the best way to move forward, but staff believes this conversation will benefit from more discussion.
The CDE plans to engage with additional stakeholders, many of which are listed on this slide this month and next, and to bring preliminary findings to you at your next meeting in July.
So with all of that said, we're looking forward to taking the plan out for phase four of ESSA stakeholder engagement.
As you can see on this slide, we're planning another series of regional meetings in partnership with county offices across the state, with several scheduled in the evening this time to make it easier for teachers, parents, and principals to participate.
Also, last month, a group of representatives from the Equity Coalition offered to partner with us to engage more parents and community members.
And we're in the process of designing and scheduling those meetings right now.
So we're very thankful to them for that offer.
The department is also going to host or co-host several online meetings during the public comment period.
We're scheduled to co-host a webinar with ACSA and CSBA on May 24th and are in the process of scheduling additional webinars with other stakeholder organizations.
Our intent is to be able to tailor the content of those webinars to those particular stakeholder groups.
We're also building, as we did in phase two, a toolkit of resources so that stakeholders who can't attend a meeting in person or online can learn more about the plan and provide feedback.
These tools will include the state plan broken up into smaller sections, videos to accompany each section, a facilitator guide, and a link to the survey in which people can provide feedback.
Our hope is that people use these tools to facilitate local meetings, but we think that they'll be useful to just an individual who wants to provide feedback and doesn't want to host or participate in a meeting.
We're going to promote all of these stakeholder events using a number of strategies, including a letter from Superintendent Torlakson inviting everyone to participate, social media, and listserv messages from a variety of our CDE listservs.
So our objectives for today, Deputy Superintendent Carrick Ashley will be up in a minute to facilitate, or maybe after lunch, I'm not sure what you're thinking.
Deputy Superintendent Ashley will be up in a minute to facilitate discussion around four topics on this slide.
We also want to make sure we have time today to address questions that you may have regarding additional plan sections, right?
So these are our main topics, but we do want to have conversation with you around other plan sections.
And a number of my colleagues are here to support that.
And by the end of this item, we want to recommend that you approve the plan again, just to take it out for the 30-day public comment period.
So as we move through this presentation and the discussion and the public comment today, I want you to keep in mind, it'll be really helpful to the department as we go out with phase four, to please keep in mind the question on the bottom of the screen.
All right, because we've been talking about a lot of the elements of this plan.
for a year and much more in terms of some of those accountability sections, right?
We've been talking about a lot of this.
We want to make sure to make the most of this public comment period.
We don't want to ask people questions around things that are pretty well decided.
We do want to ask people questions that will help you all to make
to answer the questions you have around what we are going to include in this plan, right?
So as the discussion goes on today, I will be sitting back there listening very intently.
Where do you want more information?
What do you want to hear from stakeholders?
Because that will really help us to maximize phase four.
The other very quick note I wanted to bring your attention to on page 67 of the plan.
At the outset, I said, well, the assurances are settling out but aren't quite settled out.
The federal budget has settled out to some extent, but it settled out too recently for us to update our fiscal analysis at the front of the item.
So in July, we'll provide you with an updated current fiscal analysis.
But there is one piece on page 67 of the plan
Title IV Part A funds.
used to be required to send them to LEAs via a formulary process.
And through this budget that was just approved, the amount of Title IV-A funds has been decreased pretty significantly.
But states have been given the flexibility to award those funds either by a formulary process or by a competitive process.
So right now, and this is all happening in real time, right now page 67 describes that formulary process.
That's something we'll need to go back in and look at.
Do we want to do this by formula?
Do we want to do this by competitive?
So, it's something to be thinking about.
And I think that's all I have for now.
Shall we invite Carrick up?
Are you ready for lunch?
I just wonder if there were any, you know, this is largely procedural, which we, on that list of meetings, was there one in the San Francisco Bay Area?
Did I miss?
There is not one in the San Francisco Bay Area this time around.
We have Sacramento and Stanislaus.
Okay.
Yeah, there's 7.3 million people in the inner seven counties of the Bay Area and that would be the size of a number of states.
So I, you know, sort of caught my eye.
Well, we can work.
We have done some in Alameda previously and I've done meetings in Marin previously.
It's one of the, you know, with 58 counties.
It's hard to get to all of them every time, but that's something we can look into.
That's also part of the webinar strategy beyond our partnered webinars.
We also have just here are some CDE webinars typically on a Saturday morning and three to five so that folks who can't make it to a meeting
are able to participate in an online meeting.
But if you'd like us to reach out to our colleagues now in San Francisco and Alameda.
Yeah, I'll leave that up to you.
Okay.
The other thing when you do the federal funds, it looks like there was an increase for Title I. Okay, first of all, California districts used to have to reserve money for supplementary educational services.
And so that is gone and that goes right back into their base.
So unlike some states that were operating under waivers or our core waiver states, they, you know, we had this money going out the door for SES.
So I'd like to know something about that amount.
Secondly, the SIG money was folded back in.
It shows up in the federal budget as zero, but it was folded back into Title I.
And so it goes into the Title I formula, so I'd like some explanation of that when you do the federal.
And lastly, there was some increase put into Title I by the Congress in this budget.
So it looks like we're up some to me in real terms, particularly when you look at the SES money, but no?
There was a nominal increase in what happened a couple of weeks ago, but I think it's important to remember that although SES is gone and program improvement is gone, there is now a 7% reduction of Title I off the top for schools that are identified for comprehensive and targeted assistance.
So again, we haven't had a chance to formally look at this, but I think California may stand to make a little bit more money than projected, but I think the impact
at the LEA level is with the 7% mandatory set-aside reservation off of the top of the Title I money, I'm not sure that it trickles down.
Something to think about.
All right.
Yeah.
It's just a number of factors that are obscured by the way the federal budget is presented in the paper.
Absolutely.
Okay.
So, we will take a break and this is scheduled for 45 minutes for lunch.
So, we'll come back at 10 of 1, 12.50.
Thank you.
Okay, the board will reconvene and we're ready for the presentation on item three by Carrick Ashley.
Good afternoon.
Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent.
In honor of Teacher Appreciation Week, I would like to recognize those in my family who are current teachers and former teachers.
My father, Donald, my sister, Jane, and sister-in-law, Annie, my brother, Sean, and sister-in-law, Sylvia, my nephew, Thurman, my sister-in-law, Ruth, my niece, Allison, my wife, Jan, my son, Trevor, and daughter-in-law, Ariana, and my son, Brendan, who will be doing student teaching
in the fall.
So this is one father who's grateful for the teacher shortage.
So, as Barbara Murchison mentioned before our lunch break, there are four issues in the SSA state plan that we thought we would highlight for you because there are things that there that there is a little more information than other information that we thought we would like to get your feedback on, get feedback from stakeholders.
So these four, screen on by the way.
Excellent.
So the four listed there, the identification of schools, the annual measurement of the participation rate, the establishment of long-term goals, and native language assessments, also known as primary language assessments.
So with that,
Let's do a little review quickly about the accountability decisions you've made.
And by the way, when we look at those, we go through those four issues, I'll stop after each one of those four to give time for the board to deliberate on it, ask questions, clarifying questions, and then we'll take public comment at the very end of all of it.
But we will take time between each one, otherwise the conversation might be a little difficult for us.
So first, let's start with some accountability decisions that you've already made.
So State Board has already approved a concise set of state indicators that also are consistent with ESSA.
That was done back in March and in May.
You have approved the methodology for those state indicators using both status and change to come up with a color-coded performance, set of performance levels giving us in fact 25 different
colored performance levels in the chart that you have seen before.
You have approved the performance standards connected with those color-coded performance levels based on the distribution of current performance of LEAs and schools across the state.
And you lastly approved an annual process to review those indicators and the performance levels so that each year there's an opportunity to take another look at anything coming in new.
to take a look at what is already part of the system to see if there's any changes that we want to make.
So all of those are decisions that you have already made.
So the first what we're going to talk about this afternoon is identifying the lowest performing 5% of Title I schools.
So under ESSA, state accountability system, and it is the state's responsibility to identify an approach to identify those lowest performing 5% of Title I schools.
So just to give you an idea of what that is, that would be about 300 schools that we'd be identifying.
There will be additional schools under the alternative schools.
accountability system.
But in terms of traditional schools, that would be in the range of 300, just to get that in your mind.
So, in order to identify schools in two ways, the comprehensive support and the targeted support, based on the performance of the total school population and based on student group performance.
So in identifying the underperforming student groups, that would be, this is the definition, any student group in a school that on its own would meet the criteria for being in the lowest performing 5%.
So as we go through this, we'll talk about the criteria for the lowest 5%, and in your mind you can think, okay, so if any student group on its own would meet that criteria, then they would be identified for some targeted assistance.
So ESSA requires an approach to identify both for comprehensive and targeted support.
And in that approach, you have to provide greater weight in the aggregate for those indicators on academics.
So for instance, for us, that's student test scores, progress of English learners, graduation rates, and the additional K-8 measure.
So those measures have to, in the aggregate, be weighted greater than the non, what's referred to as the non-academic criteria.
So for us, that would be suspension rates.
So this is a chart, again, of something that you've already done, which is identifying LEAs for support under LCFF.
So this is just a reminder, a backdrop.
We're talking about ESSA and identifying the lowest performing 5% of schools.
This is the criteria that you've already identified for identifying LEAs for support under LCFF.
talked about the California model and the different indicators.
Here's a chart that shows you the difference between the academic indicators and, in our case, the one non-academic indicator.
And if you look, you can see they're broken down elementary and middle schools might have four, high schools might have four.
So again, in the aggregate, you can see the red line that shows you above the ones that are academic.
So they already, by nature of the system we're using, are greater in weight than the other indicators.
So, based on feedback from stakeholders and from our technical design group, the TDG, three options were identified for identifying the lowest 5% of Title I schools.
That was first given to you in, I believe, an April 12th information memo.
The three options are all based on the color-coded performance levels.
So we'll just go over each of the options so you know what they are.
Number one is to identify a pool of schools based on all of the indicators equally.
So as you think back to that chart a couple of slides ago, four indicators.
So if you were to have a school that had red in all four indicators, those schools would be identified first.
But also with those schools would be those schools that have ended up in the red for all of the applicable indicators.
So if you only had three and all three of them were red, you would be in the pool.
Same thing for two indicators.
And if we actually had schools with only one, which we probably do given that we have all different types of schools in the state, then you would also be identified in the first pool of schools.
If we didn't reach our, say, 300 schools, our 5%, then the next set of schools that would be identified were those that had all reds and then an orange.
So three reds and an orange would then get you in.
Or if you had three indicators, two reds and an orange.
And that's how you go until you identify your 5% pool.
So that's option one.
The difference between, well, let me go back.
There's actually an A and a B under option one.
And that is how you're going to treat the assessment scores.
Are you going to treat the English language arts and math as separate indicators?
That's an option.
Or you could put them together.
Now in our LCFF, identifying LEAs for support, we put them together.
But those are two options within option one.
Option two is also using those colors, but providing some sort of a weighting system.
In other words, if you decide that suspension rate should be the most important, then we're going to give that more weight than the other indicators.
Or if you decide it's the least important, you could give it less weight than the other indicators.
And then go about identifying the schools.
So the difference between option one and option two is basically a weighting issue, whether you want to treat all indicators similarly, the same, or if you want in an option two,
to provide some weighting either up or down for certain indicators.
The last time we discussed this in March, some of you hadn't really expressed a desire one way or another.
A few of you were very, very strong saying, no, I'd be weighted equally.
And then option three is actually also a different weighting, type of weighting of schools or indicators.
And that is to put the indicators in a certain order.
This is one order, just chosen out of the air.
It could be in any order.
But this one starts with the academics and then goes to the English learner progress and then the suspension rates.
And how this one would work
is that under the academic, you'd first take all of the schools that would be identified, again using the colors, and that would be your first pool.
If you didn't reach your 300, you would go then to the second indicator.
And in this example, it happens to be the English learner indicator.
And you would see who would qualify there.
If you haven't reached your 300, if you've reached your 300, you'd stop.
If you haven't reached it, then you'd go on to the third indicator.
So that's a different kind of waiting, because in fact, you could have an indicator that you never get to for identifying if you've reached your 5% before you got to the third or fourth indicator.
So the TDG went through these options, and the TDG recommended option one.
They preferred considering the ELA and math as separate indicators.
If you put them together, it does basically make them a half indicator each.
And so that was the technical design group's recommendation.
And for options two and three,
They thought that the weighting procedure just was too much in conflict with the decisions that we've made up until this time, which is basically to treat indicators as all of equal importance.
So that's the technical design group.
We also took it to CPAG, and there was a little, there was less agreement from CPAG, but the majority of the members did prefer the option one method, though they preferred putting the English language arts and math together, which is different than what the technical design group was recommending.
They thought that was more aligned with our California model.
And then if, for those CPEG members that said, well, if ELA and MATH are considered separately, then not providing an additional weight to them, but perhaps a lesser weight to the suspension rate.
And then there were some members of the CPEG that preferred option three, starting with one indicator and working way down.
So some of the things to consider in this option, and then we're almost to the place where we can stop and have a deliberation on this.
is that in September, the State Board did approve criteria for LEA eligibility for support under LCFF.
Those criteria did not apply a differential weighting to the indicators, which is more consistent with Option 1.
That's the one that's mostly consistent with the decisions that you've made under LCFF.
And so that is why you would see Option 1 listed in the State Plan that we would then go out for stakeholder input on.
So I think
Oh, just a couple of points.
We actually made this point already, and that is because some schools might not reach the 30 end size.
Not all schools will have four indicators in which they'll have a performance level for them.
There might be some that have three, two, or even one.
And then lastly, this consideration, we talked about this also already in that some indicators might not even get to on option three if you've already identified your five percent.
So, I think that is the end of that section.
So, we'll stop for... Yeah, very clear and distilled a lot of concepts into a simple presentation.
I think helpful board member comments.
Board Member Rucker, then Board Member Burr.
I just have a couple of questions about the school identification.
I remember previously when the board was asked to identify schools for intervention for the SIG program and composed that list, the schools were clustered by grade level or grade span.
So we ended up having high schools that did not make the list and middle and elementary schools that did and the high schools that did not make the list had significantly different or lower performance data about those schools.
Is there something about the way this identification would go for the purposes of this plan that could still put us in that same type of problem?
Are the schools still going to be clustered by grade span to make the selection or are they going to be ordered in a different way?
So that is a decision that will be made by the board.
You can choose to identify the lowest 5% without regard to grade span, or you can choose to identify the lowest 5% in each grade span.
We've done... Oh, OK.
So the lowest 5% in each grade span, that potentially could mean more than 300 schools?
Far fewer than 300.
You would still have 300 schools.
Okay.
But you would get, you might get some higher performing elementary schools that get identified and some lower performing high schools that don't get identified.
Because we have far more elementary schools than we do high schools.
So they would make up more of the 5%.
We have done some simulations on this.
And it works out pretty even right now, but we don't have all the indicators yet.
And when we put in, you know, all of the indicators that could make a significant difference.
Okay.
Well, you read my mind because I was going to ask you about simulation.
So with the point in time when the board does need to make that determination, would you be able to share with us what it is you've learned from the runs that you've done?
Yes.
Okay.
Board member Burr.
So this isn't really a question, but it's it comes under the topic of other considerations in reading the plan.
This is always kind of been in the back of my mind, but there are several policy issues that I think we need to think about and.
not just go down the path of we have to identify 5% underperforming schools, because that's what the feds tell us we have to do.
Because while I think most of the plan, and I want to give lots of kudos to all the hard work that's been done to get to this place, does in fact create an integrated, coherent system of state and federal accountability,
This part does not, and it deviates significantly from what our policy perspectives have been in two ways.
One, with respect to what is the locus of control?
In my view, it's school districts, LEAs.
there's no such thing as schools that exist outside of a district separate from charters, which we can have a conversation about.
But for traditional public schools, they all exist in the district.
That's the unit of measurement.
That's the unit of accountability.
That's the unit of everything else.
And so to suggest that the federal government can reach down and identify schools that are needed help separate from districts
is ridiculous on its face, in my view.
It's been a failed experiment many, many years.
Ms.
Rucker just talked about the SIG program.
That's the most recent one.
So I think for those of us who have spent all this time over the last several years saying we have a state system,
that is going to focus on school districts and hold them accountable and the locally elected officials who are in charge of them accountable for their student performance.
This approach is contrary to that.
And this is where, when I started to read the plan and sort of put it all together, I went, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
We are now trying to put a square peg into a round hole.
We're trying to figure out now what the intervention will be, how we identify them,
at a level, again, that's inconsistent with our state system.
How we label them, which is now a continuation of NCLB, we're going to call them consistently underperforming or whatever their new term is, which we've been trying to get away from for three years, and what support we're going to give them.
Which in our state system, we sort of flip it the other way around.
We say, we're going to focus on our student subgroups.
We're going to be very clear about that.
If they're not meeting our targets, that's where we're going to go.
And we're going to do it in a continuous improvement system, where we're going to work right alongside them to make sure that they're being successful with all of their students.
This piece of this is very troubling to me.
And so I just want us all to step back and go, wait a minute, are we going down this path because the federal government is telling us to do that and we have no choice?
Or should we say, wait a minute, we're going to lead.
That's what we've said we're going to do all along.
And we're going to resist.
to use a favorite word lately.
And we're going to go back to what our approach should be in terms of a policy perspective and how do we do that.
So that's my little speech about this, but I just want people to know how uncomfortable I am and I do think we have come to the point of collision with the state system and the federal system and we need to think very carefully about that.
So as the plan goes out for public comment, I'd like to have a lot of conversation around that.
I would like to let the field know we're open to what their perspective is on that.
But more fundamentally, I think, Karek, we will need to have data runs that say, what does our system look like?
I didn't know we're going to talk about this in July.
How will we identify LEAs?
How many LEAs?
What are the student groups?
you know, what kind of technical assistance will need to be provided to them.
And if we were to go with option one, which I agree is the closest, but again, I want to be really clear, it's not aligned.
It's different.
It's very different than what we've been doing.
What does that look like?
Because my biggest fear is that we'll get to a place where we, in fact, are identifying different schools, different LEAs, calling them different things.
And we're back in that NCLB tailspin, which we've tried so desperately to get out of.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I had a similar question, obviously not as passionate as board member Burr about how incompatible this is.
But I, as I was reading the state plan, and I know that we will likely go into a more in-depth conversation about the state plan.
I have a lot more thoughts about that.
But for this particular, for the identification process, you know, I'm really struggling with essentially five, the bottom 5% of subgroups, bottom 5% of schools, bottom 5% of LEAs.
And how do we put it together so that we do have a sense of how are we, the technical assistance, right?
Because at the end of the day, there is no district without students.
So that is really the focus of, that should be our focus, our student groups.
But how do we do it if there's the student groups and then there's some schools and some schools may not be in the LEA that gets identified.
And then we have to focus, we have limited capacity, which I hate to think that limited capacity will shape our policy decisions, but to an extent that's what we're doing, right, by just identifying the bottom 5%.
I don't see it.
I don't see, I've been waiting since I was appointed.
So Karen, good luck.
I've been waiting to see how this all focuses and comes together.
And I still can't, I still can't picture it.
And now we're only a couple of months away from submitting this plan.
So I think that any information, data runs, visuals, how we will really wrestle with that incompatible system that we're trying to develop into one coherent system.
And I think we need to have that conversation and that I would agree.
Thanks.
I mean, this is a fundamental issue.
Glad you added, there's a three-part issue, Feliza, in that regard.
The one way, it doesn't get over the fundamental conflict that Member Burr elucidated, but what does the federal law say about restricting us on, if we are forced to identify schools,
that we can proceed with our intervention with a strong focus on the district rather than you bring a SWAT team into the school, which was the old SAIT, I guess.
Yeah.
And so there's a, there's a, although Board Member Burr didn't elucidate this,
There's a lot of research on trying to improve schools without trying to improve districts.
And generally, it doesn't work very well.
And you send a team into the school, and they never bother much with the central office.
So what does the law say that would prohibit us
from saying, okay, if we have to identify schools, we want to approach this through the districts and district assistance and an integrated theory of assistance.
That doesn't get us over the problem of multiple identification.
It just tries to shift it to, we're not going to go down the road of just dealing with a school and not dealing with a district.
How much does the law hem us in on that?
Well, I will say that I believe that the system of support, however you want to talk about it, the assistance provided to schools and districts, has inherently more flexibility with how we approach that than, say, the identification of schools, because the law is very clear on that.
And if we were to move away from that, then we'd probably have to seek a waiver or
But we'd want to look at the, see what the data show us.
But in terms of support for those schools and districts, I think assisting schools through the school district or the authorizing LEA, I think is, I think that's something that is within the law.
Okay.
So here's another criteria that your technical group and CPAG didn't figure out, which is you take these three models,
and run them and see which ones identifies more closely with the way we're identifying.
So that your decision criteria isn't on what you all discussed, it's on which one of these three melds the best with the way we're identifying districts under LCFF.
So just for example, if method three, which is you move down, I think that's called a tiered system by some people, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
If that has some problems, but if that happens to mesh better with our system under LCFF, that moves it up as a candidate.
So I'd like
yet a fourth criteria here to look at in order to see if there's harmony there.
That makes sense.
There may be that there's a pretty strong overlap in identification between the school districts in LCFF and the schools in ESSA, but we have no idea about that.
But we could
Yeah, run your alternatives through that.
Or you could, well, let me think about that one.
You could have an alternative.
Could you have an alternative that says, here are the districts in that we identify
and then we'll look at those only and take the bottom 5% of those or something.
I mean, you know, back it up rather than, you know, you go this way, you start with where we identified and then you choose the schools within that.
I don't know whether that'd be legal, but of course that could be tested through a waiver.
You're still identifying a bottom 5%.
How about that?
Member Burr, any reaction?
You see where I'm going?
I mean, you start with us and then you get to 5% in those districts.
That's exactly right.
I think that the point is that we lead with what our policy approach is.
And our policy approach is to identify the districts.
And it's to identify the districts based on low student group performance.
That's what we've been working on all this time.
And that's what the five by five grids and all that yield.
So if there's a way for it to, again, start there and the data
shows us that, great.
If not, all I'm saying, and I think Carrick alluded to this, is I think we should consider all options, including a waiver.
Because we, from the get-go, we have said we're going to lead.
I'll just, I don't want to put words in Carl Cohn's mouth, but Carl has reported, and I think there was an article recently, where he travels all around the country.
And generally, California is viewed as being three years ahead of the rest of the country in this conversation.
So I think we should take advantage of that and again reinforce that and say this is what we believe on behalf of our students.
Not try to torture ourselves into getting to a place for pittance, for as I've said many times, budget dust.
They should not be controlling what we're doing based on their relative investment in our school system.
Any other board member comments?
Board member Valdez.
So in the spirit I think of continuous improvement and that's what we're talking about here in our model and thinking about systemic change and what Dr. Kirst is talking about in terms of looking at it from the district level.
In my own context that's something I would recommend looking at that because as you're trying to set up systems and with the eight indicators
And I know there's academic waiting, if you will, but not really waiting.
They're all important.
What's happening is that at the district level, everyone has a job and a responsibility.
And sometimes it's almost in silos, but it's coming down to that site level.
But it's not about the site.
It's about the system.
And so the system is really at the top.
And so if you're looking at coherence and you're looking at the right drivers and
I know the state has looked a lot at Michael Fullan's work and you're looking at, you know, setting goals and looking at collaboration and looking at internal and external accountability.
That really doesn't come at the site level.
I mean, it can be there.
But if you want longevity and you want endurance, I think it happens more so at the district level.
And I think that
more will benefit from it because, again, you're setting up a system and some schools might not have been identified, might have been potentially at risk, but you're going to help the entire system.
Yeah, while I'm thinking out loud, here's another thought on this.
Dave Gordon, the superintendent of Sacramento County, and I don't want to state the number exactly, but he said
some huge number of the low-performing schools in the state are in a relatively small number of districts.
So, you know, it was something like 15 or 20 or something like that.
So if you're spending a lot of resources with a single school over here in East Overshoe, you know, and the rest of the district is fine, you're really not being that efficient if you're not working in these districts that have huge numbers of these
lower performing schools, oh, they may be in the top 7%, you know, and not 5%, so now they're magically okay.
But, you know, the bottom 5% isn't all that high in some cases.
So, I mean, we could think about a rationale like that is that we're trying to do this in order to pick up
the mass of the schools rather than dealing with isolated districts and isolated schools.
And that's the right way to think about it in such a big state where you can't be everywhere.
And if you spread yourself over all these geographically spread one-off schools, you're going to run out of it.
Okay.
Other comments?
Anybody over here?
Okay.
Felice is next.
Yeah.
I would be interested in seeing that data though.
I would be interested in seeing how many of our bottom 5% of schools actually align with the bottom 5% of school districts.
And I think that information will better inform our decisions here because
you know, with demographic shifts, there may be that one school that is in an amazing district, but that school's not doing right by its students.
And I think that's also something that we need to know and be aware of.
So I would like to see subgroups, schools, and districts, and where's the overlap?
And how many students are we, or how many schools are we capturing in the district that would be identified as bottom 5%?
How many schools
are part of that district and the subgroups that are being, that are also part of the bottom 5%.
I think that we need information to guide our decisions.
And I added a number of students because you can have a lot of little schools.
So, if you're trying to affect students in your unit, that should be another overlap with this analysis.
Pat.
I think there's another good reason for us to look at what we are asking to do with and how we would hold districts accountable when a school site in their district is held accountable.
But let me take it from a different frame than what we've been discussing up to this point.
We have right here in Sacramento County examples of school districts that have flagship schools.
At graduation, when they put together the program, behind the name of every single senior is the name of the school, the college, or the academy that graduating senior is going to matriculate to after graduation.
100% of that cohort at that high school graduates from high school, yet in the same district,
There is another high school that doesn't have that level of success.
At that flagship high school, they have a full slate of offerings for the AP courses.
They offer multiple languages.
They offer multiple math courses in the harder math and sciences.
while the high school across the district doesn't have that.
There's a difference in the performance of the students.
There's a difference in the types of programs being offered.
There's a difference in the experience of the teachers and how the school that's not a flagship school is performing.
And so, not surprisingly, that high school that's not a flagship school is one of the lowest performing schools in the state.
Choosing to focus accountability for the performance of that school site on the district actually does operationalize one of our key principles in the LCAP for districts to look at not only how they are programming,
their school plan, but the choices they are making in providing services in ways that are not just a distribution plan, but that are equitable and meet the needs of students.
That is a clear and very transparent example of where there's poor planning in that local control plan for that particular school.
And in fact, because that is a low-performing school,
in a district that has a flagship high school, that plan failed that school.
So I think this is an opportunity to operationalize that element of accountability in the local control accountability plan and that type of oversight because if a school, if it's only a single school,
in that district that's identified, that's a clear example that that district has failed that school.
So I do think there is a good reason to focus at the district level.
That's another way to build a rationale if you think we have to do a waiver, but I don't think so.
I think the plan that you write can actually focus on what we intend the local control accountability plan to do.
and holding districts accountable to support their schools because if a single school fails in that district, it's what the district failed to do, not just the school alone.
A school site doesn't fail alone.
Those students didn't fail alone.
And so I think that this, I don't think we, while a waiver is worth pursuing or considering, I think in the ways that we intended the LCAP to work and the ways we intended our local indicators to work and those self-assessment tools to work, I think we have the tools in place to make this state plan work in the way we intend the LCAP accountability to work.
And I'm trying to be very careful in how I have that conversation so that I don't offend the people in that district because they're some of my close personal friends.
So I'm trying to be very careful.
But that is an example in real time, in real life, that we know already exists.
And that's the great, great big secret that we're actually not addressing.
Okay, other board comments on this one we got?
Okay, so let's step back for just a minute before we go to the next one, which is goals.
To remember what it is that Barb Murchison shared with us before lunch, and that is the action item is to approve this plan to go out for action or for stakeholder input.
So,
We've gotten some good input just from you about the idea of trying to meet some data runs, seeing if we can focus this on LEAs versus schools.
So there's two ways we can approach this when it goes to the motion.
You know, you could actually amend something in the plan that would go out.
Or we could just make sure that when we go out for that stakeholder input, we include a lot of questions about this idea of focusing on LEAs versus schools.
So that's just something for you to think about.
Don't necessarily have to comment on it now, but that is the motion about going out.
So we either amend the plan or we just include some questions in our stakeholder input meetings.
So but we have several areas you're going to we're going to talk about.
And then before we we're going to hear from our public comment at the end of the item and then the board will discuss.
So just to remember board members that we're going to give back to CD our recommendations with any modifications.
But that'll happen after our public comments just to kind of hold these ideas.
Great.
So let's go on to goals.
I should have mentioned this with the first one, but goals start on page 30 of attachment one, if you prefer to use your board item to go through here.
Otherwise, you can just take a look at, I'm sorry.
Page 43 is the participation rate.
I got a little ahead of myself.
Page 43 in Attachment 1, we're talking about a participation rate before we get to goals.
So participation rate, as you remember, under AYP was a requirement for English language arts and math as well as science.
Students, 95% of the students in a school, in a district, had to meet, had to have at least 95% participation rate in all of those assessments, whether it was a regular assessment or an alternate assessment.
95% participation rate.
Unlike AYP, or AYP required that if they did not make that 95% participation rate, it was an automatic fail.
That was the old system.
Under ESSA, they allow the state to determine how 95% participation rate will be used in the accountability system.
So it's up to us to determine how we are going to do that.
So for now, the State Board has not made a decision on how that participation rate will be implemented in the accountability system.
For now, what we have is perhaps an indicator in the dashboard, whether that's done by color or some sort of a symbol or numbers to go along with it, some indication of whether the school did or did not meet that 95% participation rate.
And then the assistance given to that school as a result of missing that 95% participation rate could be through the statewide system of support, and it could be differentiated.
Under the old AYP system, you failed.
Under this system, if you didn't make it, you can make it
a difference or your assistance could be different depending on if the school had a 94 participation rate, 94% versus a 75% participation rate.
There's probably a different way you want to go about approaching how that school or district might get assistance.
So, that's the 95% participation rate up to now.
Any discussion or comments?
Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
When you say assistance to meet the 95%, would that be part of the, they would have to be identified first and then part of the assistance they receive would be on upping their participation rate.
However, I know that California, our opt-out was rather low.
I know that in other states where they have higher opt-outs, it tends to be in more affluent communities.
So those districts or schools would not necessarily be captured through our technical assistance, right?
And so I think that it would be best for us to identify somehow
the school or the LEA because they may not be targeted for assistance because they're not going to be part of the bottom 5% if they follow the same trends as we've seen in other states.
But maybe you could tell us who are these schools that are not meeting the participation rate.
You're correct that overall we had a very high participation rate, but there were pockets, schools, individual schools, not districts.
Individual schools tend to be affluent, where they had opt-out rates probably almost as high as 50% of the grade 11 students, grade 11 we're talking about.
This wasn't a problem at elementary and middle schools.
But we're talking less than a handful.
Really small.
Board member Rocker.
So it's tempting in this plan to write a blanket rule of thumb for how to deal with the participation rate.
And I'm not sure that that's actually a very good idea for the reasons we just covered is the participation rates.
But what I do want us to think about during our time, during my time on the board, we have dealt with some instances where a whole class of students, maybe a group of students who are taking like an opportunity class,
and they forgot to test those students.
And then they discovered because they forgot to test those students that they didn't meet the 95% participation rate.
I think it's those types of schools where they play games with the system and manipulated the attendance of students or the participation of students for particular reasons that we need to pay more attention to than schools who fail to meet the 95% participation rate because a parent opt out.
So there's a difference.
So what I'm suggesting is in addressing this particular issue, there's a difference between deciding to sanction a high school because you have parents who chose to opt their children out from taking the test and school districts who by action of the district failed to test the students, they should have failed.
And so I think that that's what the plan actually needs to address, primarily because we do have an opt out statute in this state.
And so, in districts where parent opt-out is the reason why the participation rate is below what it should be, I think those schools should be treated differently if there's a sanction at all because you can't hold schools accountable for a parent's exercise of their authority.
Whereas, when districts choose to forget to test students, that's a different issue.
That's all.
And we have dealt with those waivers.
And we were nice.
In my personal opinion, this board was nicer than they should have been.
Well, and you can imagine the reason for the 95 percent participation rate is so that certain students who may not perform well, surprisingly, don't get tested.
And I would say we're talking about a very small number of situations, but it's still enough to address.
So what I'm hearing is a differentiated approach.
Okay.
Any other?
Yeah, okay.
Go on?
Okay, on to goals.
For those who want to look in your board packet, again, it's attachment one, starts on page 30.
So what ESSA requires is that the state in its plan and its accountability system establish ambitious long-term goals which include measurements of interim progress toward meeting those goals for all students but also for each student group.
So, goals are required for academic achievement, which is our English language arts and math assessments, four-year cohort graduation rate, and progress for our English learners on English language proficiency.
The goals are meant for setting the same length of time for each indicator for all students and for each student group to achieve the goal.
Take into account the improvement necessary to make significant progress, especially for those where there may be gaps, and for the English learner proficiency, an increase in the percentage of students from year to year.
So as of yet, the State Board has not approved specific long-term goals or the specific timeline related to achieving those goals.
But this is part of what we want to get stakeholder feedback on as well as information that you might want to share with us today.
So we do, the State Board does expect to revise these performance levels every five to seven years.
That was discussed earlier in previous Board meetings.
Accordingly, the timeline for reaching the goals should also be aligned with the revision timeline.
So that could be five years, six years, seven years.
So for the next couple of slides, I'll use seven years just as an example.
I'm not trying to make policy for you.
But to make it easier in my presentation, we'll say that we're going to revise these every seven years.
So under the old system, graduation rate for instance, we had an actual hard number, in this case percentage, goal for graduation rate.
It was 90%.
So the board could
in fact, set hard number goals just like we did under AYP.
And it would look like the little chart here at the bottom where a district's graduation rate in this example, 79.5%, the target being 90%.
The distance to that goal by subtracting the two is 10.5%.
And then in this example, like I said, seven years to meet that goal, you do a little division and then your goal each year is to make 1.5%.
That is an option in order to reach that goal in seven years.
or the State Board could determine to set goals using the colors consistent with what you've approved already, the 5x5 color grid.
What CDE is recommending is setting the goal using that 5x5 color grid to be consistent with the methodology in the California model.
We'll show you an example of that in a minute.
setting the green performance level as the long-term goal would establish ambitious goals.
And you'll see some data on that that will show you that.
As a starting point for stakeholder input, which is what this draft plan is to be, during the public comment period, we've identified a single cell in the green area, which is the cell where the status is high and maintained is the change indicator.
and it looks like this where that is almost right in the middle of that chart where if you look at high on the left side, you look at maintained and we even have a little orange outline around that box that would indicate that for purposes of the plan and getting stakeholder feedback that that would be the goal.
What the next slide will tell you is that anything to the right of that goal or above that goal, those other green areas, the blue area up there, that exceeds the goal.
What you would have to decide is that green area that's up there in the first row where the performance is very high but the change is actually declined.
that would be an area in which we'd have to determine does that, is that considered meeting the goal or not.
But this one in the middle is the one that for purposes of the state plan would be what we consider the ambitious goal.
If you look at the footnote, you would see that over 73% of the schools aren't there yet.
So that's what makes it an ambitious goal.
Again, after seven years, we've made a commitment to five to seven years, we made a commitment to take a look at these performance levels so that we don't end up back where we were before where
the API of 800 was meeting the goal and we never changed it.
And after a while, it probably wasn't the most appropriate.
So, in this new California model that we're using, we would revisit that every five to seven years.
This example.
This example happens to be the ELA academic indicator.
So, like I said, I'll switch back to it, but this is in words what I just told you about the chart.
So, one of the things that we've talked about is how are we going to do the interim progress along the way and how are we going to have kids catch up, right, where there may be gaps.
This is a chart.
I know it's a little small for you to read.
In fact, I'm going to have to get my glasses out for me to read it myself.
But this actually came from a board item back in January.
And this is by student group.
So you don't have to be able to read it a lot.
But in the first three rows, you start with all schools, then you go to the African-American subgroup, and you go to the Asian subgroup.
All you have to do is look at those.
those three, and mostly the African-American versus the Asian, and you can see right away there's a lot of work still to be done in this case with the African-American subgroup.
So this idea of measuring across the seven years in our example, that subgroup would have to grow a lot more to get to that goal of green than other subgroups in the effort to try to close the gaps.
So, I'll go to next steps and then we'll go back to the chart if you need it.
The next step would be then to take the initial draft of the state plan, assuming your approval today or any modifications you might want to make to it, identifying that high maintained cell.
And remember, every one of these indicators
it would be the same color, the same cell, but we've differentiated each of those indicators with the distribution of the school.
So it's an appropriate goal, it's a different goal, even though it's the same green cell, because it's based on the actual data of the distribution of schools, which I think was the point that
member Rucker was making the last time we had this conversation.
And then in July, come back with that feedback from stakeholders and some more detail because CDE, the department, will be developing reports for each of those subgroups with numbers to show where the gaps are and how much they would need to grow in order for them to make their goals and to catch up.
Board Member Ortiz, we'll call him.
I have a comment about the closing of the achievement gaps and setting those goals.
And this is essentially a semi-final copy of the state plan.
I know that we had draft regs.
I know that we had final regulations and there was some hesitation to adhere by those because they went above the statue.
Then 45 happened to us and we were all wondering what that meant, right?
But
the statute has been the same and it has been consistent.
And we knew that in the law, it required us to identify ways where those students that were furthest behind would be able to make growth in order to meet a state determined timeline.
And so for me, as this is going out for public comment, it is really difficult to imagine how somebody who doesn't partake in these meetings, has not read the ESSA law, is not acquainted with ESSA, would really make an informed
comment about how do we narrow achievement gaps when they have two sentences that state, because all student groups have the same long-term goals, student groups with lower baseline performance will need to make greater improvement over the time to reach the long-term goal.
Yeah, that's pretty common sense.
That should happen, right?
But how can that then lead to a rich discussion to inform
How do we narrow achievement gaps?
What are the goals?
We look at African American students.
They are by far the racial subgroup that is lagging the furthest behind.
We look at Latino students.
We know that we want to recalibrate this every five to seven years.
This is a system of averages.
Obviously, if we
If the majority, which are Latino students, are able to make gains, that could also help increase our standards and our performance.
I just have a really hard time being patient with the development of this piece because this is something that I certainly have urged us to consider.
And as we're approaching the deadline of September, to have two sentences described and ask the public to give us feedback
it's frustrating at best.
The long-term goals, it's so ambiguous here.
Are we aiming for five, six, or seven years?
So I'm glad to see that we're leaning towards seven.
I know that that requires a discussion.
But again, what is going on for public comment?
We're assuming that people are tuning in.
That is not the case.
You know, there's many of people and people who are parents and educators who really should have an opinion about this that are not aware of this.
And they're not going to get that information from our commons.
And again, how are we so far behind when this has been a conversation that we all knew had to take place?
And even if this is something that we feel was the feds that are mandating this, Californians in this room, because we see them flood our boardrooms, have been asking the same question.
So we should be further along.
I don't know what's going out to the public and it's hard to endorse a state plan that is so vague that I myself have tons of questions and I'm one of the 11 here.
Thank you.
So, let me at least say back to you a couple of things that I heard.
One, when we go out for stakeholder feedback, one of the things we will do is the same thing we did the last round of stakeholder feedback, and that is CDE staff work with state board staff to come up with what are the critical questions because we know, I mean, we are not expecting
the general public or parents or whatever to read the plan and then come to the meeting prepared to make comments.
We don't think that that's probably not a reasonable approach to take.
That we need to distill it into more clear information and critical questions that you want
And that was the slide Barbara showed earlier.
What are the questions you want to hear back from stakeholder feedback so that they understand what it is that they're giving us feedback on?
So let me assure you that that will be part of that discussion.
So, just for accuracy, since we're in the basketball playoffs, this is actually the quarterfinal.
July will be the semifinal, with September being the final plan.
So, you can expect this will not be
word for word, the same plan that comes back in July.
There will be a different plan with the feedback that we get and the recommendations that we made.
And as we go along, we're trying to get more and more specific for you.
So there are some areas, as Barbara Murchison said, will be plans to plan, but the other areas will need to be more specific as we get closer.
I think she's also suggesting a communication strategy which is different from what we had today, but says the same thing.
I don't know how you do that exactly, but, you know, so it's how you translate this literally from the language of educationese to something somebody can understand.
The stakeholder feedback, it will not be you, right?
I mean, you have a greater understanding of all this in the background than the general public will.
So, how we word it and the information that we give for that stakeholder feedback will have to be adjusted.
Board Member Holliday.
One of the earlier slides, you were talking about how much a particular LEA had to grow over the seven years, and you divided that by seven.
And so each year was the exact same expectation of growth.
That's not reality.
That's not life.
And we certainly experienced that with AYP and API.
There can be this
brilliant moment where a subgroup that is lagging far behind that a district or a school or a charter school moves that group significantly and yet there's still a way behind.
Those moments are not to be ignored.
Those moments are to be seen as opportunities for learning and continued growth.
And each of these groups is going to move at different rates in different ways for different reasons.
Life is just a lot messier than dividing it by seven.
And keeping that kind of concept in mind, I think is important as we consider this.
I don't know exactly how this would fit in here, but
I was, before you even showed the chart that showed how far behind African-American students are, when I was executive director at EdSource, this feels like a very long time ago, in 2008.
In fact, it was nine years ago.
We did an analysis of African-American student achievement in California.
And one of the things that came out of the analysis
In fact, I still, I have it on my desktop now and I just sent it to Sue and Mike.
One of the things that came out of the analysis that I didn't know was that two-thirds of the African-American K-12 students in California live in five of our 58 counties.
We have 58, right?
Two-thirds of them live in only five counties.
And so I thought of that and we have the list, again this data is old, but we have the list of schools that have the most.
I thought of that when you were talking about the district being the focus of the support or intervention.
And I was thinking about that report.
I just pulled it up to look at it again thinking, boy, I would so, I would be so happy if it, in that process of aligning in the way that you're talking about aligning, it also picked up some of those districts and some of those counties.
and we were able to target providing intervention and support to the districts and counties that have the highest number of African-American students who are the most behind.
That would be a worthy, worthy outcome of doing it this way, in my opinion.
Just in the next steps as we reach out to stakeholders for actions on this plan, I would really encourage to try and very actively include students in this plan.
Just because a lot of these very vague things that need a lot of specificities in them, only students can really provide the background required for coming to the decisions that should be acted on in this plan.
So just when you are considering how you're reaching out in the community,
really actively try to include students in that outreach.
Right.
Thank you.
So, Carrick, I was talking to Feliza a little bit here about, for purposes of the public comment, I think that, like she pointed out, the language in the draft is so kind of general, which I know we're doing on purpose because we don't want to make a contract with the feds that we can't deliver on.
But for purposes of what's underneath that and for seeking public input, I wonder whether using the chart you have up here in the public comment sessions and some very specific examples of here's what it would take for African-American students to get to green.
as opposed to white students or Asian or whatever the other things, so that you understand that we really are talking about targets that are much higher for groups that are struggling right now.
I just, I think it has to be made real.
So that's my first suggestion.
The second thing is,
Back to Member Holliday's comment.
I just approach this notion of setting goals with such level of caution because in the past we've either gone way too high or way too low.
We can't get the Goldilocks sweet spot right.
And so I just I'm struggling a little bit with the green and with what that means.
Because and I was trying to figure out is there a way for us to look back at trends like on graduation rate at what what was the slope of the line as we improve graduation rate?
And I realize we're so early in the system.
I don't know if there is a way, but that's what I'm struggling with as it relates to setting goals of we either get too high or too low.
And as we've talked about in the past, we always sort of pick them out of thin air.
And I just want to make sure we don't do that in this circumstance.
Fair enough.
So what I was telling Sue was, yes, I think it is important for us to show the public this, but also there has to be a standard methodology that everyone's using across the state so that when we're gauging at what does it take to narrow the achievement gaps between your student groups, that everyone's using the same methodology.
So there has to be that level of guidance.
And the other thing that I just, you know, and I've been advocating for this, which is for us to own this notion of wanting to close achievement gaps.
Granted that it is the ESSA state plan that kind of forged the conversation, but it's everything that we say we value in California.
It's everything that's embedded in the LCFF.
It's everything that undergirds the California way.
So we shouldn't see this as, well, you know, this is something that we have to report back to D.C., but rather this is something that we feel is imperative for us to get a handle on here for the sake of our students.
And we're also going to share it with, you know, our friends at the Department of Education.
But I think that until we own that this is something that is aligned to our California way, that it's something that it is to our interest to make sure that we keep an eye on who are what student groups are not making
are not performing, we're going to see it as something that's almost a burden and something that we have to consider because of the Department of Ed.
And it's not.
These are our students.
These are not students coming from D.C.
These are California students that are not performing in California schools and it happens to be the same students over and over and over again.
And so we need to own that and we need to own our kids.
Thank you.
Okay, so I'm so happy I get to follow her.
I'd like to associate my comments with what my colleague just said.
There's nothing wrong with public education in California if you happen to be a parent of a graduating student like Olivia Sison.
There's nothing wrong with public education in California.
If you happen to be one of those flagship high schools that has a public library on the campus, that has the ADG requirements available to all the students at your school, that actually allows students to visit their schools during the school year, after school, and on the weekends, there's nothing wrong with public education.
If you happen to live in an affluent community and you're one of those schools where you can afford to provide all the services your students need,
This plan is for the schools where something is very clearly wrong.
And so the problem I'm having with what the plan says, and I agree that we have to be careful how we contract
the idea of continuous improvement and intervention in schools.
But let's be clear, what happened through this year, we have students who are going to graduate from high school and they spent their entire career as students living under No Child Left Behind.
And for the students who are not going to graduate this year, No Child Left Behind failed them.
And so we have to think about not what it is that will make us comfortable in dealing with intervention.
We have to not make the same statement.
I'm a member of this board and I've been a member of this board for six years.
But I've been an African-American woman for far longer.
And so when I look at that data and I see that students who look like me are at the top of the list, but not for all the right reasons, but for all the wrong reasons.
I'm sorry, but right now we're having the wrong conversation.
So if we're going to write this plan, if we're going to write this plan and we want to stick with our values, first of all, let me be clear.
While it's only three to five percent of our state's budget, in the districts that receive that money, that's a teaching position, or that's some extra books, or that's an extra service.
And so the question should not be how we're going to intervene,
or when we're going to intervene, or what the formula will be for identifying the schools, the question is going to be whether or not what is being done is actually working.
And right now we know for those students shown in this chart, it's not working.
And so what has made me excited about the work that was done in the LCAP is I thought we finally created an accountability system that would hold districts accountable for the decisions they are failing to make in providing resources to schools that have a profile that looks like this.
This is actually the only time that I'm in favor of profiling African-American students.
But the problem is we have the data, we're not paying attention to it, and we're not answering the question of why.
Now, there are a lot of reasons why we could say why, but the truth is you have to ask, do we really want to close this gap for those students?
And if we continue to be persistent in our failure to close that gap, then you have to ask a different.
The answer to the question about why has less to do with our liberalism and the idea that we're here in California and leading the California way and being more real with the fact that we are comfortable with the successes and gains we can show.
See, let's talk about the graduation rate.
I'm so pleased that Superintendent Torlakson can report that the graduation rate for English learners, for Latinos and African American students has increased every year since 2010.
but we're still not graduating all of the students we should be graduating.
So while we can rest on our laurels and be glad that the rate has gone up, the question about what has failed those students who didn't graduate is not being answered.
this plan needs to do that.
And that's what this plan, I'm not, I'm, I hope that the public comment will show that we're not happy with what the plan says.
I know we would like the plan to say more, but at the same time, we would like to balance the plan to say less.
But let me be, let me be a good, a good steward on my role as an African American on this board.
This is the one time where less is not more.
So I do agree that we need to look at the do a root causal analysis to understand the big picture but in thinking about the actual
the history of what we've been through in this short term of this new accountability system, we now finally have multiple measures that we're beginning to use that are showing a better view, if you will.
So African-American students in my district are not performing well, but I'm also looking at the climate and how they self-report.
And so there are these things that we can begin to connect and look at.
It's not just the academic side, it's the socio-emotional, it's the connections, and I think that's part of what this system offers.
And I think in my work when I was with the county and working with underperforming schools during the SAIT and the DATE and all during those times,
Money is not the answer and there are lots of districts that have received lots and lots of money all through the years and so we know it's not about the money.
But what I would recommend is that we have a system that we've started in LCAP and if we're saying that LCAP is our plan and that if we look at the balance of more, it's the California way and we're meeting the federal guidelines along the way,
that the expected annual measurable outcomes that districts are beginning to put in place, there should be this alignment when we look at whatever the growth model is or the kind of the distance from green or the distance from that if you're looking at the academic indicator.
That should be what I think districts now need help with as we're doing the federal piece, but there should be this alignment.
And by doing that, the LCAP leads
the continuous improvement targets.
And by default, we meet the federal targets, if that makes sense.
That's just something I just think we need to lean on that and how are districts setting those.
So is it... There's the old adage that you have to make two years growth in one year because you're never going to close the gap.
But do we get more time or does every group get the same amount of time?
And so then the rate of improvement has to be accelerated.
So I think those are questions that need to be
looked at as you're thinking about how we're going to set this.
Just to respond, that's pretty clear in the law.
It's the same state-determined timeline for all student groups, with the understanding that some would need to accelerate growth in order to arrive at that same state-determined timeline.
And I think it's important because it opens up the conversation about, what does the data tell us?
And unless we are forced with answering those questions, we won't really delve into the data.
One of the misnomers, I suppose, is that Latino students are underperforming because of the EL student group within the Latino population.
And I asked for the data and I want to thank the department for providing the data.
When you take out Latino English learners from the Latino student group, there's only a difference of 10% from students that are Latino and ELs.
And only Latinos, when you look at met and exceeded, it's only a 10% difference.
That means that it is not our EL students that are weighing down the performance of Latino students.
That achievement gap would exist whether Latino EL students are included in the subgroup or not.
That type of data and delving into the data is needed because, you know, it's so easy to say, well, the achievement gap with Latino students is because of the English learners in there.
Not so.
If you take them out, you still have a very similar performance.
So we need to set that state standard.
And it does need to be something that is ambitious.
Again, not because the feds are asking, but because we should be gearing in that direction.
The resources should all be aligned to make that possible.
And we want it, right?
We want this.
This is what we want for our students, so we should make it happen.
Thanks.
Okay, so I do want to, I do just want to touch on the comment concerning funding.
There is this idea that funding is part of that content compensatory model of education and of providing support for schools.
But is being compensatory and providing additional funding actually addressing the school improvement problem or is it addressing a different problem?
One of the other elements that's not clearly spelled out in the plan is the added requirement under ESSA that we have to add something to the school accountability report card and the district accountability report card that summarizes all revenue streams that are received at that school per pupil with a per pupil ratio.
So for those who would like to believe money does not make a difference, those dollars and the differences in those dollars that are spent inside a district at different schools is going to show that money makes a difference because I'm absolutely certain in a district where you're teaching a lot, where one high school teaches a lot of AP courses, they spend more money on the teaching staff than they do at the high school that does not have those programs.
So yes, money does make a difference.
Money makes a difference not because you spend the same amount of money.
Money makes a difference because just in the way our local control accountability plan provides supplemental and concentration grants for particular groups of students, they need more money to do the same type of work to create and deliver on the same types of expected outcomes.
It's not that money makes a difference, it's how you spend the money
and what you spend the money on that makes the difference.
So that while ESSA never addressed the comparability issue on how you spend money equally, what our local control accountability plan is supposed to do is hold districts accountable for spending the funds equitably.
And there's a difference between equal and equitable.
This plan does not address that particular issue.
Okay.
So, the last of the four is Native Language Assessments, which you may hear me refer to as Primary Language Assessment.
It starts on page 25 and goes to 26 and 27 in Attachment 1, if you're interested in following in the board packet.
Some background information.
First of all, most of our assessment requirements actually aren't part of this ESSA state plan.
They go through a different process that's called peer review.
And so there's a lot of information about assessments that's not in this plan, but that's by design of the U.S.
Department of Education.
Let me say that California is building the California Spanish assessment.
That's not a requirement of ESSA.
It's the next version of the standards test in Spanish that we've had in California for a number of years.
So it's already part of our contract.
It's part of our process to build this assessment.
So it's not specifically in response
to the federal government or the requirement or any requirements in the ESSA plan.
What the ESSA plan does ask us to do is certain things like identify the language that is most significant for us.
Of course, it's Spanish.
Our ESSA state plan does describe some of the things that are available now for our students that take the Smarter Balance assessments.
You'll see them listed here on the slides, but embedded glossaries that are English, translation glossaries for nine languages, test directions that are translated as well as stacked translations for our math assessment and in Spanish that will also be available in the California science tests as well.
So that's described in the state plan.
As I mentioned before, state is developing what's called the California Spanish Assessment based on Common Core standards in Espanol.
It is not just a translation of the Smarter Balanced Assessment, but it's actually based on standards that are similar to Common Core, though they are the Common Core state standards in Espanol.
And it includes some linguistic augmentations specific to the Spanish language.
The CSA will provide student level data.
So there will be student level data coming out of this assessment that will go back for the purposes of for the student, for the parent to see progress in Spanish.
There'll be aggregate data available to schools and districts so that they can take a look at this data and make some determinations about how well their program is working, especially a program that's like a dual immersion program.
I should mention because it's not listed here.
It is an optional assessment, always has been an optional assessment.
It's not a required assessment.
And the California Spanish assessment will be used in part for schools and students to meet the state seal of biliteracy.
What the federal government does require and is part of their regulations is to measure, have that native language assessment measure the same constructs as it administers it in English.
That the CSA and Smarter Balanced assessments actually measure different constructs as Smarter Balanced, of course, has already developed how the Spanish assessment is designed to be developed.
They are different constructs.
I'm not an expert in this area, so I'll give you the easy example.
And that is, for instance, the English language uses things like contractions.
Spanish language uses things like accent marks.
So there's some different constructs to the two different languages.
So therefore, in the state plan, what's described as a recommendation from staff that the results from the Spanish assessment used to be used locally in the local accountability plan, local control accountability plan, and to evaluate their local programs.
This recommendation, it's quite extensive described in the plan when it comes to saying that this is only the quarter final.
When it comes to the final plan, we may want to draw back some of that detail that's there in the plan now, make it a little more minimal.
It's in more detail now because we thought it was necessary in order for people to give feedback on it to understand why the recommendation is what it is.
we might even want to stay silent on it.
I can tell you that since this draft of the plan, I've looked at seven or eight state plans that have already been submitted to the U.S.
Department of Education, and all of them tend to be silent on this issue as to whether a primary language assessment will be used in their accountability system.
They take time talking about the accommodations or the resources and supports for English learners in their regular assessment like we do for Smarter Balanced.
They do in Smarter Balanced, they describe those.
In Park States, they describe those.
But silent when it comes to a primary language assessment.
So that's a decision that you as a state board could make to be silent on it.
My recommendation is based, what you see in the state plan is a very kind of psychometric, if you will, recommendation of the two different constructs of what these languages, what these assessments are actually measuring.
But it is a policy decision as to whether you include it in your accountability system or not.
What I would strongly recommend is that we not put something in our S.S.
State Plan, this goes back to what President Kirst kind of opened with, and that is because it's a contract, that we not make a commitment
to saying we're going to put this Spanish assessment in our accountability system because we're still a number of years away from actually seeing data from this assessment and how that data would look in some sort of an accountability system.
So to make a commitment now and give it to the federal government for them to review and then later monitor us for it may not be the time.
It doesn't mean we could not add it later outside of the ESSA state plan.
But my recommendation is not to put it in the state plan for timing purposes.
We're beginning the work now on this assessment.
The idea of the first administration of this assessment would be in 18-19.
So after the 18-19 would be the first time we would see one year of data.
And of course, with our status and change approach to accountability, it would be 19-20 before we had two years of data to take a look at the differences.
of the two years.
So again, the timeline itself speaks to this may not be the right time to put it into a plan and make promises that we may not be able to keep.
Even though the recommendation is really a psychometric recommendation,
doesn't preclude the state from using that assessment in the future for accountability.
Now, it depends on what we mean by using it for accountability, right?
We've got local accountability, then we've got state accountability in our dashboard.
That Spanish assessment, how the regulations kind of view it is, it would be used for some students in lieu of
the English language arts assessment in lieu of Smarter Balance for this state, which is the one that we have trouble with because the tests at this point are not interchangeable, could be an indicator of its own.
right, in an accountability system.
It could be a report within the dashboard.
So there's a lot of different ways of going about how we might use this Spanish assessment in terms of the accountability of students who are in programs like dual immersion programs.
What happens in the state plan doesn't preclude continuing conversations about the appropriateness of this assessment and how it might be used in whatever way we choose to use it in accountability.
And of course, we would, what we're asking for is approval to go out to get stakeholder input on this so we can bring it back to you in July.
I will say though,
It's almost a little unfair to ask for stakeholder input right now, though we will.
And we'll actually design some very thoughtful questions so that parents understand what it is and people from the public understand what they're giving feedback on.
Because quite frankly, as you know, because we've been through this a number of times, anytime you make a decision on what you want to see in your accountability system, you always want to see the data and see what the impact is.
So this first round of stakeholder input, we'd be going out and asking, would you like to see this in your accountability plan in the state's accountability system?
And we'd be asking people to say, yes, no, I don't know, without any data at all.
So we will ask for that input.
I would suggest, as those discussions go on, we would have to then go out and ask for it again once we actually had data to show people what the impact might be.
That's only fair, like we do with you when we ask you to make a decision.
So I think this last slide is an overall slide.
It's not related to the Spanish assessment, so we'll stop there.
I know that there is interest in seeing whether this is something that should be, could be reflected in the accountability system.
So I do support the idea of not including it at this time so that that allows for internal conversations to take place or conversations with EL experts or language acquisition folks that could better inform whether it is appropriate and if so at what level of accountability.
So I do support that.
I had a question about the five-year graduation rate.
I don't know if this is a time to throw it in or are we going into an open catch-all stage?
There actually will be a catch-all.
Okay.
So if you'll say that.
Okay, so I support not including it.
Thank you.
I also agree probably today and at this point where we are in developing the accountability system, it might be a good idea not to include it.
I just wanted to also add an observation.
I looked at where you have it noted that there's 33% of the students
in grades K through 12 speak Spanish and among English learners, about 83% of those students speak Spanish.
This is just my observation and listening to, and Michelle, I really want you to know, I really do listen to you when you give your report about the test.
For numbers that high and for a language group that significant, what surprises me is that there isn't a significantly higher number of districts that are reporting those tools for translation
and those glossaries are being used.
So I think that we have a different problem that really wouldn't be addressed in this plan, but I think that some attention needs to be paid to that.
So later on, when we go back and we start talking about the LCAP and the monitoring for that,
there might be some questions we need to add there for county offices to talk to districts about what they're doing with the assessment program to provide support to those students.
Because for numbers like that, I know for a fact that many districts are not allowing the use of those tools, thinking it means that their scores are going to be reported in a particular way.
So, I continue to say it surprises me in an industry where we're supposed to teach students to read and follow the directions, the people in charge do not.
So, I would like to make sure we, that those, that that data is not lost in our conversation about the LCAP and that monitoring as well.
Yeah, so, so,
We highlighted kind of the four issues that we thought would generate a lot of conversation.
But this is the time that if you wanted to make a comment about other things in the plan, this is your opportunity.
Let me just clarify the process is going to be after we clarify any other questions including the graduation rate and cohorts.
We're gonna go out for public comment and then we're gonna come back as a board and talk about what we're gonna ask the CDE to do either Before it goes out for public comment or any modifications or guidelines So just so board members know as you listen to public comment that that's what we're gonna focus on after the public comment Right, yeah, that's right but member Ortiz-Lincoln has one first
So there's three things.
One is the five year graduation rate.
I understand completing an analysis to see if that's something that should be incorporated.
But I was a little surprised to see it as an affirmation that this would be reflected in 2018.
I knew board member.
I'm wondering, OK, who made that decision was my first question.
Other questions included, who are the students?
We know that these students would not be captured in the college career readiness indicator, for instance, because that's based on a four year cohort.
And so I again, one of the comments that I've made in the past is I also want to make sure that yes, diploma and some kids may need a little longer and we want to support that.
But we don't want that to become a tracking system for some students and those students will likely be Latino, African American students, English learners.
So want to know
What does the data tell us?
Who are these students?
How does this factor in as it does call for a more robust accountability or a more robust criteria for the five-year graduation rate?
I didn't see that reflected in the SSA plan.
So we need more information on that.
I would want this to be an option for us to explore versus saying that that's what we're going to do without having a clear discussion about that.
So that's one.
Two, the exit criteria.
So once you are in comprehensive or intervention, there is no outline for what that criteria would be to exit and by when.
So there was something there about a cohort, and I'm assuming that would be four years.
But are we saying it has to be less than four years?
Are we saying that in four years they would exit if what?
It wasn't clear to me what would exit a school from comprehensive or technical assistance or what was the other one?
I can't remember.
Targeted.
And then the third thing is in those areas where we are doing more of a plan to the plan,
When do we bring stakeholders back?
Because there are some areas where folks want to know, well, what is the plan?
Reclassification being one of those, right?
And we know that there's other moving parts, which then kind of pushes us towards submitting a plan for the plan.
But once we submit that plan for the plan, when do we bring stakeholders back to give them updates on the plan and to get input on the plan or how things are now changing?
Now we know the things that we were waiting to change have changed.
This is where we're now.
Now we have an LPAC assessment.
Now we have cut scores.
if you could give us information about what happens after we submit the plan.
We have 120 days for the feds to approve it, but we also should have an internal timeline for engaging folks once we get the feedback.
So graduation rate, exit criteria, length of time, and plan to plan.
Thanks.
10-minute break.
The State Board will reconvene, and it is time for public comment.
Please call the roll of the people that should... Amy?
Yeah.
Please call the roll of the people for public comment.
Thank you.
Would the following people please line up for public comment?
Carl Dugbarty, Isaias Hernandez, Ida Bautista, Chikora Hun, Antoni Mitchell, Precious Ward, Sarah Lillis, Liz Guillen, Samantha Trown, Patricia Argan, Ada Rodriguez,
Heidi Huarte, Liana Huarte, Eric Premack, and Colin Miller.
Good afternoon.
Again, my name is Isaias Hernandez with the Mexican American Opportunity Foundation.
I just want to thank you guys for that presentation and your feedback.
A lot of really what I was going to say was already mentioned and covered through some of you.
I just kind of want to reiterate that some of
The, I would say, advocates and non-profit practitioners here today, including myself, are really focused on not having yet setting ambitious state plans or goals, nor have we adequately addressed how the state will identify schools and support them for improvement.
So, I just want to mention that as well.
Again, I do thank you guys for bringing that up today, but it is something that we're going to be keeping a close eye on and that we hope we get more information on to provide adequate community feedback and receive more parent engagement opportunities for us.
Thank you.
Hello again.
My name is Aida Bautista.
I'm from the Mexican American Opportunity Foundation.
And as I was listening to the presentation previously, it was mentioned that there's no long-term goals yet addressed in the South State plan.
They are stating they are proposing to put colors, more colors.
But I urge the state to think about putting numbers instead of colors because I don't think colors is enough.
We need numbers.
We need to make sure we have the
percentage, a graduation rate percentage determined by numbers also.
And also to re-evaluate the program, the state plan between five to seven years.
I think five will be great because every four years we have new graduates and new students coming in to the school system.
So that's one of the proposed to the state plan from us.
Yes.
Thank you.
Hello, good afternoon.
My name is Carl DuBarry.
I'm a parent from Fontana, San Bernardino County.
The draft plan states that the need to define ineffective teaching and its intention to consult with stakeholders in the coming months.
We agree that this work is very important, and we urge the state to complete that work before submitting the final state plan.
I have a question in there.
How does the committee plan to consult with stakeholders?
And what is the prolonged or the defined deadline for them to get the parents and the community back for answers?
Ineffective and effective by using the multiple measures, including but not limited to the impact on student academic performances is very important.
We ask that you please look at this and then get the stakeholders together, much as experience, so that we can know exactly where we're going.
Thank you very much.
Here at Primack Shorter Schools Development Centers have two thoughts.
First off, if Secretary DeVos walks her talk, maybe what we should be doing is just submitting the California plan as our ISSA plan.
So I think we should double down on board member Burr's thoughts here and roll with it and see what sticks.
Be interesting to see.
Maybe there are some benefits to being on the left coast under a Trump administration.
Then with respect more specifically to charter schools, we're very concerned about how does this plan align with charter law.
Charter law does not align with this plan in a number of respects.
Some of it is still very much in flux, so it's hard to tell specifically, but there are already some sharp corners, particularly around the teacher quality indicators that do not reflect
the flexibility allowed to charter schools with respect to non-core, non-college prep classes and with regard to teaching within and outside of assignment and team teaching and other similar types of arrangements.
So we would ask that you hold off on signing any assurances to the federal government until those things are resolved, Dr. Kirst.
And we would be happy to work with various parties to try to resolve these issues, but we would like to resolve them here.
Thank you.
Hello, Liz Guillen for Public Advocates.
We submitted a letter to you commenting on behalf of organizations in the LCFF Equity Coalition.
And attached to that letter were separate briefs on some of the topics.
that you discussed today and others that are being addressed in the ESSA state plan.
We are really concerned that the ESSA state plan is our opportunity to demonstrate that LCFF emphasizes equity.
In part through the expectations for different outcomes, for comparable outcomes, even though it might mean different work.
The draft plan though really misses that opportunity.
And the approach is so minimal on the equity components that we are worried about what it says about California's commitment to ensuring that our accountability system really focuses on equity and closing achievement gaps.
And we're not the only ones worried.
We're starting to see fatigue in the field and they can't give up either.
We want this system to work and we're working on it together.
So please give us faith.
Thank you.
Samantha Tran with Children Now and I just want to say how grateful I am for board member Ortiz-Lacombe and board member Rucker's comments.
I think over the last 111 days we have fully embraced that idea that we do not have a civil rights backstop at the federal level.
That California is going to have to be our own equity
guardian, and we could choose to treat the ESSA plan like a compliance exercise, or like we advise school districts, we can clearly articulate what we value, what our vision is.
And in many respects, the plan touches on things that we care about.
Flexibility and continuous improvement are talked about.
We're talking about collaboration and capacity building, and those are important.
But at each turn where equity can be embedded in the plan, we fall short.
And fundamentally, equity from our perspective is about the willingness to see.
Are we willing to see our alternative education students?
Are we willing to look at gaps, closing gaps, especially in the yellow, where kids can languish for a long period of time?
Are we willing, as Board Member Rucker mentioned, to look at resource issues and whether or not kids are getting an opportunity to learn?
In our letter we can't understate the amount of issues that we see but we're willing to roll up our sleeves and be a partner and problem-solve and figure out what works and what doesn't work.
But fundamentally the core question is are we systematically willing to see?
Thank you.
Good afternoon, my name is Devonna Robertson and I am a parent in the San Bernardino School District.
COPE, along with a coalition of African-American stakeholders, are deeply concerned about educational and equity and accountability for students of color.
As most of you know, African-American students represent one of the highest underperforming student subgroups in the Inland Empire region and the state.
Through our local advocacy, we are pushing our local educational agencies to implement target improvement support systems and to dedicate resources to improving achievement among underperforming subgroups.
By the way, San Bernardino Unified School District is one of the school districts doing just that.
We believe that the requirements outlined in the Every Student Succeed Act set clear standards and mandates to close an achievement gap through this emphasis on comprehensive and target support for schools with a consistent track record for underperformance overall, underperformance overall and among subgroups of students.
Thank you.
Hi my name is Shakora Hunt.
I am a student at Cajon High School from San Bernardino School District and I am here on behalf of COPE.
As a student we live out the rules that we you are set here.
We need teachers and administrators that will follow guidelines as well.
But if you don't give guidelines on how to make our school succeed, according to ESSA, there is still a duty to bear minimum.
If our district was full of effective teachers and administrators, we as students would have better examples and understand how to be effective students for ourselves.
Thank you.
I'd like to ask the following people to please line up.
Rick Miller, Jose Banda, Chris Lund, Steve Martinez, Jorge Aguilar, Joe Witte, Heather Ho, Doug McCray, Colleen Pagter, Patty Scripter, Allison Osurio, Shelly Spiegel-Coleman, Jan Correa, Peter Schilla, and Lynn Aoki.
Hi, my name is Precious Ward and I'm a student at San Gorgonio High School from the San Marino School District and I am here on behalf of the Youth Action Program.
An effective teacher and administrator are people who care about their jobs and not just for the money.
Someone who gives care, someone who gives extra time for students in their after school program, someone who helps their students succeed in their education.
in life.
An example on a teacher who wants to see their students succeed in life and in school is a teacher who is there to push them to do extremely well in their education also is there for them in life because there can be students doing good in school but have problems outside of school which would attend them to do drugs or or hang with the wrong group of people.
So the teacher will be there to check up on how things are going on they're going at home or in their personal life.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Antione Mitchell.
I'm from San Gorgonio High School in San Bernardino School District.
I'm here from the Youth Action Project.
And an example of a good, effective teacher to me was my old AVID teacher, Ms.
Tran, because of the simple fact that she always went out of her way for all her students.
She used to do special things for all her students, like she used to bring different people from different careers for all the different students.
She used to buy her own school supplies for all the students who needed it to make sure all her students were doing good in school.
And then she used to meet one-on-one with every last student she had to make sure all their grades were good.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm Colin Miller with the California Charter Schools Association.
I want to raise three quick points on the issue of identifying the 5% schools.
First of all, I will associate myself with Eric's comments related to the concerns about charter flexibilities in that process.
We've done a really good job of highlighting those as they relate to the LCAP and the rubrics and the policies that you put forward.
We would want to make sure that that carries forward.
Secondly, though, CCSA does put a strong emphasis on student learning outcomes, and we would strongly advocate that any system that identifies schools focus on learning outcomes as a primary factor in that.
Thirdly, just wanted to alert you that respectfully with legislation sponsored by the SPI, there is now a connection between what you're doing around the 5% and how that relates to charter schools upon renewal.
We think it's an uncomfortable fit and at best just a premature conversation to have.
As you know, we've been discussing this issue about how this all rolls into renewal.
Now we see a legislative proposal that
deals with it very directly and in a way that we have the serious concerns with.
That will make your work obviously very much more difficult if you're looking at that work also as a criteria for charter work.
So we appreciate your consideration on that.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Rick Miller, Executive Director of the Core Districts.
As you know, we've been coming to you for almost nine months now advocating for the inclusion of an innovation zone within the ESSA State Plan.
And today, I'm joined by superintendents, staff, and research partners to urge that inclusion and talk about why we think it matters from a local perspective.
Quickly, I want to share three important points.
First, at your request, we met with your staff to talk about this idea.
And the one area that they raised of most concern to them was the notion of equity in choosing different schools.
And so we want to make sure you see in your packet,
We went to a legal firm, got a brief back, and they clearly said, quote, there was no equity issues weighted to the proposed waiver.
So we feel very comfortable we've answered that question.
Secondly, we want to reiterate that what measures matters, and it makes a difference to local school districts whether it counts, and so that's why we're here today to make sure it's included in the system.
Thirdly, I want to draw your attention to our letter, which includes educators such as Linda Darling-Hammond, Mike Smith, Dave Gordon, Children Now, and CSBA all supporting this movement.
And finally, I want to just remind you that we have a data system that includes two million kids in the state of California in our system.
So actually a third of the students in California are already drawn together in the system.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Jose Bonda and I'm superintendent for Sacramento City Unified School District.
Having served in multiple districts in and out of California, I believe that this notion of an innovation zone is one of the most exciting, important ideas that I've seen with accountability.
The State Board and the Governor have been leaders in talking about local control and continuous improvement.
And this proposal allows you to live those values.
Continuous improvement means constantly looking at data and then changing practice based on what's working best for student learning.
Without the Innovation Zone, the state has limited data and no process to ensure that we are testing options and then revising our models based on those results.
The Innovation Zone critically comes with a partnership with PACE researchers to ensure that we're doing both quantitative and qualitative research to measure the effect of those additional metrics.
When you include student level growth or cultural survey results and accountability, how do teachers respond?
Does it improve outcomes for students?
These are the questions that we can actually answer, but only if you adopt the proposal.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Dr. Chris Lund.
I'm the assistant superintendent in Long Beach Unified, and I'm here on behalf of Chris Steinhauser, our superintendent, who wasn't able to be with you this afternoon.
As you know, our district has long focused on continuous improvements and using state accountability measures as well as the core measures have been an important part of that.
We train all of our school site council members on the use of the core index report to help set goals, monitor progress, prioritize budgets based on need.
And we do so because of the rich data that it gives us.
So it includes the state measures, but it gives us all this other essential data that gives us a very well-rounded picture of our students.
The high school readiness data, the social-emotional learning data that you've referred to, the growth data, the chronic absenteeism data, college career readiness data that's already built in, SAT scores, AP data.
This creates a much different impression of our school sites.
And when we've run the analysis on who are our most at-risk schools, we get different lists.
And this is the crucial piece.
The lists don't match.
You want to make sure you're targeting the right schools.
So use a holistic way to do so.
And that's why we're really advocating for the inclusion of this innovation plan.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Steve Martinez, Superintendent Twin Rivers Unified.
I'd like just for you for a second to think about school and district improvement model.
If you believe, as I do, that building capacity of everyone within the school district is the way to improve student outcomes by utilizing data to effectively guide your decision making,
Well, having data that gives an opportunity to really dig into student voice and their perspective of how school impacts them.
Imagine having two sets of data to really strategically get after how to really improve student achievement through the lens of a student and through the academic lens of what we need to do differently within the classroom.
So Twin Rivers would welcome the opportunity to be part of the innovation zone as we see it as a golden opportunity really to dig in deep, peel the onion back, and really get after a different way of really supporting kids differently within our school district.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Jorge Aguilar.
I was fortunate to serve on the State Superintendent's Task Force on Continuous Improvement and Accountability, and I serve on the California Practitioners Advisory Group now.
On July 1, I'll be joining this community first as a community member and then as the superintendent of Sacramento City Unified School District.
As a member of CPAC, I agree that the adopted state indicators are a step in the right direction.
They shed light on areas of focus that our state needs to continue monitoring for the exact reasons that member Rucker so eloquently mentioned.
But there are districts today that want to focus greater attention on a broader set of local indicators with the same continuous improvement optic that the California way demands.
We should embrace these additional measures from these districts, especially when they have been tested to count.
Surely there's an argument that we should wait and not ask for a waiver from the federal government until the time is better.
Those districts that have embraced continuous improvement faithfully through this innovation zone know that California students deserve this waiver today.
So I urge the board to support local control and continuous improvement by creating an innovation zone.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Joe Whitty and I'm a data analyst with the CorePACE Research Partnership.
I would like to call your attention to our recent analysis of comparing CORE's growth measure and California's academic change measure.
Distinct from looking at year-over-year change in school-wide performance, CORE's growth measure looks at each student from one point in time to another, controlling for prior achievement and demographics to isolate the impact of schools on student achievement.
We find that CORE's academic growth indicator and California's academic change indicator do not identify the same set of schools as low performing.
For example, of the 76 schools that declined significantly on California's math change measure, only 35% were also in the lowest performing group on CORE's growth measure.
Given that the core districts have collaboratively developed their growth model and built consensus and understanding around its use to identify schools with California's indicators rather than those used locally within the core districts will create incoherence and confusion.
It is for this reason that we support CORE's request to operate as an innovation center within the state.
Hi, good afternoon.
I'm Heather Huff, and I'm the Executive Director of the CorePACE Research Partnership.
When making policy decisions about technical design, we must consider actual data and how schools would actually be identified for support and improvement under ESSA.
Actual data helps us move from abstraction to reality.
To this end, we have conducted key analyses using data both from the dashboard and from the core districts, specifically chronic absenteeism within the core districts.
I have a couple of main points to share from this letter that we submitted.
First, we find that very few schools are low on all indicators.
In fact, only 0.24% of elementary schools and 0.68% of middle schools are red on all indicators.
Furthermore, as with our original analysis, we find that schools are often high on some indicators and low on others, which makes option one less feasible in our context.
For this reason, we recommend the use of the tiered approach or option three, a set of decision rules that prioritizes academic indicators.
Second, we show that the majority of schools are likely to be identified for targeted support under ESSA, which raises questions on what will be supported.
And finally, during today's discussion, we did a quick analysis to see how identified schools are nested within districts.
We find that depending on identification methods, schools are housed in 56 to 140 districts.
So I just want to point out that we have a lot of data that we can bring to bear to helping the board answer these questions in the crucial months ahead.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, I'm Doug McRae, retired testing specialist from Monterey.
I submitted two pages of detailed observations on this item to your electronic folder last week to highlight this material.
First, the draft plan is incomplete and needs substantial work for at least six important issues, including the four issues discussed over the past two hours.
And I'd suggest that a draft plan is not ready
for a 30-day public comment period and won't be ready until there are more recommendations, more concrete recommendations.
The bulleted details in the electronic folder observations, pages 8 and 9, show a number of the replies to ED prompts are not responsive to the topics raised by the prompts and that promises made in other replies do not have a high probability of execution within the timelines.
included in the draft.
Be happy to answer any questions on the materials submitted to your electronic folder.
Thank you.
Hello, Allison Osorio with National Council of La Raza.
As a national organization with 62 California affiliates who've been working to close the opportunity and achievement gaps for Latino students, we believe California, which is home to more than a quarter of the nation's Latino student population, can and must be a leader in this effort.
The draft plan before you, however, has critical gaps that we and our fellow civil rights organizations identified in our letters to the board.
We understand it is a work in progress, but urge the state to fill in the missing essential details before sending a plan out for public comment.
Otherwise, stakeholders will not have the opportunity to react to the state's full vision for accountability or understand how California proposes to ensure that districts and schools are appropriately focused on meeting the different needs of students, particularly in schools where certain groups, such as Latino students, have been labeled as consistently underperforming.
The plan needs to clearly address how the state will support and assist these students and schools consistent with ESSA and LCFF based accountability systems.
We look forward to being of assistance in gathering input and supporting further development of California state plan.
Thank you.
Shelley Spiegel-Coleman, Californians Together.
We are not new to the discussion of the purpose of the California Spanish Assessment.
Our organization has been working with the department and the legislature since 2012 on the Superintendent's Advisory Committee for AB 250, then 2013 on the Advisory Committee for AB 487, and then on the ETS Primary Language Stakeholders Group in 2015.
In each case, there was serious discussion and support for inclusion of a Spanish primary language test in the accountability system.
But this previous input has not been considered, nor has this item been ever included in any ESSA input session, nor brought to the CPEG.
We are asking you today to take out the language saying that you don't want it in the accountability system, put in to be determined, bring it back in July, work with us between now and July so we can come up with the best solution for how we can look at the Spanish language assessment.
We would prefer working on a positive approach and reaching consensus than having to oppose the language that you're proposing in the ESSA plan.
Please help us in this area.
Thank you.
I'm Peter Schilla, also with Californians Together.
And just to reinforce what Shelly said, several members of this board have already agreed that using an English only test designed for native English speakers does not yield accurate data for many English learners.
and puts them at a disadvantage.
This is an equity issue and between now and July is the time to have a thorough discussion about how this should be built in to the accountability system
And the CSA is on its way.
How will it be used?
And when will students who are instructed in Spanish be able to accurately express their knowledge on an English-only instrument?
Thank you very much.
Lynn Aoki here representing Californians Together.
I argue for the inclusion of the Spanish reading and language arts assessment in California's accountability system.
In this era of Prop 58, a Spanish assessment would support the growing interest and continuing need for bilingual and dual immersion programs.
The correlation between high stakes testing and curriculum and instruction is well known.
Generally, what is tested is taught.
The state has experience with this concept.
The standards test in Spanish, which was not a part of the state testing system.
excuse me, state accountability system.
For over a decade, many districts eliminated bilingual programs or limited by literacy instruction to K-3.
Those districts focused on or shifted their instruction to English away from Spanish in preparation for a third grade English assessment that was a part of the accountability system.
Let's keep the discussion open regarding the inclusion of a Spanish reading and language arts assessment in the accountability system.
The State Board has already approved inclusion of Spanish math and science assessments and this request is in line with your previous actions.
Thank you.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, representing the California Association for Bilingual Education.
First, a clarifying question in terms of whether the recommendation to not include references to CSA is going to be forever or whether there's when will SB see it back again.
We recommend that between now and July.
at the July State Board meeting that State Board and CDE convene meetings with experts, practitioners, and stakeholders to advise and recommend on how to include CSA in the accountability system, specifically to look at construct, comparability to ELA, SBAC, computer adaptability, and which assessment to take in which language and at what grade level
and at which English proficiency level.
We would recommend that the preliminary recommendations be brought back to the State Board in July with final recommendations in September.
Since when has California looked at other states for leadership on English learner issues?
California was the first in the nation to develop ELD standards.
It was the first in the nation to develop an ELA-ELD curriculum framework.
There is a will, there is a way.
Hi, Colleen Pagter on behalf of Los Angeles Unified School District.
In regards to the proposed methodology to identify the lowest performing 5% of schools, LAUSD would like to recommend that the state pursue the option whereby certain indicators are afforded greater weight.
This weighted option includes all indicators while also emphasizing academics.
Since the primary responsibility of schools is to ensure academic growth, those indicators should be emphasized accordingly.
LAUSD also recommends that the ELA and math indicators be evaluated separately.
We know there is significant variation across performance levels in ELA and math, so any option that collapses the two into one performance level obscures the results and does not facilitate a more targeted and effective intervention.
In addition, in developing the business rules, we recommend that the state enact measures to ensure that there are not disproportionate identification of certain school levels.
Lastly, we oppose the last option whereby the state would consider on indicators one at a time in order to arrive at 5%.
This option would create an inconsistent and unfair system whereby some schools would be identified for intervention based on multiple indicators and some would be identified based on one.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Patty Scripter, California State PTA.
While we recognize what was in the agenda was a draft, we urge the state board in your next revision to more clearly outline a commitment not just to equity, but to equity improvement.
As stated in the superintendent's task force, improving equity of access and opportunities and closing achievement gaps are critical to improving outcomes for all students.
We'd like to see that highlighted.
Also, as we go out and communicate to parents about California's new accountability system and the dashboard and the high expectations and every student being visible, we're a little concerned with the disconnect because we recognize that you're looking at a federal contract.
But parents, that's going to be difficult to communicate to parents the difference between this new accountability system.
That's great.
Every student's visible.
We have high expectations, multiple measures, and this very low target in a federal system.
So as member Burr said, we are a little concerned about that.
In our letter, we ask for increased outreach to parents and stakeholders, and we really appreciate that the department contacted us, and we're working on ways to translate the information to be accessible for parents.
Of course, we're looking at graduation and school end time, so it's a little hard to say, come to an SS stakeholder input session, as opposed to go to a graduation party, but we'll do our best.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Martha Alvarez on behalf of AXA.
So in the interest of time, I'll just focus on Title II funding.
We'll be doing a webinar with CDE and CSPA on May 24th for school administrators and school board members.
So we'll be giving you more feedback by the July meeting.
But for today, we understand and support the board's direction in wanting to keep the state plan at a high level.
However, we'd like to see more details in future memorandums about an opportunity for stakeholders to provide input on the Title II and other parts of the plan.
In the current draft, there's two paragraphs talking about Title II support for school leaders, but there's not a lot of details.
And even though we understand we want to keep it high level, we'd like to know when, how, and the timing for that feedback so we can ensure that the $7 million set aside will be wisely spent across the state and effectively supporting school leadership.
The other piece is we support the board's direction to continue to make a single coherent plan.
We appreciate all of the board's comments today to ensuring that LCFF is driving the conversation, not the other way around.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, I'm Michael McCormick, Superintendent of the Val Verde Unified School District in Riverside County.
I'm here on behalf of AXA's Accountability and Continuous Improvement Task Force for our more than 18,000 administrators from across the state.
We extend our deep appreciation to SBE and CDE staff for their monumental work in launching the first phase of the new accountability system and thinking deeply about how to make this a successful system that supports students' needs.
We're grateful for the many opportunities afforded to administrators and other stakeholders to provide input.
With respect to the ESSA State Plan, ACS and our members look forward to engaging in public comment.
We're particularly interested in obtaining additional information on how the board will decide the specific activities that will be funded with the Title II optional set-aside.
ACS stands ready to continue to lend our experience with implementing effective strategies to support administrators across the state.
The 3% set-asides translates to $7 million, and we're interested in ensuring these limited funds will be maximized so that activities funded are truly transformative in building the capacity of our leaders.
And I meant to be here earlier, but I had a delayed flight.
I wanted to let you know that overall there has been positive feedback from the field with our initial interaction with the California School Dashboard.
Many are starting to consider how to utilize this data as part of this year's LCAP stakeholder engagement process.
We love the link between a school district,
districts 5x5 grid and the dashboard and we suggest the dashboard be modified to include a link back to the 5x5 grid displays.
We'd also like to recommend an additional tab or column on the dashboard for each key indicator
that displays the number of points needed to move to the next performance level or color for status and change on the 5x5 grid.
My principles feel this addition would be truly turn the dashboard into a planning tool.
The accountability has certainly changed the narrative to discussions about the whole child rather than on a single assessment.
And we're also very excited about the fact that in Val Verde, we've already uploaded our narratives into the dashboard for the local indicators and appreciate the opportunity to provide additional information about our processes for our stakeholders.
Finally, AXA stands ready to collaborate with the board, CDE, and other stakeholders as we strive towards supporting a successful rollout and implementation of the new system
with the goal of improving opportunities and student outcomes.
Hashtag LCAPWorks.
Thank you.
Mr. President, I'm Brian Rivas speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
First, I want to say thank you, Member Rucker and Member Ortiz-Licn for bringing a sense of urgency to this conversation.
It feels like it slips away from time to time.
And I wanted to share, when we've talked to community groups about what's going on with ESSA, sometimes we've been asked, what if we're in a community with a school that's in the bottom 5%?
What happens then?
And I feel like implicit in that
question is what happens to us now?
And we didn't have an answer.
So I raise that with you because one of the things we'd like to see is for you to spell out what happens in the case of schools identified as comprehensive and targeted support and assistance.
What role will the community play?
What are the criteria for exit?
Those are a lot of questions that I think are burning out there.
The other thing I'll say is with regard to goals, it's important that you have them.
And we would prefer numeric goals because they're clearer, easier for people to monitor, and for communities to hold their districts accountable.
Thank you.
Would the following final speakers please line up?
Nicole Chambers, Lori Carruthers-Collins, Linda Hart, Paul Scott, and Sonia Gray.
Hi, I'm Jacqueline Nader.
I wanted to come up and speak today because I'm really saddened by the lack of discussion that I've heard today about targeted support and intervention.
Targeted support, to me, really feels like the heart of ESSA because the point of ESSA is to close gaps.
I want to thank board members Rucker and Ortiz-Lincon for their courageous comments about how we need to better serve our subgroups, like students of color as well as low-income students, because they have been underserved for so, so long.
I really want to encourage everyone in this room to be courageous as we work together on the ESSA state plan.
If we do the right thing and we write a plan that is clear about how we will close gaps for all our subgroups and then the federal government holds us accountable to that,
then, in my opinion, we've won because we've done what's right for our students.
Good afternoon.
My name is Cindy Lederer.
I'm a physical educator and I'm with the California Association on Health, Physical Education, Recreation, and Dance.
Our association continues to try to persuade yourselves and the hardworking ESSA committee that health, physical education and physical activity are crucial parts of developing a successful student academic learning.
What we would like to see is that statements in the plan
that California understands that academic achievement and learning is vitally hooked with the student's health and physical activity.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Angela De Ramos.
I'm here on behalf of California Teachers Association.
CTA believes the draft plan before you would take California backwards by establishing a separate federal accountability system that is neither holistic nor multidimensional.
As detailed in our letter, the draft does not adhere to the board's own guiding principle, which calls for a single coherent system that avoids the complexity of having separate state and federal accountability systems.
The disconnect between the proposed approach in the draft plan and the holistic multidimensional focus of the LCFF were noted with concern by some CPAG members.
And we believe an appropriately crafted waiver could garner support if it is the only way to remain true to our state approach and avoid recreating the parallel AYP API systems.
CTA is prepared to support such a waiver if necessary.
Thank you.
Terry Burns for the California School Boards Association.
And we concur with the efforts to make sure that the California way drives this plan.
We really very much appreciate that you have put a document forward that folks can talk about and highlighted in there where there's still many decisions to be made.
We hope that comes back in July.
There will be a track change version.
So it'll be easy comparison for folks.
We do for the reasons stated support CORE's efforts to include an innovation zone that we can
continue to look at new and better ways to get the information we're looking for.
And finally, we hope you will stand with us in trying to get both the additional financial resources and data resources for us all to implement these plans.
There's a lot of good things expected out there, but we need the resources to make that happen.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Nikki Chambers and I'm the President of the District African American Advisory Council for the San Bernardino City Unified School District.
And I have two sons that attend public school at San Gregorio High School.
As it stands, the draft plan does not articulate a clear plan for school improvement.
ESSA requires accountability systems and improvement plans for schools that are identified for comprehensive support and improvement or targeted support and improvement.
These schools are supposed to receive technical assistance.
So the plan must define the criteria that schools must reach before they stop receiving that assistance.
And they must also describe how interventions will be escalated in those cases where schools do not show the improvement.
The plan should also define how it will focus on struggling subgroups.
It's been mentioned here, African-American students, Latino students.
But also, I'd like to point out, we also need to keep in mind our special education students.
As a parent of a student with autism, I know how those early interventions can make a difference.
When my son was first diagnosed with autism, they told him he wouldn't do anything.
He just made honor roll last week.
Hi, good afternoon.
My name is Lori Carruthers-Collins and I'm a community member in the San Bernardino City and I'm here with COPE Inland Valley Advocacy Group.
As an advocacy group, we believe that the ESSA plan does not provide enough guidance in the area of targeted support and improvement for districts to identify and support schools with chronically underperforming subgroups.
The plan does describe a multi-tiered support that county superintendents, the CCEE and the CDE will coordinate to provide differentiated assistance and intensive intervention.
The plan describes a number of potent possible interventions, but does not provide concrete guidance, which seems to suggest that LEAs will be responsible for determining their own targeted support plan, i.e.
flexibility.
We are concerned that the lack of clear direction lets LEAs off the hook for making any meaningful progress toward improving achievement.
So the level of guidance you provide is critically important.
Thank you.
Chair, members of the board, my name is Linda Hart.
I am the Executive Director of the African American Mental Health Coalition and here in partnership with COPE from San Bernardino.
The draft plan does not articulate the point at which intervention begins.
Does not.
We want our schools to be successful, but we also know that our children cannot wait.
We think it's important for the state to set strong guidelines.
Again, strong guidelines for the intervention will begin so our schools and students have the full range of support to improve.
Seven years is too long.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Paul Scott.
I'm a business owner and a community volunteer with Blue Educational Foundation and Vice President of the District African-American Parents Advisory Council in Rialto, San Bernardino County.
Although I think 11 is still kind of high, I would like to commend the board for taking action to reduce the in-size minimums to ensure that numerically insignificant students remain visible and receive necessary services.
Thank you.
ESSA expects states to examine whether school districts with significant numbers of schools identifies as targeted or comprehensive support and improvement are allocating resources equitably.
However, the draft plan does not define resources or resource inequities, nor does it provide guidance on how to prioritize resources for equity.
As staff completes the plan, we urge them to be clear and transparent about how they're defining resource inequities, what data they will review, and the guidance they will provide for equitable, culturally responsive allocation of resources.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board.
And I appreciate the time that you're providing me to listen to what I have to say.
I am a parent of a fifth year old, a fifth grader, and a senior from Highland San Bernardino district, school district.
And I'm also a member, community member, partnering with COPE.
an inland valley advocacy group.
I understand that there will be additional revisions before the plan is finalized.
And I ask that you really consider
planning to do more to identify and articulate a plan for comprehensive and targeted support and improvement schools in order to meet the intent of the statute and to realize the state's vision for accountability for all students.
Thank you.
Good evening.
My name is Sonya Gray-Hunn and I'm a parent, a community organizer within the City of San Bernardino and the County of San Bernardino.
I'm here with COPE, an Inland Valley Advocacy Group.
The plan does not provide specific guidance how parents, students, teachers, administrators and community stakeholders will be engaged in the school improvement process.
The school improvement plan should have a outline of how this, how it will engage stakeholders, how stakeholders will be engaged in the process so they can understand their roles to improve the ongoing opportunity to have a voice as we continue to engage the plan.
Thank you.
Hello again.
Kareem Gungor, father of three, Fontana Unified School District.
I want to talk an extension of my comments earlier in regards to the dashboard and how it relates to the ESSA.
The draft plan states that it will use a color coded dashboard system to help identify 5% of chronically underperforming schools.
But as it's currently designed, as you guys deliberated, the dashboard does not indicate if a school has been identified for comprehensive or targeted support based on its overall performance or the performance of particular subgroups of students.
So when you think of students, think about your most vulnerable students, your special education students, which I'm a father of a daughter who has developmental disabilities.
Think of your English language learners.
Think of your students that don't have a voice or don't have a parent that's available to speak for them.
It also doesn't articulate a clear goal or performance growth target that the school must meet to move out of comprehensive or targeted support designation.
While the dashboard is in a pilot phase, we believe that a thoughtful redesign of the dashboard is necessary for proper identification of comprehensive and targeted support and improvement of schools.
And I'm 29 years old.
I grew up and no child left behind.
And I can take you back to my community and show you how many children we left behind.
I'm hoping you do everything within your purview to make sure that we do everything we can for our kids.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Sarah Lillis with EdVoice.
I really appreciate the conversation and members Ortiz-Lecone and Rucker, thank you very much for expressing, I think, some of the sense of urgency and frustration that some of us are feeling that in this plan and what we've seen thus far, we don't have a sense of how we are actually going to address
these historic achievement gaps and these failings that we've had for several decades.
And so we understand the resistance to put too much detail into a contract with the federal government.
But we did think this was an opportunity to really outline this integrated system that we've been talking about of federal, state, and local.
So if we want to keep it high level for the ESSA state plan, perhaps we can do
a California state plan that answers all of these questions but in a much more detailed way so that the locals can actually engage and understand where we're headed.
And I would refer you to the LCFF equity coalition which has some details to really address the issues of equity and achievement gap and we'd be happy and we're eager to work with you to really move this forward.
Thank you.
That completes the public testimony.
So I've asked Board Member Strauss to summarize, you know, for getting us ready for guidance for what the department should
send out a 30-day comment.
So, Kirk, if you'll come up and we'll go back to the four areas.
So, for board members, so we have each of us, some of us have held our comments and many of us have more comments.
So, what we're going to try to do to focus is the department needs direction on how to send the draft out for public comment.
So, let me just say,
After we have our discussion, I'm intending to make a motion to move the draft out for the first required legal 30-day come up.
But before we do that, we need to have a discussion on the four areas that the department's asked us to give specific direction on.
And then in addition to that, we want to have any clarifying questions or additional data runs or things we want to ask the department to bring back to us for our July meeting.
So if that helps to organize it, you have the, Kirk, you know the slide that has the four that starts off with the Spanish language assessment?
That one with the four things that you've asked for direction on.
So that's how we want to organize our comments just to help get for us as a board to give direction to the staff and see if we can come to consensus on that.
Nope.
Let's just be after that, I think maybe.
Under number one, identification of schools.
Okay, that one.
Yeah, those four things.
So, yeah, because on mine, so do we want to go in the order of that?
I was actually going to start with this Spanish.
You want to start with identification of schools?
What's easier?
Okay, well, so I was going to actually
I don't know why my list is reversed.
I was going to start with the Spanish language assessments and actually just listening to the comments and discussion and concerns.
I would like to put up to see if we have agreement among the board.
If we can pull that out and ask for the departments already said that they would meet with the special people with expertise in the area Spanish language assessment to discuss the issues and then bring it back to us for recommendation once the group has had a time to talk about it.
and let's see if we have agreement on that.
That's one thing that I am, that we, let's talk about that piece and see if we have agreement.
So any comment or suggestion on that one?
Well, these are just each area.
I'll include it once we come to each one, right?
So is that, that's one proposal I have, but we, but we're not saying, we'd like to talk about it, but after they've done some recommendations and discussion, is that right?
Okay.
So the next one is the establishment of long-term goals.
So how are we feeling about the discussion of long-term goals?
We had a lot of input on that.
Do we have any recommendations or areas that we want to recommend?
Either we leave it till the next time or do we want to direct comments in this area?
Do we want to ask the, what do we want to ask CD to do in the area of long-term goals?
So when this goes out to public for public comment for 30 days, what is going out?
Is it what we saw today?
That is what is going out, just what's there now.
And then when we come back in July, we'll have a more in-depth discussion about some of the comments heard here and from public comment, some data simulations.
But what is going out for public comment is just the draft that we saw.
Is that correct?
Take a look at it, unless you make a specific amendment.
Just to clarify, if an amendment, if there's consensus around an amendment, I'm hearing Eileen Strauss say that you'll encompass that in some final motion here to send out.
Before it goes out.
Yeah.
So the question is, do we want to do anything on the area?
That's an area that you asked us for direction on, Cara, correct?
And so as it is, it will be brought to us in July for once you've gotten feedback, you're going to come back.
If we don't do anything and we leave the draft the way it is, then you'll be coming back in July with a recommendation on long-term goals based on input.
Is that correct?
Okay, so board members, do we want any discussion on that?
Do you want CD to make any changes before it goes out?
Or are we okay with them bringing back recommendations for long-term goals to our July meeting without any steps before that?
Yep.
I think for me on my end, it would, it would need so much to, so much added that is not currently here.
And, you know, for me right now, what's going out for public comment would not really elicit the comments that we would want because we're giving them very little to comment on.
And so I will wait to see what comes back in July, given the feedback that was here.
I think that data should drive this conversation.
I think that models should drive the conversation.
But at this point, we would have to fill in so much that I don't know that we could capture all of that with an amendment.
On my end, at least.
Well, I'm concerned that the draft would rely on
feedback from the public on this particular issue to frame or even shape what the revision would look like.
Because I'm hoping I was emphatic enough in the feedback I gave today to assure you that in my opinion, this needs to be revised, that it's insufficient.
And so I'm concerned that we're sending out a draft
on that contains content on one of the most important sections of this plan that's already insufficient.
And we're asking the public to comment on something that's already insufficient.
And I'm not really sure that what we will see in July will be sufficient either.
So what would you like to see in it?
I mean, we can't, that's, I mean, this is, yeah, we need, what would be sufficient for them to react?
So the presentation that you did for us on this long-term goal, interim goal piece where you did the five by fives and you had a lot more verbiage in our presentation that's in the plan.
What about if you took your recommendation, the one you've been offering up today, and put more meat on that like you did for this presentation and take that out to the public comment?
Because that was a good presentation.
I mean, everybody here understood that.
And that might give you more feedback that was useful.
So, you know, embellish what you've already got in there.
So I see around, we see heads shaking.
That would be helpful.
OK.
All right.
So then the next one on the annual measurement of achievement on the 95 percent participation rate.
Do we have any direction of any modification you want before it goes out or any extra research we want during that time before it comes back to us in July on that area?
So I see no comment on that piece.
On the identification of schools, I'll just start off by saying earlier in our conversation during the presentation and before public comment, we talked about a need for some data runs to help us make some decisions.
I think member Ortiz-Lincoln and Rucker talked about that.
And I think it would help us make an informed decision if we understood how you were, if you go back to some of that discussion and comments before.
So
What I would like is some options in July.
I don't know if you'll have it in time for CPAC.
It would be nice, but I know it's an early June meeting.
I think like the first.
But some identification of schools by different data runs to help us make a decision based on those options would be helpful.
That'd be one proposal, but Member Rucker's got a comment as well and maybe some of my colleagues do.
And I heard distinctly the
making some data simulations on identifying districts versus schools.
Yes.
I was trying to think of the options.
Remember, you had these options like the tiered option.
From the standpoint, if we identify districts first, how does that change your thinking about the options, if at all?
because you were going right, you had a school, direct school paradigm.
So if you go through the district, it seems to me, and you might have to list alternatives.
I know the field doesn't like alternatives, but, you know, you could lay out alternatives as well.
I think we're at a stage where it, you know, the idea that because people don't want to, people only want to react to a specific thing, but it may be we need alternatives in some of these areas.
that we've talked about as well.
So some of this we bring back in July for the stakeholder input.
We make sure that the questions that we go out with stakeholders is this getting feedback on the idea of identifying districts.
But you're also going to do some data runs to help us in July tell us what the differences would be as well.
So let me just ask my colleagues because we do have each of us probably want to make some comments generally certainly from what I heard and I have a few things.
Do we have any more on the identification of schools before I make the motion?
Member Holliday.
Pardon me.
Yeah.
The multiple indicators that the parents in a district and individual school site look at to have a broader understanding of where they're being successful and where there are holes and gaps and how to improve student achievement is the California way and is incredibly helpful.
However, when it comes down to singling out
districts or schools who are low performing in terms of subgroups, closing the achievement gap.
The emphasis is on academic performance and not on school climate.
Now school climate, for example, you know, one of the other indicators.
So I tend to think that a tiered approach probably
makes more sense in that we're really looking at academic success or lack thereof.
And that doesn't, I don't see that as going against what we're doing in California, but I sort of see it as a bottom line for drawing lines if we have to.
So I'm just so we can give direction on after these four things that we've just talked about.
There are some other things my guess is some of us might be thinking or may not.
So you have enough to I'm going to make a motion in a minute, but I want to give all of us a chance to add any comments generally.
So maybe I don't know if this is a good idea.
I mean, we just go around and everyone gets a chance to who wants to since member Holliday, we'll start with you.
Okay, great.
I do know that this was a very small percentage of the overall California budget, but as someone who used to run a small school, the Title I money was really important and it allowed me to find the funding to
try some innovative approach or to hire this extra person, this extra services, I think Member Rucker said.
So, you know, I don't think we should dismiss this exercise.
That being said,
for the five plus years that I've sat here, I thought everything that we've been doing has been with the goal of closing the achievement gap and that all of these steps that we've taken are trying to help districts and parents and schools through the LCAP process and through rigorous standards to have academic excellence for every child.
We don't just identify the bottom five.
We identify a broad spectrum of academic success or lack thereof.
And we look at all subgroups.
So I just hope that the tone, if there can be a tone in the contract, right?
The tone of this ESSA plan is that we care, we're doing more than
The ESSA plan actually asked for.
We are committed to closing the achievement gap and equity.
And I kind of agree with Eric Premack.
You know, we say what we're doing and have them come to us.
We want to go around.
Okay.
Member Sandoval.
Yeah, just my comments around the identification of schools and I think would be really helpful to us and then to the stakeholders as you elicit public comment or feedback on the draft is in the identification of schools and the options that you presented as possibilities, having some data runs to illustrate the implications of those choices.
I think that's very important.
Member Valdez.
So just a couple things.
One is on the description on page 41 of the
The identification, it says 5% of all schools receiving Title I. Since Title I goes to schools, can we give it to the, can we do this analysis based on the district?
That's just a question if we're talking about the Title I dollars.
I mean, certainly the district has a plan for Title I, but I don't know if that's possible.
And then another question, I know we didn't even talk about it, but the, a little bit maybe, the ineffective teacher.
Who's going to be making that definition?
Is that a committee or how are you defining that?
So, two questions.
Member Sison.
I wanted to echo the comments of Board Member Rucker and Ortiz-Lacon.
My mom, she always repeats this quote that she loves from Governor Brown.
And to paraphrase, it's the rest of the country still looks to California for education.
And I think that that's so important because here in California, we really see ourselves as this
you know, we excel so much in what we do.
And I know that we have this very intricate dance that we're playing right now with the federal government and, you know, what we want here in California.
And I really think that we should err on the side of being more progressive and inclusive here in California, because that's what California is known for.
And that's the kind of California that we would like to project to the rest of the country and the rest of the world.
Member Williams.
It's a pleasure for me that there are so many times that I am so impressed by the board members that I serve with and the values that they have.
And this is one of them listening to everyone talk about that and express that.
I want to, I want to say, go back to Sue's comments, which feels like it was hours ago, but.
Okay.
All right.
I'm not, I'm not in a time warp.
about, if I understood Member Burr correctly, she's not trying to water down what it is we think is important in what we are doing, but rather to make sure that we are driving our values, our plan, our hopes are still out front and we're adapting ESSA to that.
and giving ourselves within as much flexibility as possible so that we don't get stuck with AYP or something like that in terms of that we don't value or believe in or feel like is effective.
And I agree with that.
I also agree, I also am acknowledging the tension
between that and the clear commitment on the part of what I expect is every board member's commitment to focus on achievement gaps and narrow them and focus on the kids that are struggling the most and make sure that sometimes when we say we want flexibility, it sounds like we're not committed and I don't think that's what you were saying because we're committed in our own plan and our own state goals.
So,
I just want to be mindful of that.
And I also want to encourage you that when you're out getting public comment, that while you are showing them things and asking for reactions, you probably do this.
I haven't been to your public comment session, so I don't know.
But sometimes, rather than asking them to react to what they're seeing,
asking them what they value and what they think is most important, what they want the effect to be, and then you guys coming back to us and expressing that and saying, and here's some more ways we've thought of that we might be able to accomplish that.
And also, I want to thank you for all your work on this.
You guys just must be exhausted.
President Krista, do you want to make a comment?
Yeah, just I wanted to clarify some of my own thinking a bit.
The establishment of long-term goals
What is really being proposed is something like we did with CST.
Not exactly, but you, you establish, you don't set 90% graduation rate or we want everybody to be level three in seven years or something.
That's the NCLB.
The way this was proposed for comment
was that everybody would get to this, it's a norm, it's sort of a normative standard of the distribution.
You know, everybody needs to get where green is.
And then that sets up differential rates, as Feliza explained, to get there.
The bottom has to increase a lot faster than the top to get the people to green.
You get large amounts to green and so you have those differential targets for different districts.
We could, you know, and maybe schools.
And in CST, this really worked.
John Mockler did a study that CST was around for 10 years and the whole distribution went from here to roughly here.
30, it was a little bit more than a standard deviation, which is something like 32 points on a standardized test.
I remember when 800 was in Urbana and then it was routine.
So every, you know, so this can work.
I don't know that it's the best system.
I'm just saying you can get there by chasing the norm, if you will, or the norm is the green circle.
And so I don't think a lot of people out there, there's a communication problem, understand that this is a form of a long-term goal.
And I think somehow what I'm...
still unclear in is how the, a growth model then will link to this.
So we're doing growth models with ETS.
So what does a, what the different growth model options have to do with leveling people up to green in the current distribution?
I don't know how those tie together.
And I'm a little confused, but that's because we haven't really laid out growth models yet or developed them.
So I can be patient.
So I'm just wondering.
OK, so moving on, I'm going to go down this way and I'm going to end and then I'll make the motion.
So member Burr.
Well, I guess I feel compelled to reinforce something that board member Holliday said, which is we all believe in equity.
We all believe in making all of our children have the opportunities that they should have and to be successful.
And have believed that ever since I've been on this board.
Actually have believed that since 1992 when we created the Public School Accountability Act.
And we're the first state that required disaggregation of data by subgroups so that those students would no longer be invisible.
So I just want to say that for the record because I feel a little bit besieged on that topic.
But I also think just for purposes of hopefully a suggestion about presentation that I think a little bit of what happened here was we do this a lot.
We sort of err on the side of too little information when we did the plan.
And to try to avoid the issue that President Kirst raised earlier about wanting to set up a contract that we can't deliver on or don't want to deliver on with the feds.
So we sort of have a very minimal conversation.
And what's lacking in there is a restatement of what our belief is as a state.
And you have, and Barb, I just want to be clear about this because the introductory part of it that talks about the California way and the glossary and all of that is helpful, but I don't think people sort of took that.
They went right to the template and then they're reading.
And the template, just like any other federal document, reads like a compliance document.
It's not a statement of our beliefs.
It's not a statement of what we want to do on behalf of our children.
It's not a statement of what our state accountability system does.
So just for purposes of presentation and in framing your questions, I think creating that kind of umbrella conversation to say, here's what we believe as a state.
Here's what we already have in place.
Here's where we think the feds are consistent with us and how we're going to move forward.
might be helpful because otherwise it's, I felt like a lot of the comments we were getting and letters were, this was their only hope, right?
In the absence and it almost, not ignored, but just didn't put into context what we've been trying to do for so many years here in California.
Member Ortiz-Lincon, do you want to make any comments?
I think I've made several.
I just want to emphasize the equity piece.
And I know that we here could all say, yes, we believe in equity.
We support equity.
Equity is embedded in our policies.
It's embedded in our funding formula.
But the data is telling us something different.
So
What we say we believe in is not being reflected when we look at our student populations, our subgroups, I hate that term, but the student populations.
And so then there's a mix match, right?
So in order for us to say we believe in equity, and equity is what the California way is about, then we see that in the data.
We see that in the narrowing of the achievement gaps.
We see that in student performance.
And so I think that's where the conversation, that's where we're not seeing eye to eye.
Of course we believe in equity.
But why do we have achievement gaps, historically, for the same group of students, right?
And so unless we're willing to say we believe in equity, but something's not happening that is equity focused when it trickles down, then we're never going to address the issue.
And seeing the achievement gaps,
It's just calling for an honest conversation.
We're not hoping to have a blame game here.
Though I could play that game too.
We're not hoping to do that though.
We're hoping to say this is a reality, so how do we move towards it?
And somebody mentioned this in the public comment.
If we don't want to give that to the feds because we feel that that would, it's a contract, then fine.
But let's put it somewhere.
It has to be codified somewhere.
And if we start our own California plan,
I'm okay with that, but we have to address it.
Not addressing it and saying that we believe in equity is just not enough at this point.
And everything else, the staff has my comments.
I submitted a list of them so they could also share that with you.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Member Rucker?
So, what is apparent and what is becoming clear?
First of all, let me begin by saying I appreciate the public comment.
For folks who came here today and a lot of people traveled a long distance and spent a lot of time in a car or other public conveyance to get to this meeting today,
to share their comments about this very important plan.
And even if you were frustrated and because you only had a minute to speak, I want you to know the people sitting up here and the people in this room heard your concerns and understood the passion with which you spoke.
And I truly appreciate the input that you gave.
What I heard very clearly is not that this state plan is our last best hope, but very clearly, while all of us in this room can talk about our commitment to equity, to parity, to closing the achievement gap, and to doing the things that provide the best services to the students who most need them, that's only lip service if it's not articulated in the plan.
And so to rephrase something that Richard Elmore has talked about and talking looking at the instructional core if it is not in the core, it doesn't exist.
And so what I clearly heard from the people who came here as stakeholders is if your commitment about how you're going to provide services or differentiate support for students or do things to hold districts accountable for the problems of failure in their high schools or in their elementary schools
If the plan doesn't clearly spell that out, there is no commitment to do that.
And so somewhere between the minimal conversation that's articulated in the plan purely for the compliance that's being called upon by the state plan template and what is more aspirational
in what was articulated, not only in the legislative intent in ESSA, but the aspirations that were expressed, not only by me, but the people who came here today.
There has to be something that can balance both ends of that spectrum in a way to articulate that in the plan.
We covered a whole lot of issues about the participation rate and whether or not we're going to sanction schools with a simple rule of thumb about not making the participation rate.
I think that's an example between simple compliance, either you hit the 95 percent or you're truly held accountable for the behavior of your district and not the choice of parents.
That's a clear example of how to balance those two perspectives.
We talked about the issue about what it means to set those high goals and looking at that green cell for high and maintained, that's a very aspirational goal and that's fine.
But again, as has been pointed out, some people have to be called upon
to do more.
The plan doesn't recognize those differences and should be articulated that some districts have to be called upon to do more in the schools in their districts where they have to do more work to make those gains happen.
I think I appreciated the statistic that we have a high concentration in many geographic areas of students of particular needs.
And so are there differences that the plan can differentiate not only for the state, but in those regions where those clear geographic differences maybe contribute to those issues.
Balancing between compliance and creating some aspirations that bring the attention to those communities may be helpful.
I'm very glad that we seem to have some consensus about the primary language assessment.
And I think it was, it is a good idea today to pull that information out because we know there's going to be this consultation with this expert group.
I would rather see the public comment on what we actually know is going to be revised than have them comment on something that's not going to be of much value to us today.
That again, that's an example of balancing between compliance and looking for a way to really bring in that input.
But finally, I do want to think through and I want you to think about what it actually means when we use this term closing the achievement gap.
I have heard this in my entire professional career.
I'm fortunate that I graduated and attended school in California and went through public schools in this state.
I have family members who continued their public education in another state, which will remain nameless, Mississippi.
But,
But I am also mindful of the fact that I was born in a state that felt they had the freedom to put on my birth certificate that I am colored, not black, not African-American.
So that is a stain.
There's no subgroup that's called colored, by the way.
But that is still a stain that sits on every single student in this state, even though they're not called colored.
So closing the achievement gap is about more than raising the test score.
It is about creating equity in access and creating a sense in their districts that they are of value in their districts by the way the districts choose to treat them and the programs they go to school in.
That is something also not being addressed.
What I clearly heard from stakeholders is the desire for this body, this state, in this plan to hold districts accountable for how they treat their students as a part of the work that we are doing to create this equity, to value parity, and to close the achievement gap.
Thank you.
So I'll make some comments now before I make my motion.
First, I just really appreciate all the people who came today to share effective practices, things they thought we should include, knowing that this draft, that it will change a lot before September and that it will continue to get better.
Particularly want to appreciate the superintendents and leaders from CORE who came because I do think
the work that they're doing to run additional data, to look at additional measures, particularly, for example, as a former high school principal, the idea of high school readiness is a really big deal.
Those of us that know that we have data at the end of 11th grade knows that's way too late in the process to really inform what we need to do to help high school kids, particularly those that are struggling.
So I think that kind of work really helps to inform our work, especially in the growth model, as we've all been talking about, and also the idea of taking a look at what does continuous improvement mean.
So those, and I don't think they're the only ones, but they represent a very diverse and large percentage of our population in California.
And so to me, we want to continue to encourage that kind of innovation so that our accountability system continues to get better.
And we know from API that it grew over time.
Those of us who live with it in schools knew that there were different calculations and different measures that went.
It didn't stay static.
And then I think that we're committed in our accountability system to continue to improve it.
And I think we've raised those issues.
So I just appreciate the department and really Barbara and Carrick and then your whole team behind you that's doing all this work and guiding us through the process.
I think I speak for all of us that we'll be anxious to hear what you get on the 30-day comment and also with the edits and modifications.
And I assume it'll be a very rich data discussion in July.
So
With that, I'm prepared to make a motion that we approve the draft ESSA plan with the edits, modifications, and additions that we've suggested.
And that you send it out for the statutorily required 30-day public comment period.
That the final plan will be presented to us in September.
We'll also be working on it again in July as well.
Just in terms of the framing of the motion, one point of clarification.
There were some suggested edits.
The first is to remove the Spanish language assessment, which I believe that is fairly straightforward in terms of executing that.
The other one about incorporating detail from the presentation on the long-term goal into the draft plan.
That's correct.
There may be, you know, there's judgment involved in sort of how to go about doing that.
So one recommendation to clarify the motion would be to specify whether to whom the board would be delegating
the final determination that the edits are sufficient and appropriate before putting it out.
It could be delegated to the Department, to the Executive Director of the State Board.
The Executive Director of the State Board in collaboration with the Department.
Okay.
So, do I have a second?
Second.
Thank you.
Any further discussion from the Board?
If not, I'll raise your hands.
Thank you.
one abstention and otherwise it passes easily.
So we will have more to hear from you, I'm sure, and look forward to that.
Thank you.
Okay.
Do we want to take another break before we finish up?
Or just keep going?
What do you want to do?
Break.
All right.
Yeah, you got to move around a little, I think.
Okay, the State Board will reconvene.
I have six.
Sue, will you help?
Okay, we need a motion on proposed consent items, which are four through thirteen.
I move the consent calendar.
I second.
Is there any public comment on the consent calendar?
Yes.
Yes, on item seven, Eric Premack and on item ten, Lorraine Richards.
Thank you.
I apologize for last minute on this issue.
I heard from one of our member schools this morning that their LEA plan has not been placed on the agenda for review.
They were told that it would go on the January agenda and had assumed that it went through and it didn't.
It's an all-girls school and apparently there is some concern about that.
I happen to know that there are a number of all-girls schools in this state that are federally funded.
And for whatever reason, the plan has been held up.
We would ask you to amend item 7 to include the GALS Charter School in Los Angeles.
Thank you.
Any comment from the department?
Nobody here to comment, so I don't know whether we can do anything with that now.
Yeah, they need to consult.
Do we want to come back?
Well, let's have the other public comment.
Yes.
Who's the next public commenter?
Lorraine Richards was with item 10.
Yeah.
Okay, well, we'll have to defer.
Just to clarify, the issue, because it wasn't part of the agenda, it hasn't been noticed as part of the agenda, so staff are going to have to research that and come back and I guess address it in July as far as either an explanation of what was or wasn't included or come back with it in July.
The reference to the item that was commented on in public comment that wasn't a part of the item needs to be addressed at a future meeting because it wasn't part of this agenda.
Okay, it wasn't publicly noticed.
Okay, so we're ready for the proposed consent.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
All right, that's done.
Okay, we're now ready for SBE priorities.
And let me... Pardon?
Waivers are tomorrow.
Yes.
So I am up to...
Item 14, State Board Projects and Priorities.
Need a motion to approve the minutes.
All those in favor?
Okay, I'm going to call down the, call down the list here.
First of all is the California NGSS, Williams.
I haven't attended any meetings on NGSS recently, but I have talked with the people that are operating the California NGSS K-8 Early Implementation Initiative.
They're finishing their third year.
They're preparing reports to the funders of that initiative.
And there's even some discussion that one of the funders is interested in maybe extending the initiative another year or two if there's funding.
So that's very, very positive.
And that's all I've got on NGSS.
Member Strauss.
So on April 24th on Monday, I was at Ventura County office for the NGSS rollout.
Helen Quinn was there, Kathy Duran, all of the people who worked really, really hard in developing it.
And to congratulations to the rollout committee in Ventura County.
It was really well attended, lots of great energy.
both the large group and the small group breakout.
So, just to tell you that the rollouts are really relevant, grade level specific and conceptually across, and it's really exciting to be part of seeing this next step of the implementation.
Okay, next are Charters, Holliday, Williams.
Yeah.
Okay.
So we were both at the ACCS meeting last month.
And so we saw the dress rehearsal for tomorrow.
Okay.
Child Nutrition Council, Ortiz-Licombe.
I did not attend, but I want to thank Amy for providing some updates that I'll share with you all.
The first update is that the U.S.
Department, USDA has released this updated meal pattern.
And if you're wondering, what is the meal pattern?
I'll tell you.
It includes information on nutrition, portion sizes, appropriate crediting, and early implementation options.
And we have to submit this plan by October 1st.
So we are currently working with child care providers.
and educating them on the new meal pattern.
Also, there is, according to state and federal rules, schools are required to provide free drinking water to students during mealtimes, which is good to know.
I didn't know that.
California, the California Water Resource Control Board is creating a program that allows districts to get their water tested for lead at no cost.
And they're also collaborating with the CDE to create a grant program which allows schools and districts to receive grant money for filtration systems.
There was also a discussion about plate waste and a lot of it had to do with some of the new regulations that came in in 2012.
Unfortunately, I think that Michelle Obama's health initiative was just rolled back.
So I'm sure that that will be revisited in the next meeting because now there's new specs or meal patterns.
So that's all for CNAC.
Thank you.
California Collaborative on Educational Excellence, Board Member Burr.
You want CTC?
Okay, I'll do it after you.
Go ahead.
So you heard from Josh Daniels this morning.
He gave a pretty comprehensive report about the professional development, which we discussed at our last meeting in April, on April 6th.
The other piece of work that he didn't have a chance to talk about is we are working with pilot districts, 10 districts, one county office of education.
They had already had a retreat together and they come together as teams, meaning the county superintendent,
In which the district is located to work together and they're using the full and coherence framework to do that work.
That was very well received and they have another retreat next week on Monday and Tuesday to continue that work.
We just voted on the consent calendar and we selected a new fiscal agent for the collaborative.
Riverside County asked to be excused from that obligation.
And I just want to express our appreciation to Marin County Superintendent and the County Office of Education who stepped up to be the fiscal agent for the collaborative.
And our next meeting will be June 8th.
CTC Strauss.
So, thanks to Leilani Agonado, who is our staff person aligned.
She was at the last meeting.
Again, I think two items worth sharing with everyone.
While there's no finalization, there's a lot of talk about the Ed Specialist credential in light of a couple things.
One, our Common Core.
Two, the shortage of teachers.
The idea of whether we should continue to have different designations in the Ed Specialist or whether they should be able to deal with a variety of learning disabilities.
So a lot of discussion about that and about fieldwork requirements.
So it was extensive on fieldwork requirements for credentialing, many of which we've all, several of us have done.
So there'll be more discussion about this, no finalization, but I think in light of all the work we're doing here at State Board, it's impacting credentialing issues.
And along with the fact that we know we have a teacher shortage and so trying to address.
So those are two particular areas and we'll keep you updated as they continue to have the discussion and the study about that.
Computer Science, Williams.
I'm hoping that next Thursday I'm attending an IQC meeting where we will, the IQC will look over the applicants, the 70 applicants to serve on the Computer Science Standards Advisory Body.
And that they will also review guidance that they will be proposing to the State Board of Education for adoption that would guide their work.
So I'm eager to see what the Governor's May budget revises and hoping that that work will be funded.
In the meantime, I am going at the end of this month, May 23rd through 25th,
Chief Deputy Superintendent Glenn Price and I will be attending a national convening hosted by Infosys Foundation that is all about computer science and makerspace.
And it's an invitation only group that I attended last year, had the honor of attending last year.
And it was just one of the most exciting kind of mind expanding events that I have attended in decades.
And so I'm really looking forward to being there this year.
and being there with Glenn.
And at the end of that meeting, I have been invited, since it's up in the Bay Area, I've been invited by Maggie Johnson at the Google Foundation, who is in charge of their K-12 and higher ed outreach related to computer science education, to come down and meet with her and one of her staff for a couple of hours and talk about what's going on in California, what they're doing, and, you know, what we could do
to increase synergy around the expansion of computer science education.
Okay, English learners, Ortiz-Lacombe.
I don't remember us giving updates on our liaison assignments.
Well, it's on my list.
No.
Well, I gave my update on this.
Yeah, CNAC.
Environment holiday.
You're now on my list.
Yes, you should be honored that you've made the list.
I mean, you know.
The Environmental Literacy Steering Committee is really making some wonderful progress on infusing environmental literacy into the curriculum throughout the state of California.
The sort of fiscal agent for the Steering Committee is 10 Strands in that they have received a $3.1 million grant from the Leonardo DiCaprio Foundation to support this work.
And the steering committee is divided up into 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, like 5 or 6 work teams.
each tackling different aspects of this task.
For example, there is a work team that I'm on that is helping districts understand how they can rewrite their LCAPs in a way that infuses environmental literacy into the curriculum and all sorts of other work teams.
There's a great deal of energy for this and a great deal of hope for this because of two things.
One, first of all, we know for a fact that when.
But when content is environmentally focused and has to do with the actual environment in which our students live, that they are more engaged in the work, they understand more deeply the concepts, and that they have greater student achievement.
I have experienced this at a very personal level with my own organization with whom I work.
And also because the Environmental Literacy Steering Committee, I don't mean to sound like a broken record, is really committed to equity.
And the fact is that in the past, sometimes environmental literacy has been seen as an add-on and something that only the more affluent have the time and energy for, when in reality, environmental literacy
is incredibly important for all populations in all schools throughout California.
I'm very proud of the work that they're doing.
Thank you for letting me speak to that.
Interesting, yeah.
Health.
Oh, okay.
We're back to English learners, right?
Yes, my apologies.
Sometimes I get both of my roles confused and I'm like, what do I report on?
So for the ELPs, the English Language Roadmap Committee is meeting next week in Sacramento.
So I'll be flying back up next Wednesday.
And this is a body that has been tasked with developing or updating the EL policy, which was last crafted in 19, when did Prop 1227 pass?
1998.
So we are updating, that should be coming to the board in September.
This was, this is going to be the third of four meetings and we'll have some updates for you and again a recommendation for a new policy for ELs.
So in terms of the health, I know that that framework is coming next week as well to the ICQ.
And unfortunately, I will not be able to attend.
I'll be out of town.
But I hope that somebody is able to give me some updates.
Thank you.
That's one of the areas we have not updated.
Okay, IQC, ELA, ELD, Strauss.
I have two things to share with on that.
First, on the 14th of April, there was, we have a Common Core Stakeholders Group called the Consortium for Implementation of Common Core Stakeholders held at the CTA in Natomas.
And we've been focusing, we meet periodically to talk about how we're doing statewide on this.
And so it's really a great group of really intense conversation around areas of leadership development,
math instruction, which we know we still have work to do, and English learners.
So Fresno Unified did a great presentation on the really thoughtful work they're doing in Fresno for English learners that would really help inform.
And we talked about, like, what do leaders need to know about this as far as leading the improvement work?
And so WestEd did a really good presentation as well on professional learning.
And then we had Tom Adams talking about what districts are facing district-wide.
And then Rachel Perry talked about the CAST Institute.
So that was a really productive day.
And we actually said that we need more time just to talk about all those issues.
But it was a really, really great day.
And then the ELA-ELD Collaboration Committee is co-sponsored by CESSA, CDE, and State Board.
And we met on the 20th of April here in Sacramento.
And it was a really exciting talk about sort of what to do with the next steps
We've done the rollouts of ELA-ELD, people are doing adoptions, but we know we still have quite a lot of work to do.
And so we've identified focus areas of professional learning for both teachers and leaders and areas of access and equity and trying to look at a systems approach and also how are we communicating the messages around ELA-ELD and the integration.
and what the actual specifics of integrated designated because still not everybody understands that concept.
So we're looking at collaboration and system-wide professional learning across the state.
So there were several groups that met, one on leadership to do the next steps and goals,
One on language and literacy across the content areas, because we know literacy is a great connection across all of our new frameworks in history and science as well.
And then design and delivery of instructions, another group.
Then monitoring, progress, and assessment.
And then the whole framework complete.
So we'll continue to get together periodically.
It's a real commitment that we keep the think group with different
um, county offices and different, um, groups together.
It was a really, a packed room of trying to think through what to do next.
So we'll keep you up to date.
Um, they have some grant money to support this, not a lot, but enough to keep the think group going.
And so we'll, we'll share that as we go forward.
Okay, IQC, History, Social Science.
I just, let me just start by just saying on May 2nd, I went to L.A.
County.
They had the history rollout.
So, thanks to Michelle Herzog and her team at L.A.
County and all the people who helped do all the writing of the history framework.
So, another great excitement of energy around keynote speeches and small group sessions, really around just really rolling out the changes in the framework.
And Tom and I were part of the welcoming group of the message about the changes in the framework.
It was really exciting.
Thank you, Dr. Strauss.
I just wanted to say that the staff have planned a number of rollouts for the history social science, a number of rollout activities and events for the history social science framework.
I do want to point out the rollout event that was scheduled at UC Irvine on April 19th was sold out.
The framework rollout that was scheduled to Larry County Office of Education on May 4th was also sold out.
We still have four events that are scheduled and planned in Ventura County, Santa Clara County, Cal Poly, and the Los Angeles County Office of Education later in the fall.
So there's still opportunities for folks who haven't had a chance to go to a rollout activity to consider that and go to those rollouts.
I also want to point out that the history of social science curriculum adoption training happened the week of April 24th through the 28th.
I was able to attend the first two days of that training.
And there was a concerted effort by the staff to add some more interactive activities to train the members
You're going to hear more about that particular activity from the staff.
So I don't want to steal their thunder and their ability to report on their good work.
So you're going to hear more about that at a later time.
But I do want to say the staff made a concerted effort to be very inclusive, to engage all of the IQC members as facilitators for the panels.
There are 12.
Ten, there are ten panels that are doing the review.
The reviewers had opportunity to sit in and observe the training that was done.
There was a deep dive and a deep discussion about the criteria and how to apply the criteria.
And basically there are two sets of curriculum material.
There are the fortunate ones or the unfortunate ones who receive digital material.
And then there were others who received print material.
For there is one particular panel that received 80 boxes of print material.
There is one team that received a flash drive.
So there is a great, there is a great diversity of what is being considered for history social science for the adoption.
A great deal of conversation about what the criteria means and how to apply the criteria.
Having completed the training during that week, the folks have either have already received their material or are waiting to receive their material.
And the panel will be reconvened in July for the reviewer's discussion in July.
But I will stop there because I know Stephanie and Tom will tell you more details about the week itself.
But it was a very well attended training and there were, in general, the evaluations for the weeks, the week full of training was very, very, very, very favorable.
The week concluded by the, with a presentation from each of the publishers.
So each of the panels actually got a chance to hear
a presentation about the content and the materials that they would be studying over the next several months.
And it was very, very well received.
So very happy to have gotten a chance to participate in doing that particular activity.
As on a related note, related to the IQC, there was a teleconference that was actually scheduled on March 27th.
The principal purpose of that teleconference was primarily focused on organizing and assigning each of the IQC members to be facilitators for each of the panels.
And so that was the only item.
The IQC teleconference was scheduled and posted in areas around the state.
I sat with Stephanie Gregson at the teleconference that was set at the West End Bonaventure.
And it was just because I was already in Los Angeles, so I sat with her to participate in the teleconference.
And that's my whole report.
Okay, IQC Mathematics.
So I think the issues in mathematics are being addressed through the consortium work and looking at the next steps of what we need to do.
So we haven't done any more at IQC particularly on that.
Yeah, thank you again, Dr. Strauss.
So no, no other work has actually been done on that work.
You may recall after the adoption, there was a criticism about not only the materials that were adopted, but how the criteria was used to adopt the materials that were done.
There is some other work being done, not only in supporting the framework, the follow-up from some of the framework act rollout activities, but in many districts, they are upping
their ante on providing additional professional development to help teachers supplement what they're doing with the implementation.
And I want to remind you that the stat law in California allows for a follow-up adoption and for the content to be revised or even updated.
So there's work
that the department continues to do not only with the current publication, but also with the current adoptions, but also to help districts that chose to go their own way in the math adoption.
So this is work that is continuing to unfold and districts are continuing to have that conversation.
And I'm looking forward to see how that how that work also develops and continues.
Okay, IQC Science.
Any update on that?
No?
Okay.
Special education.
The Advisory Commission on Special Education met for two full days in April.
There's a lot of cross-division work happening with the CDE and interagency work.
And coming in August, there's going to be a publishing of Meeting the Needs of Students with Dyslexia, so guidelines there.
And technical assistance is a great need in this area.
And this fall, there will be the launch of regional meetings to support school personnel and parents in better meeting the needs of students with dyslexia.
So looking forward to that.
I just want to highlight two things, parent and family voice.
That's always an important part of the meetings of the commission.
And one of the clear messages that I heard from
Parents was the fear of accessing services to support students and families, especially as it relates to their concern about immigration status being on the radar.
So we're seeing the effects of those policies in special education.
So it's a barrier to
family engagement, and of course advocacy to request assessment for students in the first place.
So that's one way that this is showing up in the lives of our students and families.
The other thing that I wanted to highlight was a presentation by Yolanda Vargas.
She's a youth organizer at the California Foundation for Independent Living Centers, and she shared information on YO,
which is Youth Organizing Disabled and Proud.
And she did a wonderful job of describing how this group connects, organizes, and educates youth with disabilities.
So this student-run organization combats internalized ableism, low expectations, and it promotes leadership and self-advocacy, self-determination among our young people.
So I just want to acknowledge her wonderful presentation at the meeting.
Yeah, I had an addendum on special ed.
There was a report on special education finance by the Public Policy Institute of California.
They, the Department of Finance, which is unusual for finance, held three statewide meetings.
I went to the one in San Mateo, where they received a reaction from the field and the general public on that.
on the proposals in that report.
And so people are now considering about what will be the initiative, if any, that will come out of that.
But we've been talking with Kristen Wright and CDE and the board staff and the Department of Finance, which is taking a major role in this as well.
So that's an update on that part of special education.
Summer School for the Arts.
It's summer, so you should have something.
Yes, yes.
It feels like summer.
The California State Summer School for the Arts Foundation has hired two regional outreach coordinators, one to focus on the Bay Area and the other one of the Central Valley.
And the result has been a significant increase in applications from these regions.
And one example, there was an 18% increase in applications from the Bay Area and more acceptances from this region than ever before.
There's also extensive and deep outreach to schools with performing arts programs.
And leadership of the school has offered application workshops, a theater workshop, and a workshop on how to audition in front of a camera.
These are great skills.
And as a result, this is one example of the depth of services to one particular school.
The school was able to accept 50% of the applicants from that school.
And also, the school is working with College Track, and that's a program that works longitudinally with students for 10 years, from middle school through college.
And the leadership of the school has worked with campuses in Watts, Boyle Heights, Sacramento, East Palo Alto, and Oakland.
So there's a lot of outreach statewide, and we're seeing a very rich and diverse applicant pool and students being accepted.
Good work.
Okay.
So I have two things to report as the last one on initiatives to link the State Board and CDE better to post-secondary education.
So my first one is since Ting Sun is not here and she is the chair of this, was the first meeting of the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee, which we'll meet again tomorrow.
Pardon, Friday.
Yeah, I meant Friday.
And we have three members and the Community College Board of Governors has three members.
And it's our members are Ortiz Lacone, Rucker, and Ting Sun.
They have a very interesting meeting scheduled coming up on Friday with a lot of talk about how to integrate our career and technical education
programs better and with community colleges, what's working out there.
We have spent a billion and a half dollars, $500 million on Career Pathways Trust that the State Superintendent played a major leadership role in and then a $950 million on
redoing the regional occupation programs and the linkages of these career pathways between post-secondary education, secondary and post-secondary education is crucial.
And that's among the things on the topics.
But I wanted to say that's off and running and we appreciate the strong support of the CDE staff and we'll need that to continue to keep this going.
Finally, I,
intended an unusual presentation on this, which I've been dreaming about for years.
The... Kerrick Ashley, Tony Alpert and I addressed the University of California Board of Admissions in San Francisco, which makes all, makes the final decisions on what the criteria are for the admissions at the University of California system.
Tom Torlakson and I had appeared before the Regents and made presentations on this, on these issues.
And so this, we came with a plea to bring us together closer.
And one area, the area that we particularly talked about was we asked
the BOAR's mission to consider, among its comprehensive admissions criteria, the 11th grade Smarter Balanced Assessment.
That it would not, of course, replace maybe SAT or ACT, but it would be one of the factors that they would look at in admission and send that as a clear signal to students.
They were quite interested.
They asked some very interesting questions, some technical questions.
So, I'm glad Tony was there and really got into it.
So, I don't know what's going to come of this, but we made an ask and even that's historic, I think, in some way.
That ends my report on linkages to post-secondary education, which is something that, you know, we proceed in our separate post holes of K-12 and then there's the three systems and then there's private education in that regard.
So, it's really something I think we need to work on.
So, that's the end of our... Okay, one final.
Go ahead.
I have to revisit the motion.
So I need to revisit the motion on ESSA because it wasn't clear.
So we're going to have to do this again.
Am I right?
Or do I just revisit the motion?
OK, so.
OK, so I'm clarifying the motion on ESSA, OK, with much better language this time.
OK, so I move that we approve the initial draft of the state plan to go out for public comment, but with staff to first incorporate two edits that we discussed.
Removing the reference to use of primary language assessment for accountability purposes.
and adding more detail to long-term goal sections along with the lines of the staff presentation.
And delegate to ED to approve, to our executive director to approve those edits prior to posting for public comment.
Okay.
Any discussion?
You don't need to vote.
Okay.
All right.
That's done.
Yeah, we're down to general public comment then.
People to address this for an issue concerning issues not on our agenda for this month.
We have six speakers signed up for public comment.
Kelly Murphy, Robin Goldman, Gretchen Clark, Heather Bennett, Allison Wong, and John.
Please come up.
Good afternoon and thank you very much for hearing us today.
We very much appreciate this time.
We are here as members of Stand for Ross Valley School District in Marin County.
We are here to ask all of you to request a material revision from RVC to restate its projected enrollment and provide an updated budget reflective of the revised ADA before allowing the Ross Valley Charter to open this fall.
RVC was rejected by our local school district twice due to the charter's unrealistic budget, among other reasons.
The charter was then denied by the Ross Valley, the Marin County Office of Education for the same reasons.
The SBE's assessment of the charter's financial viability was based on an enrollment of 222 students.
And now, our VC is estimated to have fewer than 120 students.
Per your MOU, material changes are required when proposed changes in enrollment differ by more than 25%.
As we stated at your March meeting, RVC reduced their projected enrollment to 170 children, a reduction of almost 25% from that 222 number you approved.
Earlier this week, on May 8th, the Charter acknowledged this lower enrollment.
Their CFO said that they will present two budget scenarios to the CDE for review in June.
One scenario for 170 students, the other for 150.
150 students is a decline of 32 below the approved enrollment.
Please consider the following.
RVC withholds enrollment numbers despite repeated PRA requests.
We have yet to receive any confirmation of children who have actually chosen to enroll, not who were just admitted into this charter.
The most recent PRA we did receive from the charter on March 26 revealed that only 120 students have verbally accepted their places.
120 is a 46% shortfall.
As of March 26, only 104 prospective students were in district.
That's a 55% shortfall.
Even this number seems like a stretch as families continue to drop out for a myriad of reasons, not least because ours is an exceptional, dynamic school district.
The charters had at least two lotteries, yet they won't release their accepted enrollments, even one month after the enrollment deadline.
Gives one pause.
A review of their budget shows limited allowance for essential expenses, special education, English language learners, staff health and welfare benefits, classroom supplies, and teacher aids, especially in younger grades.
You have the power and the responsibility to prevent this disruptive financial disaster before it happens.
Please require the charter to submit a revised petition that reflects their true enrollment prior to your final authorization and allowing the school to open.
Our community has done its due diligence and we are engaged.
Our stand website averages 3,000 to 5,000 hits every week.
We wrote a petition with over 1,400 signatures and we asked the charter to revoke its Prop 39 application.
Our neighbors have put over 3,000 magnets and over 1,000 yard signs up standing in support of our public schools and asking this charter to please
fold and come back into our community.
Our community is paying attention.
If RVC opens with unsound financials, you will have failed in your fiduciary duty to act in the best interest of all of our children, those that are in the charter, as well as those in our district schools.
We want to leave you with a petition of protest that was conceived and written by two middle school students.
It was signed by over 150 students from our district middle school, which is where the charter will be housed.
We also want to give you a few more postcards from STAND supporters.
You've probably already received about 500 from us, but we have a few more for you.
You risk damaging the charter movement by authorizing this unnecessary, non-viable charter in the Ross Valley community.
On behalf of all of our petitioners, please review the budget and request a material revision from the Ross Valley Charter before they are set to open this fall.
Hi, I'm Allison Wah.
Our Ross Valley School District is comprised of highly performing California distinguished schools.
Children going through this school district are being well educated.
California can be proud of what our public schools in our district are achieving.
Unfortunately, with the opening of Ross Valley Charter, it does not seem possible to maintain the same level of high quality education.
How can it?
Beyond the obvious loss of ADA, our resource strapped district has already spent over $250,000 on legal fees.
Our board recently approved spending $150,000 to prepare for the charter school's Prop 39 takeover of our facilities.
Our beloved soft entry for sixth graders starting the tough middle school years will be no longer.
And at times, our superintendent and district staff spend 85% of their work hours on charter related items.
All of this
All of this significantly reduces our district's capacity to continue to provide quality education.
The situation in the Ross Valley is a poster child for when charter schools lower rather than raise the level of public education.
One strong district will be split into two pieces, both of which will be less than the whole.
Education within the district schools will be worse as the resources have diminished.
Likewise, as the charter is unlikely to survive in our community, charter school students will suffer not only due to the disruption of their education, but also because they will sadly be returning to lower performing district schools.
Albeit oh so slightly, your decision to approve this charter will lower the overall public performance average of California education.
These kinds of choices could be how California ultimately ends up like Michigan.
A state who's standing in national testing went from the middle of the pack to the bottom of the pack since it embraced charter schools.
Do you want the same thing to happen to California under your watch?
Thank you for your time.
I'm happy to see how things are going.
I really want to hear it.